hello everyone and welcome to this how
to full course 2022 video by simplylog
in this video you will learn about big
data and how it has evolved over the
years and look at the different tools
the hadoop ecosystem has that are
crucial for storing and handling vast
volumes of data
you will also learn the applications of
different components with hands-on
demonstrations
so as the world online becomes
increasingly
packed in the wake of rivals discovering
the possibility of a rapidly
accelerating market
big data analytics is fast
becoming an integral way for businesses
to outperform their many challenges
as for statista.com
the global big data market is forecasted
to grow 103 billion us dollars by 2027.
google has the highest market share when
it comes to the search engine market in
2021 more than 90 percent of global
searches were made through google this
percentage translates to
more than 2 trillion searches annually
and over 63 000 searches a second
big data in banking is expected to reach
62 billion us dollars by 2025 and in
healthcare it can be worth over 67
billion us dollars by 2025. now there is
a need to analyze data faster so that it
can be valuable to any organization as
it helps businesses to answer critical
questions quickly
some benefits of big data analytics
include
cost efficiency
so big data can help organizations in
identifying better and more efficient
ways of conducting business
big data analytics helps develop a
better understanding of customers needs
and desires that can help to better
product development
it can also help in keeping track of
market trends and customer purchase
behavior
also big data allows in making future
predictions using predictive analytics
now to utilize big data and make
valuable decisions organizations use
hadoop which is a popular big data
framework so hadoop is a framework for
storing enormous data and running
applications on commodity hardware it
allows organizations to use huge amounts
of data from various sources identify
opportunities and risks and help
organizations to move quickly and
efficiently now with this brief
introduction about big detail and hadoop
let's look at the agenda for this full
course video so we will start by
understanding
the basics of big data and then learn
about the hadoop distributed file system
after that we look at map reduce and how
to write programs on mapreduce
next we'll talk about yarn followed by
scoop and high
after that
our instructors will make you understand
about big nhbs with hands-on
demonstrations
finally we learn about the big data
engineer role and we look at some of the
critical big data and hadoop interview
questions towards the end let's begin
let's rewind to the days before the
world turned digital
back then miniscule amounts of data were
generated at a relatively sluggish pace
all the data was mostly documents and in
the form of rows and columns
storing or processing this data wasn't
much trouble as a single storage unit
and processor combination would do the
job but as years passed by the internet
took the world by storm giving rise to
tons of data generated in a multitude of
forms and formats every microsecond
semi-structured and unstructured data
was available now in the form of emails
images audio and video to name a few
all this data became collectively known
as big data
although fascinating it became nearly
impossible to handle this big data and a
storage unit processor combination was
obviously not enough
so what was the solution
multiple storage units and processors
were undoubtedly the need of the hour
this concept was incorporated in the
framework of hadoop that could store and
process vast amounts of any data
efficiently using a cluster of commodity
hardware hadoop consisted of three
components that were specifically
designed to work on big data in order to
capitalize on data the first step is
storing it the first component of hadoop
is its storage unit the hadoop
distributed file system or hdfs
storing massive data on one computer is
unfeasible
hence data is distributed amongst many
computers and stored in blocks
so if you have 600 megabytes of data to
be stored hdfs splits the data into
multiple blocks of data that are then
stored on several data nodes in the
cluster 128 megabytes is the default
size of each block
hence 600 megabytes will be split into
four blocks a b c and d of 128 megabytes
each
and the remaining 88 megabytes in the
last block e
so now you might be wondering what if
one data node crashes
do we lose that specific piece of data
well no that's the beauty of hdfs
hdfs makes copies of the data and stores
it across multiple systems
for example when block a is created it
is replicated with a replication factor
of 3 and stored on different data nodes
this is termed the replication method
by doing so data is not lost at any cost
even if one data node crashes making
hdfs fault tolerant after storing the
data successfully it needs to be
processed
this is where the second component of
hadoop mapreduce comes into play
in the traditional data processing
method entire data would be processed on
a single machine having a single
processor this consumed time and was
inefficient especially when processing
large volumes of a variety of data to
overcome this mapreduce splits data into
parts and processes each of them
separately on different data nodes
the individual results are then
aggregated to give the final output
let's try to count the number of
occurrences of words taking this example
first the input is split into five
separate parts based on full stops
the next step is the mapper phase where
the occurrence of each word is counted
and allocated a number
after that depending on the words
similar words are shuffled sorted and
grouped following which in the reducer
phase all the grouped words are given a
count
finally the output is displayed by
aggregating the results all this is done
by writing a simple program
similarly mapreduce processes each part
of big data individually and then sums
the result at the end
this improves load balancing and saves a
considerable amount of time
now that we have our mapreduce job ready
it is time for us to run it on the
hadoop cluster
this is done with the help of a set of
resources such as ram network bandwidth
and cpu
multiple jobs are run on hadoop
simultaneously and each of them needs
some resources to complete the tasks
successfully
to efficiently manage these resources we
have the third component of hadoop which
is yarn
yet another resource negotiator or yarn
consists of a resource manager node
manager application master and
containers the resource manager assigns
resources node managers handle the nodes
and monitor the resource usage in the
node the containers hold a collection of
physical resources
suppose we want to process the mapreduce
job we had created
first the application master requests
the container from the node manager
once the node manager gets the resources
it sends them to the resource manager
this way yarn processes job requests and
manages cluster resources in hadoop
in addition to these components hadoop
also has various big data tools and
frameworks dedicated to managing
processing and analyzing data
the hadoop ecosystem comprises several
other components like hive pig apache
spark flume and scoop to name a few
the hadoop ecosystem works together on
big data management
so here's a question for you
what is the advantage of the 3x
replication schema in hdfs
a supports parallel processing b faster
data analysis
c
ensures fault tolerance
d
manages cluster resources
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comment section below hadoop has
proved to be a game changer for
businesses from startups and big giants
like facebook ibm ebay and amazon there
are several applications of hadoop like
data warehousing recommendation systems
fraud detection and so on now when we
talk about evolution of big data we have
known that data has evolved in last five
years like never before now in fact
before going to big data or before
understanding these solutions and the
need and why there is a rush towards big
data technology in solution i would like
to ask a question take a couple of
minutes and think why are organizations
interested in big data why is there
certain rush in industry where everyone
would want to ramp up their current
infrastructure or would want to be
working on technologies which allow them
to use this big data think about it what
is happening and why are organizations
interested in this and if you think on
this
you will start thinking about what
organizations have been doing in past
what organizations have not done and why
are organizations interested in big data
now before we learn on big data we can
always look into internet and check for
use cases where organizations have
failed to use legacy systems or
relational databases to work on their
data requirements now over in recent or
over past five years or in recent decade
what has happened is organizations have
started understanding the value of data
and they have decided not to ignore any
data as being uneconomical now we can
talk about different platforms through
which data is generated take an example
of social media like twitter facebook
instagram whatsapp youtube you have
e-commerce and various portals say ebay
amazon flipkart alibaba.com and then you
have various tech giants such as google
oracle sap amazon microsoft and so on so
lots of data is getting generated every
day in every business sector the point
here is that organizations have slowly
started realizing that they would be
interested in working on all the data
now the question which i asked was why
are organizations interested in big data
and some of you might have already
answered or thought about that
organizations are interested in doing
precise analysis or they want to work on
different formats of data such as
structured unstructured semi-structured
data organizations are interested in
gaining insights or finding the hidden
treasure in the so called big data and
this is the main reason where
organizations are interested in big data
now there are various use cases there
are various use cases we can compare
that organizations from past 50 or more
than 50 years have been handling huge
amount of data they have been working on
huge volume of data but the question
here is have they worked on all the data
or have they worked on some portion of
it what have they used to store this
data and if they have used something to
store this data what is happening what
is what is changing now when we talk
about the businesses we cannot avoid
talking about the dynamism involved now
any organization would want to have a
solution which allows them to store data
and store huge amount of data capture it
process it analyze it and also look into
the data to give more value to the data
organizations have then been looking for
solutions now let's look at some facts
that can convince you or that would
convince you that data is exploding and
needs your attention right 55 billion
messages and 4.5 billion photos are sent
each day on whatsapp 300 hours of video
are uploaded every minute on youtube did
you guys know that youtube is the second
largest search engine after google every
minute users send 31.25 million messages
and watch 2.77 million videos on
facebook walmart handles more than 1
million customer transactions every hour
google 40 000 search queries are
performed on google per second that is
3.46 million searches a day in fact you
could also say that a lot of times
people when they are loading up the
google page is basically just to check
their internet connection however that
is also generating data idc reports that
by 2025 real-time data will be more than
a quarter of all the data and by 2025
the volume of digital data will increase
to 163 zeta bytes that is we are not
even talking about gigabytes or
terabytes anymore we are talking about
petabytes exabytes and zeta bytes and
zeta bytes means 10 to the power 21
bytes so this is how data has evolved
now you can talk about different
companies which would want to use their
data to take business decisions they
would want to collect the data store it
and analyze it and that's how they would
be interested in drawing insights for
the business now this is just a simple
example about facebook and what it does
to work on the data now before we go to
facebook you could always check in
google by just typing in companies using
big data and if we say companies using
big data we should be able to find a
list of different companies which are
using big data for different use cases
there are various sources from where you
can find we could also search for
solution that is hadoop which we'll
discuss later but you could always say
companies using hadoop and that should
take you to the wiki page which will
basically help you know what are the
different companies which are using this
so-called solution called hadoop okay
now coming back to what we were
discussing about so organizations are
interested in big data as we discussed
in gaining insights they would want to
use the data to find
hidden information which probably they
ignored earlier now take an example of
rdbms what is biggest drawback in using
an rdbms now you might think that rdbms
is known for stability and consistency
and organizations would be interested in
storing that data in oracle or db2 or
mysql or microsoft sql server and they
have been doing that for many years now
so what has changed now now when we talk
about rdbms the first question which i
would ask is do we have access to 100 of
data being online in rdbms the answer is
no we would only have 10 or 20 or 30 of
data online and rest of the data would
be archived which means that if an
organization is interested in working on
all the data they would have to move the
data from the archived storage to the
processing layer and that would involve
bandwidth consumption now this is one of
the biggest drawbacks of rdbms you do
not have access to 100 of data online in
many of the cases organizations started
realizing that the data which they were
ignoring as being uneconomical had
hidden value which they had never
exploited i had read a presentation
somewhere which said torture the data
and it will confess to anything now
that's the value of data which
organizations have realized in recent
past take an example of facebook now
this shows what facebook does with its
big data and we'll come to what is big
data but let's understand the use case
now facebook collects huge volumes of
user data whether that is sms whether
that is likes whether that is
advertisements whether that is features
which people are liking or photographs
or even user profiles now by collecting
this data and providing a portal which
people can use to connect facebook is
also accumulating huge volume of data
and that's way beyond petabytes they
would also be interested in analyzing
this data and one of the reasons would
be they would want to personalize the
experience take an example of
personalized news feed depending on a
user behavior depending on what a user
likes what a user would want to know
about they can recommend a personalized
news feed to every particular user
that's just one example of what facebook
does with its data take an example of
photo tag suggestions now when you log
into facebook account you could also get
suggestions on different friends whom
you would like to connect to or you
would want to tag so that they could be
known by others some more examples which
show how facebook uses its data are as
follows so the flashback collection of
photos and posts that receive the most
comments and likes okay there was
something called as i voted that was
used for 2016 elections with reminders
and directions to tell users their time
and place of polling also something
called as safety checks in incidents
such as earthquake hurricane or mass
shooting facebook gives you safety
checks now these are some examples where
facebook is using big data and that
brings us to the question what is big
data this was just an example where we
discussed about one company which is
making use of that data which has been
accumulated and it's not only for
companies which are social media
oriented like facebook where data is
important take an example of ibm take an
example of jpmorgan chase take an
example of ge or any other organization
which is collecting huge amount of data
they would all want to gather insights
they would want to analyze the data they
would want to be more precise in
building their services or solutions
which can take care of their customers
so what is big data big data is
basically a term it is used to describe
the data that is too large and complex
to store in traditional databases and as
i gave an example it's not just about
storing the data it is also about what
you can do with the data it also means
that if there is a lot of dynamism
involved can you change the underlying
storage and handle any kind of data that
comes in now before we get into that
let's just understand what is big data
so big data is basically a term which
has been given to categorize the data if
it has different characteristics
organizations would want to have the big
data stored processed and then analyzed
to get whatever useful information they
can get from this data now there are
five
v's of big data volume velocity variety
value velocity although these are five
v's but then there are other v's which
also categorize the data as big data
such as volatility validity viscosity
virality of data okay so these are five
v's of big data and if the data has one
or all of these characteristics then it
can be considered as big data including
the other ways which i just mentioned so
volume basically means incredible amount
of data huge volumes of data data
generated every second now that could be
used for batch processing that could be
used for real-time stream processing
okay you might have data being generated
from different kind of devices like your
cell phones your social media websites
online transactions variable devices
servers and these days with iot we are
also talking about data of getting
generated via internet of things that is
you could have different devices which
could be communicating to each other you
could be getting data from radars or
leaders or even camera sensors so there
is a huge volume of data which is
getting generated and if we are talking
about data which has huge volume which
is getting generated constantly or has
been accumulated over a period of time
we would say that is big data velocity
now this is one more important aspect of
big data speed with which the data is
getting generated think about stock
markets think about social media
websites think about online surveys or
marketing campaigns or airline industry
so if the data is getting generated with
a lot of speed where it becomes
difficult to capture collect process
cure mine or analyze the data then we
are certainly talking about big data the
next aspect of big data is variety now
this is where we talk about structured
data semi-structured data or
unstructured data and here i would like
to ask a question what is the difference
when do you call the data is structured
semi-structured or unstructured now
let's look at an example before we
theoretically discuss about this i
always would like to use some examples
let's look at a log file and let's see
what is it so if i look at this log file
and if i would say what kind of data is
this which is the highlighted one the
answer would be
it is structured data it has specific
delimiters such as space it has data
which is separated by space and if i had
a hundred or thousand or million rows
which had similar kind of data i could
certainly store that in a table i could
have a predefined schema to store this
data so i would call the one which is
highlighted and structured but if i look
at this portion where i would look at a
combination of this kind of data where
some data has a pattern and some data
doesn't now this is an example of
semi-structured data so if i would have
a predefined structure to store this
data probably the pattern of data would
break the structure and if i look at all
the data then i would certainly call it
unstructured data because there is no
clear schema which can define this data
now this is what i mean by variety of
data that is structured data which
basically has a schema or has a format
which could be easily understood you
have semi-structured which could be like
an xml or json or even your excel sheets
where you could have some data which is
structured and the other is unstructured
and when we talk about unstructured we
are talking about absence of schema it
does not have a format it does not have
a schema and it is hard to analyze which
brings its own challenges the next
aspect is value now value refers to the
ability to turn your data useful for
business you would have a lot of data
which is being collected as we mentioned
in previous slides right there would be
a lot of data wrangling or data
pre-processing or cleaning up of data
happening
and then finally you would want to draw
value from that data but from all the
data collected what percentage of data
gives us value and if all my data can
give me value then why wouldn't i use it
this is an aspect of big data right
veracity now this means the quality of
data billions of dollars are lost every
year by organizations because the data
which was collected was not of good
quality or probably they collected a lot
of data and then it was erroneous take
an example of autonomous driving
projects which are
happening in europe or us where there
are car fleets which are on the road
collecting data via radar sensors and
camera sensors and when this data has to
be processed to train algorithms it is
realized that sometimes the data which
was collected was missing in some values
might be was not appropriate or had a
lot of errors and all this process of
collecting the data becomes a repetitive
task because the quality of data was not
good this is just one example we can
take example from healthcare industry or
stock markets or financial institutions
and so on so extracting lots of data is
not useful if the data is messy or poor
in quality and that basically means that
velocity is a very important v of big
data now apart from veracity volume
variety velocity and value we have the
other v such as viscosity how dense the
data is
validity is the data still valid
volatility is my data volatile or
virality is the data viral now all of
these different v's categorize the data
as big data we would like to talk on a
big data case study and we have taken an
example of google which obviously is one
of the companies which is
churning and working on huge amount of
data now it's actually said that if you
compare one grain of sand with one byte
of data then google is processing or
google is handling whole worlds sand
every week that is the kind of data
which google is processing now in early
2000 and since then when the number of
internet users started growing google
also faced lot of problems in storing
increasing user data and
using the traditional servers to manage
that now that was a challenge which
google started facing could they use
traditional data server to store the
data well yes they could right storage
devices have been getting cheaper day by
day but then how much time does it take
to retrieve that data what is the seek
time what is the time taken to read and
process that data thousands of search
queries were raised per second no doubt
now we could say millions and billions
of queries are raised per second every
query read 100 mbs
of data and consumed tens of billions of
cpu cycles based on these queries so the
requirement was that they wanted to have
a large
distributed highly fault tolerant file
system large to store to capture process
huge amount of data distributed because
they could not rely just on one server
even if that had multiple disks stacked
up that was not an efficient choice what
would happen if this particular machine
failed what would happen if the whole
server was down so they needed a
distributed storage
and a distributed computing environment
they needed something which can be
highly fault tolerant right so this was
the requirement which google had and the
solution which came out as a result was
gfs google file system now let's look at
how gfs works so normally in any
particular linux system or linux server
you would have a file system you would
have set up processes you would have set
up files and directories which could
store the data gfs was different so to
facilitate gfs which could store huge
amount of data there was an architecture
an architecture which had one master and
multiple chunk servers or you could say
slave servers or slave machines
master machine was to contain metadata
was to contain data about data when we
say metadata we are talking about
information about data and then you have
the chunk servers or the slave machines
which could be storing data in a
distributed fashion now any client or an
api or an application which would want
to read the data would first contact the
master server it would contact the
machine where the master process was
running and client would place a request
of reading the data or showing an
interest of reading the data internally
what it is doing is it is requesting for
metadata your api or an application
would want to know from where it can
read the data master server which has
metadata whether that is in ram or disk
we can discuss that later but then
master server would have the metadata
and it would know which are the chunk
servers or the slave machines where the
data was stored in a distributed fashion
master would respond back with the
metadata information to the client and
then client could use that information
to read or write to these slave machines
where actually the data was stored now
this is what the process or set of
processes work together to make gfs so
when you say a chunk server we would
basically have the files getting divided
into fixed size chunks now how would
they get divided so there would be some
kind of chunk size or a block size which
would determine that if the file is
bigger than the pre-decided chunk size
then it would be split into smaller
chunks and be distributed across the
chunk servers or the slave machines if
the file was smaller then it would still
use one chunk or a block to get stored
on the underlying slave machines so
these junk servers or slave machines are
the ones which actually store the data
on local disks as your linux files
client which is interacting with master
for metadata and then interacting with
junk servers for read write operations
would be the one which would be
externally connecting to the cluster so
this is how it would look so you have a
master which would obviously be
receiving some kind of heartbeats from
the chunk servers to know their status
and receive information in the form of
packets which would let the master know
which machines were available for
storage which machines already had data
and master would build up the metadata
within itself the files would be broken
down into chunks for example we can look
at file one it is broken down into chunk
one and chunk two and file two has one
chunk which is one portion of it and
then you have file two reciting on some
other chunk server which also lets us
know that there is some kind of auto
replication for this file system right
and the data which is getting stored in
the chunk could have a data of 64 mb now
that chunk size could be changed based
on the data size but google file system
had the basic size of the chunk as 64 mb
each chunk would be replicated on
multiple servers the default replication
was 3 and that could again be increased
or decreased as per requirement this
would also mean that if a particular
slave machine or a chunk server would
die or would get killed or would crash
there would never be any data loss
because a replica of data residing on
the failed machine would still be
available on some other slave server
chunk server or slave machine now this
helped google to store and process huge
volumes of data in a distributed manner
and does have a fault tolerant
distributed scalable storage which could
allow them to store a huge amount of
data now that was just one example which
actually led to the solution which today
we call as hadoop now when we talk about
big data here i would like to ask you
some questions that if we were talking
about the rdbms case take an example of
something like nasa which was working on
a a project called set eye search of
extraterrestrial intelligence now this
was a project where they were looking
for a solution to take care of their
problem the problem was that they would
roughly send some waves in space capture
those waves back and then analyze this
data to find if there was any
extraterrestrial object in space now
they had two options for it they could
either have a huge server built which
could take care of storing the data and
processing it or they could go for
volunteer computing now volunteer
computing basically means that you could
have a lot of people volunteering and
being part of this project and what they
would in turn do is they would be
donating their ram and storage from
their machines when they are not using
it how would that happen basically
download some kind of patch on their
machine which would run as a screen
saver and if the user is not using his
machine some portion of data could be
transferred to these machines for
intermittent storage and processing
using ram now this sounds very
interesting and this sounds very easy
however it would have its own challenges
right think about security think about
integrity but those those problems are
not bigger as much as is the requirement
of bandwidth and this is the same thing
which happens in rdbms if you would have
to move data from archived solution to
the processing layer that would consume
huge amount of bandwidth big data brings
its own challenges
huge amount of data is getting generated
every day now the biggest challenge is
storing this huge volume of data and
especially when this data is getting
generated with a lot of variety where it
can have different kind of formats where
it could be viral it could be having a
lot of value and nobody has looked into
the veracity of data but the primary
problem would be handling this huge
volume of data variety of the data would
bring in challenges of storing it in
legacy systems if processing of the data
was required now here again i would
suggest you need to think what is the
difference between reading a data and
processing a data so reading might just
mean bringing in the data from disk and
doing some io operations and processing
would mean reading the data probably
doing some transformations on it
extracting some useful information from
it and then storing it in the same
format or probably in a different format
so processing this massive volume of
data is the second challenge
organizations don't just store their big
data they would eventually want to use
it to process it to gather some insights
now processing and extracting insights
from big data would take huge amount of
time unless and until there was an
efficient solution to handle and process
this big data securing the data that's
again a concern for organizations right
encryption of big data is difficult to
perform if you would think about
different compression mechanisms then
that would also mean decompressing of
data which would also mean that you
could take a hit on the cpu cycles or on
disk usage providing user authentication
for every team member now that could
also be dangerous so that led to hadoop
as a solution so big data brings its own
challenges big data brings its own
benefits and here we have a solution
which is hadoop now what is hadoop it's
a open source framework for storing data
and running applications on clusters of
commodity hardware hadoop is an open
source framework and before we discuss
on two main components of hadoop it
would be good to look into the link
which i was suggesting earlier that is
companies using hadoop and any person
who would be interested in learning big
data should start somewhere here where
you could list down different companies
what kind of setup they have why are
they having hadoop what kind of
processing they are doing and how are
they using these so called hadoop
clusters to process and in fact store
capture and process huge amount of data
another link which i would suggest is
looking at different distributions
of hadoop any person who is interested
in learning in big data should know
about different distributions of hadoop
now in linux we have different
distributions like ubuntu centos red hat
susie debian in the same way you have
different distributions of hadoop which
we can look on the wiki page and this is
the link which talks about products that
include apache hadoop or derivative
works and commercial support which
basically means that apache hadoop the
sole products that can be called a
release of apache hadoop come from
apache.org that's an open source
community and then you have various
vendor-specific distributions like
amazon web services you have cloud era
you have hortonworks you have ibm's big
inside you have mapper all these are
different distributions of hadoop so
basically all of these vendor-specific
distributions are depending on using on
core apache hadoop in brief we can say
that these are the vendors which take up
the apache hadoop package it within a
cluster management solution so that
users who intend to use apache hadoop
would not have difficulties of setting
up a cluster setting up a framework they
could just use a vendor-specific
distribution with its cluster
installation solutions cluster
management solution and easily plan
deploy install and manage your cluster
so look into this link which talks about
different distributions of hadoop coming
back what is hadoop hadoop is a open
source framework for storing huge amount
of data and processing it it also
depends on commodity machines and it
does not need carrier class hardware now
when we say commodity machines we are
still talking about machines which are
higher than a basic laptop or a basic
server but then they are not at the
level of a carrier class hardware and
costing huge to the organization hadoop
as a framework has two main components
or i would say two processing layers it
has a storage layer which is called hdfs
hadoop distributed file system and it
has a processing layer which is called
yarn which can handle different
processing frameworks in which hadoop
map reduce is the oldest most mature and
most evolved processing framework sdfs
derives its existence from gfs it solves
the issue of storing huge amount of data
in a distributed fashion and mapreduce
is a programming model which allows to
process data which is distributed across
a cluster we will learn on sdfs and
mapreduce in
further slides sdfs is a storage layer
now compare your laptop compare your
desktop that also has a processing layer
and a storage layer your disks are your
storage layer your ram and cpu core is
your processing layer similarly hadoop
as a solution has a storage layer that
is a distributed file system which can
store
huge amount of data in multiple machines
instead of a single machine or a single
server which basically makes it highly
reliable highly fault tolerant and
distributed for parallel processing
consider a data file of size one
gigabyte now if that was getting stored
in one single machine we would still
have the data getting stored in one or
multiple disks and if you would try to
read the data the seek time time taken
to read the data would be very high in
comparison to reading it from multiple
machines now sdfs like your gfs divides
the file into smaller chunks and stores
the data across the hadoop cluster in
previous versions of hadoop the default
block size was 64 mb however from hadoop
version 2 onwards the block size is 128
mb now that's customizable depending on
the average
size of the data which is coming into
the cluster the block size can be
changed the minimum block size is 128 mb
which basically means that every file
which is less than or equal to 128 mb
would use one block and any file which
goes beyond the size of block will use
multiple blocks and these blocks would
be residing on the underlying slave
machines files are automatically split
by hadoop framework into blocks of
default block size and stored across the
cluster each node in your hadoop cluster
would have a bunch of disks that would
be storing these blocks now once we have
the data stored in a distributed fashion
that also gives us the flexibility of
going for distributed computing and when
we say distributed computing we are
talking about performing distributed
parallel processing on large volumes of
data take an example where we are
talking about one single machine or one
huge server which has four i o channels
and each input output channel can take
care of 100 megabytes of per second 100
megabytes of data per second so if we
have a data file of one terabyte it
would take approximately 43 minutes for
one machine to process one terabyte of
data if you compare that with
distributed computing where we are
talking about hundreds of machines each
machine having similar number of input
output channels in each channel having
the same capacity to handle 100
megabytes of data per second if a data
file of one terabyte had to be processed
in a parallel processing fashion using
distributed computing
it would take just 26 seconds for 100
machines to process one terabyte of data
in this environment now all of you might
be thinking that yeah this is right but
then what about the processing logic
that might be complicated and yes that
would be but then we have a mapreduce
programming model and a processing
framework to help us doing that now when
we look at one of the distributions of
hadoop that is hortonworks it also has
different resources that provide
security to your big data now before we
start talking on these different
services like apache nox apache ranger
which basically allow you to monitor
authorize and audit your hadoop clusters
let's also look at the history of hadoop
which started in 1999 with apache
software foundation in 2002 where nuts
created by doug cutting and mike cafella
then the cutting joined hadoop and took
nuts product with him 2008 nuts was
divided and hadoop was born in 2008
yahoo released hadoop as an open source
project to asf in 2008 also hadoop based
startup cloud era incorporated cutting
left yahoo for cloudera yahoo was then
coming out with hortonworks as a
commercial hadoop distribution mapar
technology also released hadoop
distribution green plum released hadoop
distribution and pivotal hd so this is a
brief on history of hadoop you can
always read about history of evolution
of hadoop how it started and today there
are more than 10 distributions which are
existing in market however cloudera is
the dominant one and as per recent news
items cloudera and hortonworks have
merged as one entity which will bring up
better solutions to the market
here is a quick demo on setting up
cloudera quick start vm in case you are
interested in working on a standalone
cluster you can download the cloudera
quick start vm so you can just type in
download cloudera quick start vm and you
can search for package now this can be
used to set up a quick start vm which
would be a single node cloudera based
cluster so you can click on this link
and then basically based on the platform
which you would be choosing to install
such as using a vm box or which version
of cloudera you would install so here i
can select a platform so i can choose
virtualbox and then you can click on get
it now so give your details and
basically then it should allow you to
download the quick start vm which would
look something like this and once you
have the zip file which is downloaded
you can unzip it which can then be used
to set up a single node cloud error
cluster so once you have downloaded the
zip file that would look something like
this so you would have a quick start
virtual box and then a virtual boss disk
now this can be used to set up a cluster
ignore these files which are related to
amazon machines and we you don't need to
have that so you would just have this
and this can be used to set up a cloud
error cluster so for this to be set up
you can click on file import appliance
and here you can choose your quick start
vm by looking into downloads quick start
vm select this and click on open now you
can click on next and that shows you the
specifications of cpu ram which we can
then change later and click on import
this will start importing virtual disk
image dot vmdk file into your vm box
once this is done we will have to change
the specifications or machines to use
two cpu cores minimum and give a little
more ram because cloudera quickstart vm
is very cpu intensive and it needs good
amount of ram so to survive i will give
two cpu cores and 5gb ram and that
should be enough for us to bring up a
quick start vm which gives us a cloudera
distribution of hadoop in a single node
cluster setup which can be used for
working learning about different
distributions in cloudera clusters
working with sdfs and other hadoop
ecosystem components let's just wait for
this importing to finish and then we
will go ahead and set up a quick start
vm for our practice here the importing
of appliance is done and we see cloudera
machine is added to my list of machines
i can click on this and click on
settings as mentioned i would like to
give it more ram and more cpu cores so
click on system and here let's increase
the ram to at least
five and click on processor and let's
give it two cpu cores which would at
least be better than using one cpu core
network it goes for nat and that's fine
click on ok and we would want to start
this machine so that it uses two cpu
cores 5gb ram and it should bring up my
cloudera quick start vm now let's go
ahead and start this machine which has
our quick start vm it might take
initially some time to start up because
internally there will be various
cloudera services which will be starting
up and those services need to be up for
our cloud era quick start vm to be
accessible so unlike your apache hadoop
cluster where we start our cluster and
we will be starting all our processes in
case of cloudera it is your cloudera scm
server and agents which take care of
starting up of your services and
starting up of your different roles for
those services i explained in my
previous session that for a cloud era
cluster it would be these services let
me just show you that so in case of
apache cluster we start our services
that is we start our cluster by running
script and then basically those scripts
will individually start the different
processes on different nodes in case of
cloud era we would always have a
cloudera scm server which would be
running on one machine and then
including that machine we would have
clouded icm agents which would be
running on multiple machines similarly
if we had a hortonworks cluster we would
have ambari server starting up on the
first machine and then embody agents
running on other machines so your server
component knows what are the services
which are set up what are their
configurations and agents running on
every node are responsible to send
heartbeats to the server receive
instructions and then take care of
starting and stopping off of individual
roles on different machines in case of
our single node cluster setup in quick
start vm we would just have one scm
server and one scm agent which will
start on the machine which will then
take care of all the roles which need to
be started for your different services
so we will just wait for our machine to
come up and basically have cloudera sem
server and agent running and once we
have that we need to follow few steps so
that we can have the cloudera admin
console accessible which allows you to
browse the cluster look at different
services look at the roles for different
services and also work with your cluster
either using command line or using the
web interface that is
now that my machine has come up and it
already is connected to the internet
which we can see here we need to do
certain things so that we can have our
admin console accessible at this point
of time you can click on terminal and
check if you have access to the cluster
so here type in hostname and that shows
you your host name which is
quickstart.cloudera we can also type in
hdfs command to see if we have access
and if my cluster is working these
commands are same as you would give them
in apache hadoop cluster or in any other
distribution of a loop sometimes when
your cluster is up and you have access
to the terminal it might take few
seconds or few minutes before there is a
connection established between cloudera
cm server and cloud sem agent running in
the background which takes care of your
cluster i have given a sdfs dfs list
command which basically should show me
what by default exists on my sdfs let's
just give it a couple of seconds before
it shows us out we can also check by
giving a service cloudera scm server
status and here it tells me that if you
would want to use cloudera express free
run this command it needs 8 gb of ram
and it leads to virtual cpu cores and it
also mentions it may take several
minutes before cloudera manager has
started i can login as root here and
then give the command service cloud
error scm server status remember the
password for root is cloudera so it
basically says that if you would want to
check the settings it is good to have
express edition running so we can close
this my sdfs access is working fine
let's close the terminal and here we
have launch cloud error express click on
this and that will give you that you
need to give a command which is
force let's copy this command let's open
a different terminal and let's give this
command like this which will then go
ahead and shut down your cloudera based
services and then it will restart it
only after which you will be able to
access your admin console so let's just
give it a couple of minutes before it
does this and then we will have access
to our admin console here if you see it
is starting the cloudera manager server
again it is waiting for cloudera manager
api then starting the cloudera manager
agents and then configuring the
deployment as per the new settings which
we have given as to use the express
edition of cloudera once all this is
done it will say the cluster has been
restarted and the admin console can be
accessed by id and password as cloudera
we'll give it a couple of more minutes
and once this is done we are ready to
use our admin console now that
deployment has been configured client
configurations have also been deployed
and it has restarted the cloudera
management service it gives you an
access to quick start admin console
using username and password as cloud
error let's try accessing it so we can
open up the browser here and let's
change this to
one eight zero that's the default port
and that shows the admin console which
is coming up now here we can login as
cloudera cloud error and then let's
click on login now as i said cloudera is
very cpu intensive and memory intensive
so it would slow down since we have not
given enough gbe ram to our cloud error
cluster and thus it will be advisable to
stop or even remove the services which
we don't need now as of now if we look
at the services all of them look in a
stop status and that's good in one way
because we can then go ahead and remove
the services which we will not use in
the beginning and later we can anytime
add services to the cluster so for
example i can click on key value store
here and then i can scroll down where it
says delete to remove this service from
the admin console now anytime you are
removing a particular service it will
only remove the service from the
management by cloud direct manager all
the role groups under this service will
be removed from host templates so we can
click on delete now if this service was
depending on some other service it would
have prompted me with a message that
remove the relevant services on which
this particular service depends if the
service was already running then it
would have given me a message that the
service has to be stopped before it can
be deleted from the cloudera admin
console now this is my admin console
which allows you to click on services
look at the different roles and
processes which are running for this
service we anyways have access to our
cloud data cluster from the terminal
using our regular sdfs or yarn or map
red commands now i removed a service i
will also remove solar which we will not
be using for the beginning but then it
depends on your choice so we can here
scroll down to delete it and that says
that before deleting the solar service
you must remove the dependencies on the
service from the configuration of
following services that is hue now hue
is a web interface which allows you to
work with your sdfs and that is
depending on this so click on configure
service dependency and here we can make
sure that our hue service does not
depend on a particular service we are
removing so that then we can have a
clean removal of the service so i'll
click on none and i will say save
changes once this is done then we can go
ahead and try removing the solar service
from our admin console which will reduce
some load on my management console which
will also allow me to work faster on my
cluster now here we have removed the
dependency of hue on solar so we can
click on this and then we can delete it
remember i'm only doing this so that my
cluster becomes little lighter and i can
work on my focus services at any point
of time if you want to add more services
to your cluster you can anytime do that
you can fix different configuration
issues like what we see here with
different warning messages and here we
have these services which are already
existing now if we don't need any of the
service i can click on the drop down and
click on delete again this says that
scoop 2 also has relevance to hue so hue
as a web interface also depends on scope
2. as of now we'll make it none at any
point of time later you can add the
services by clicking the add service
option now this is a cluster to which
you have admin access and this is a
quick start vm which gives you a single
node cloud error cluster which you can
use for learning and practicing so here
will click on scope 2 and then we will
say delete as we have configured the
dependency now and we will remove scope
2 also from the list of services which
your admin console is managing right so
once this is done we have removed three
services which we did not need we can
even remove scope as a client and if we
need we can add that later now there are
various other alerts which your cloudera
admin console shows and we can always
fix them by clicking on the health
issues or configuration issues we can
click here and see what is the health
issue it is pointing to if that is a
critical one or if that can be ignored
so it says there is an issue with a
clock offset which basically relates to
an ntp service network time protocol
which makes sure that one or multiple
machines are in the same time zone and
are in sync so for now we can click on
suppress and we can just say suppress
for all hosts and we can say look into
it later and confirm so now we will not
have that health issue reported that
probably the ntp service and the
machines might not be in sync now that
does not have an impact for our use case
as of now but if we have a kerberos kind
of setup which is for security then
basically this offset and time becomes
important so we can ignore this message
and we are still good to use the cluster
we also have other configuration issues
and you can click on this which might
talk about the heap size or the ram
which is available for machines it talks
about zookeeper should be in odd numbers
queue does not have a load balancer sdfs
only has one data node but all of these
issues are not to be worried upon
because this is a single node cluster
setup so if you want to avoid all of
these warnings you can always click on
suppress and you can avoid and let your
cluster be in all green status but
that's nothing to worry so we can click
on cluster and basically we can look at
the services so we have removed some
services which we don't intend to use
now i have also suppressed a offset
warning which is not very critical for
my use case and basically i am good to
start the cluster at any point of time
as i said if you would want to add
services this is the actions button
which you can use to add service so we
will just say restart my cluster which
will restart all the services one by one
starting from zookeeper as the first
service to come up we can always click
on this arrow mark and see what is
happening in the services what services
are coming up and in which order if you
have any issues you can always click on
the link next to it which will take you
to the logs and we can click on close to
let it happen in the background so this
will basically let my services restart
one by one and my cluster will then
become completely accessible either
using hue as a web interface or quick
start terminal which allows you to give
your commands now while my machines are
coming up you can click on hosts and you
can have a look at all the hosts we have
as of now only one which will also tell
you how many roles or processes are
running on this machine so that is 25
rolls it tells you what is the disk
usage it tells you what is the physical
memory being used and using this host
tab we can add new host to the cluster
we can check the configuration we can
check all the hosts in diagnostics you
can look at the logs which will give you
access to all the logs you can even
select the sources from which you would
want to have the logs or you can give
the host name you can click on search
you can build your own charts you can
also do the admin stuff by adding
different users or enabling security
using the administration tab so since we
have clicked on restart of a cluster we
will slowly start seeing all the
services one by one coming up starting
with zookeeper to begin with and once we
have our cluster up and running whether
that is showing all services in green or
in a different status we still should be
able to access the service now as we saw
in apache hadoop cluster even here we
can click on sdfs and we can access the
web ui once our sdfs service is up by
clicking on quick links so the service
is not yet up once it is up we should be
able to see the web ui link which will
allow you to check things from sdfs web
interface similarly yarn as a service
also has a web interface so as soon as
the service comes up under your quick
links we will have access to the yarn ui
and similarly once the service comes up
we will have access to hue which will
give you the web interface which allows
you to work with your sdfs which allows
you to work with your different other
components within the cluster without
even using the command line tools or
command line options so we will have to
give it some time while the cloud error
scm agent on every machine will be able
to restart the roles which are
responsible for your cluster to come up
we can always click here we tell that
there are some running commands in the
background which are trying to start my
cluster we can go to the terminal and we
can switch as hdfs user remember sdfs
user is the admin user and it does not
have a password unless you have set one
so you can just log in as sdfs which
might ask you for a password initially
which we do not have so the best way to
do this is by logging in as root where
the password is cloud error and then you
can log in as hdfs so that then onwards
you can give your sdfs commands to work
with your file system now since my
services are coming up right now when i
try to give a sdfs dfs command it might
not work or it might also say that it is
trying to connect to the name node which
is not up yet so we will have to give it
some time and only once the name node is
up we will be able to access our sdfs
using commands so this is how you can
quickly set up your quick start and then
you can be working
using the command line options from the
terminal like what you would do in a
apache hadoop cluster you could use the
web interfaces which allow you to work
with your cluster now this usually takes
more time so you will have to give it
some time before your services are up
and running and for any reason if you
have issues it might require you to
restart your cluster several times in
the beginning before it gets accustomed
to the settings what you have given and
it starts up the services at any point
of time if you have any error message
then you can always go back and look in
logs and see what is happening and try
starting your cluster so this is how we
set up a quick start vm and you can be
using this to work with your cloudera
cluster we will learn today on setting
up a apache hadoop cluster although
there are various distributions of
hadoop as we have already discussed and
you could set up a apache hadoop cluster
which is the core distribution you could
be setting up a cloudera distribution of
hadoop or even a hortonworks however for
cloud era you would need machines which
are really powerful at least machines
which have 16 gb of ram and in which you
can set up multiple virtual machines
each virtual machine of at least four to
five gb same thing applies for hotend
works or you could always download and
set up a cloudera quick start vm or a
hotend works sandbox in this session we
will learn how to set up apache hadoop
cluster which is the core distribution
and if one has learned how to set up
apache hadoop cluster then they would
understand the internals of setting up a
cluster different configuration
properties which are needed for your
cluster setup now for this we need to
set up multiple machines as you see on
my screen and for this you will have to
download the linux disk image so we are
using ubuntu for our cluster setup you
can always go to google and type in
ubuntu disk image iso file and you could
search for this
and that should show you a link like
this which says ubuntu 16.04
you can click on this link and depending
on your machine so my machine is 64-bit
machine and so i would download this
disk image which is already downloaded
on my machine and if your machine is a
32-bit machine then you can download
this one which is 32-bit pc i386 now to
set up apache cluster you could even do
it with a machine which has 4gb ram and
you could easily set up at least two
virtual machines which
can then be used to set up your cluster
now this also needs you to download a
virtualization software so you can type
in download oracle vm box it is pretty
lighter on the machine you can search
for the link you can easily say
wiki
and that should show you download oracle
vm box now i would suggest going for a
older version rather than going for the
latest version probably because that
might have some more patches to be
installed and you can click on an older
version of virtualbox and then based on
the machine which you have download the
relevant virtual box version once you
have downloaded oracle vm box and once
you have downloaded the linux disk image
you are ready to set up machines within
your virtualization software which can
then be used to set up a cluster to set
up a machine click on new and here we
can give a name so let me give m1 i will
choose linux and i will choose windows
64-bit now in certain cases people might
have problem in not being able to list
down windows 64-bit and that basically
means that you have to enable
virtualization in your bio settings so
restart your machine get into bios
enable your virtualization and then you
should be able to see 64-bit option here
in any case and later if you face issues
with oracle vm box you can also go for
vmware workstation click on next and
this tells you that you would want to
allocate ram so we can go for now with
1.5 gb depending on your machine you can
even give more ram to your every
individual machine within your
virtualization software so i'll choose
1.5 gb click on next now here it says
create a virtual hard disk or do you
want to add a virtual hard disk so we'll
say create a virtual hard disk now click
on create and then you can choose vmdk
that is virtual machine disk which will
also allow you to use the same disk
image in case you would want to use a
different virtualization software click
on next and then it says how do you want
your hard disk to be allocated so let's
go for dynamically allocated hard disk
that is as you store data on your disk
it will be using your parent disk
storage click on next and here we can
give the size of our disk so i'll keep
it 20 gb that's more than enough for
machines which will be hosting my apache
hadoop cluster click on create and we
have given the basic settings for my
machine however this does not have any
disk assigned to it so now while this is
highlighted click on settings and then
click on system here we can increase or
decrease the ram we can even give more
cpu to our machine that is cpu course
you can click on storage and here where
it says empty click on this and from the
drop down select your disk image which
you would have already downloaded now
let's click on network and to have my
hadoop cluster setup i would need every
machine to have a different ip now i
could go for nat which is network
address translator but then every
machine would have the same ip address
so it's good to go for bridge adapter
and if you are using your own personal
network every machine setup will receive
a different ip address click on ok and
you have given all the settings for this
machine now you can click on start and
this will start your machine it will
recognize the disk image which you have
added and basically this should allow
you to give settings to set up your
first ubuntu machine let's just wait for
a couple of seconds and that should give
me an option which says either try
ubuntu or install ubuntu and we will go
ahead with installation of ubuntu
distribution of linux for our machine
now while this comes up i can always set
up one more machine quickly by clicking
on new giving a different name choosing
linux click on next let's give some ram
click on next create a virtual hard disk
now click on create choose vmdk click on
next dynamically allocated hard disk
click on next give the size of your hard
disk and then click on create once this
is done repeat the steps click on
settings
system
processor let's give it two cpu cores
storage click on empty and then let's
choose the disk image and in network i
will choose bridge adapter once this is
done click on ok and just to a start of
your second machine also so we can
parallely set up two machines which
might approximately take 5 to 10 minutes
and once your machines are up we can
then go ahead installing some relevant
packages and hadoop to set up our hadoop
cluster now let's look at our m1 machine
and that's slowly coming up using my
disk image and once it comes up i should
be able to install ubuntu in m1 so here
is my machine which is slowly coming up
and let's look at the second machine if
that is also coming up so click on
machine one here and it says the
connection is established so it is using
the bridge adapter which we have chosen
and then it should show me the options
which allow me to go ahead with
installation options
here we can click on install ubuntu
it says download updates while
installing ubuntu it's good to select
this click on continue
it says erase disk and install ubuntu
and we are good to do that because it's
not erasing anything from my parent disk
it is doing this for this particular
machine so click on install now
it says if you continue the changes
listed below will be written to the desk
we are fine with that click on continue
and now let's choose the time zone so in
my case it shows berlin in your case it
might show the city or the country where
you are in so click on continue and
don't worry if it says it's disconnected
from internet we don't need internet as
of now because we have already added the
disk image so the language selected is
english us unless you would want to have
it in a different language click on
continue
and it needs
name so let me give my name here i'll
say what would be my computer name so
i'll say m1 i'll give a username so we
need to have a common username across
all the machines which would be used for
hadoop cluster so pick a username and
type in a name i'm giving sdc i'll give
a simple password for my machines and
then click on continue
so all the relevant things are done for
this machine and then we will have to
give it around five to seven minutes
while it sets up everything and then
finally i will get a pop-up message
which says restart or reboot your
machine and my machine would be ready
the same things will do on my second
machine so i'll click on install ubuntu
then we can select download updates
while installing if it shows up and if
it says that there is no internet
connection nothing to worry we can
always come back to this click on
continue erase this can install ubuntu
so click on install now
click on continue
let's give a time zone here and click on
continue we can always change the time
zone later also
once this is done you will have to give
your machine a name and then also a user
which you have already set up in machine
one now we would have a hadoop cluster
and we would also have sdfs which would
use the file system from m1 and m2 does
we need to have a common user which is
set up in all the machines which you
would use for your hadoop cluster setup
so wait till it gives you different
options and carefully select your
machine name your username and give it a
simple password
click on continue
and here i'll give my name i'll say this
will be my machine too i'll say htc as
the user i'll give a simple password and
let's click on continue now we will have
to wait for five to seven minutes my
first machine is already being set up
and my second machine will start now
once both the machines are set up and
once i get a message please reboot your
machine we will have to wait both of my
machines
are almost about to be set up and they
will give me an option to reboot now
meanwhile what you can also do is you
can download the cloudera quick start vm
so you can just type in download
cloudera
quick
start vm and you can search for the
package now this can be used to set up a
quick start vm which would be a single
node cloudera based cluster so you can
click on this link and then basically
based on the platform which you would be
choosing to install such as using a vm
box or which version of cloudera you
would install so here i can select a
platform so i can choose virtualbox and
then you can click on get it now so give
your details and basically then it
should allow you to download the quick
start vm which would look something like
this and once you have the zip file
which is downloaded you can unzip it
which can then be used to set up a
single node cloud error cluster so once
you have downloaded the zip file that
would look and something like this
so you would have a quick start virtual
box and then a virtual boss disk now
this can be used to set up a cluster
ignore these files which are related to
amazon machines and we you don't need to
have that so you would just have this
and this can be used to set up a cloud
error cluster which we can learn in
further sessions there is another option
that you could just be setting up one
machine and then your vm box has an
option of cloning the machine where you
can set up one machine with all the
details like java hadoop packages and
other relevant packages and then you can
clone it but then you will have to take
care that both the machine should have
different ip which means once the
machines are up and if you have cloned
the machine then you would have to
manually change the ip address in the
machines so either you could go for this
option or do it as i am doing here that
is set up two machines individually now
it would give you this message which
says installation is complete you need
to restart the computer in order to use
the new installation click on restart
now and that should restart my m1 and
similarly i get a message for m2 so i'll
click on restart now and both my
machines should restart so click on m1
again and here it might say you have to
remove the installation media so we can
click on enter and this should basically
start my machine same thing applies to
machine 2 so this will also say remove
the installation media and we were just
using a disk image so we have to just
hit on enter and that should basically
bring up my machine it will also be
advisable that if your machine is low on
ram you can set up one machine and then
you can use ssh related utilities to
copy the data from one machine to other
machine so let's click on machine one
and let's go ahead and set this up now
we will have to install some packages
like wget which allows you to download
things from internet we will have to
download hadoop package we will also
have to download oracle jdk which will
be used although apache works with
openjdk it is advisable that we go for
oracle jdk and ubuntu machines by
default do not have java installed so we
will have to download the oracle jdk
package until it and then setup our java
and these steps have to be repeated on
both the machines so that my both
machines can be used for a cloud error
cluster
so i'm waiting for my m1 machine to come
up so that i can check its ip address i
can update its ip address and host name
and then i can start downloading the
packages which will be needed for
setting up a hadoop cluster so my
machine 1 is up here i can click in the
password box and i can given my simple
password which i had set up for my
machine one and hit on enter so that
should allow you to log in and same
thing applies to machine two which is
still coming up so let's go back to
machine one and let's wait for its basic
utilities and programs to come up so
that we can start configuring our
machine now remember if you can
configure your machine in the simple way
and as smooth as possible then setting
up your cluster will become a cakewalk
so you can click on cancel if there are
some issues
like this
no need to worry about it we are going
for a simple apache cluster on two nodes
so meanwhile
let me also log into machine 2 by giving
in my password and then hit on enter
now in both my machines on the right
corner you might see the double arrow
marks which basically tells that your
machine should be connected to internet
and you should have no problem in
downloading packages from internet
however if you have some issues then we
will have to troubleshoot those and make
sure that you can at least set up one
machine which can also allow you to set
up a apache hadoop sudo distributed
cluster that is a single node cluster
however to have the feel of a two node
cluster or at least a three node cluster
it would be good to have two machines up
and running both connected to internet
both having java both have their ip
addresses updated and both having the
hadoop package downloaded so now my
machine one is up it looks like it is
connected to internet from the right
corner i can click on this and then i
can type in terminal
and
click on terminal
so this is my terminal and i'm already
logged in as hdc user which i had
selected in the beginning so let's start
by
typing in ifconfig which gives me the ip
address of machine it is 0.116
and what i will do is i will login as
root by typing in sudo su and given your
password
you're logged in as root
come back to the parent directory and
then let's go to etc hosts where i will
update the ip address of this machine
which is 192.168.0.116.
here
let's get rid of this
and let's say 192 168 0.116
and my host name of this machine is m1
so let's update this now i could get the
ip address of my other machine also so
that i could basically make these
machines ping each other so let's do the
same thing here i will type in terminal
and
click on this
and let's quickly get the ip address of
this machine which should be a different
ip address than my machine one so let's
type in ifconfig and this says 0.217
which i will update here so i will say
192
168 0.217
and that's my machine 2 and same thing
we'll do it in machine 2 also
so let's go to machine 2
let's login as root
let's give the password
and then let's go into etc
hosts
remove the erroneous entry
and then give 192.168.0.116
which is my
machine 1 192 168 0.217
that is machine 2 and then save it
and let's check if my machine 2 can ping
machine 1 using the host name and that
works perfectly fine let's do the same
thing for machine one so we'll say ping
machine two
and that should also work fine
it would also be good and required that
we disable firewall so we can say uf
w
disable the firewall on machine one
and
let's repeat the same on machine two so
ufw
disable
and the firewall should be disabled even
in machine 2.
so both the machines can ping each other
both the machines have firewall disabled
their atc host is updated and as i said
both machines would not have
java installed so if we check by giving
a command java minus version or java
hyphen version it will say java is not
installed which basically means that we
need to have oracle jdk installed on
both the machines or at least download
the jdk package on one machine which can
then be copied across the machine
so we are logged in as root and let's
first quickly start installing some
packages so i'll say apt-get install w
get now this can be used to download
packages from internet and we will
download wget
it's done now let's also install open
ssh server so that we can later have a
password less access from one machine to
other machine using ssh
so i'm installing open ssh server i've
already installed wget and these two
packages should be enough to begin with
we also need the oracle jdk to be
downloaded from web so my open ssh setup
is almost done here now let's repeat
these steps quickly on m2 so i'll say
apt get
install
wget
now if you get this kind of message
which basically means that some other
process is using it then we can always
open a quickly different terminal and
that itself should resolve the issue so
now let's go in here and let's try again
it still doesn't work now let me just
login as root
give the password and then let's try
doing this or we will have to kill the
process yeah so it says there is some
kind of lock now i'm already logged in
as root so i can just say
remove from where
lib d
package slash lock and then let's try
doing it again it still gives a problem
let's again try doing a
installation step and sometimes you
might have this kind of error message
where it says it's not able to receive a
lock or unlock so let's go in here
let's check what do we have in where
lib d
package
there is a log file
and we will have to remove this
okay and now
does that work yeah so now it says it
could not get a lock on some other file
so let's remove that also which is cache
archives
log file
and let's try it again
and it's working so sometimes we might
have such issues and we have to quickly
look what is the reason might be you can
always do a google and try to fix those
issues so it's trying to connect to
archive and basically download the
package we'll come back to this machine
let's go to machine one where we had
installed w get an open ssh server we
need java so let's open up the browser
and then let's search for oracle jdk and
we can go for 1.8 or even 1.9 that
doesn't matter we basically need a java
to be set up on our machines now if you
look in the usual path which is user lib
there might not be a directory such as
jvm we can see what is in user lib and
it has various other things but nothing
which points to java so
let's go to our browser and let's type
oracle jdk 1.8 now that is what i'm
interested in setting up on both the
machines let's look at our machine 2
status
it is still trying to connect and we
might have to give it some time
that's why i was mentioning that we can
always go set up one machine perfectly
and once that is done we can always do a
clone or we can copy or download the
packages now here i have the package or
the link which points me to oracle jdk
1.8 let's click on this link
it will ask you to accept the agreement
by giving your choices and this is only
for the first time
so i say i accept all cookies
and then it basically shows me the
packages here so let's scroll up and we
have different releases of eight now you
don't need to go for a very old one but
then it would be good to have a stable
one so i can say accept license
agreement and then since mine is a
64-bit machine i can go for x64 tar file
and that should download
my java related tar file additionally we
also need hadoop package so we can open
up a different browser and i can
straight away say
archive.apache.org
although you could also search for
apache releases and you could download
now this archive page will not only show
you hadoop but it will show you all
different apache packages which can be
downloaded and then we can set up on our
machines so click on archive of public
software releases and here we will
search for hadoop
click on hadoop
and then hadoop has different components
or projects you can say common or core
so click on common and here it lists
down all the different versions of
hadoop so let's scroll down and let's
pick a stable one now you can also
download the latest version and set up
that but i would suggest go for a stable
one so let's click on hadoop 2.6.5
and here we will download the hadoop
related tar file
again to repeat we will need the hadoop
tar file we will need the java to be
installed on all the nodes so my java is
getting downloaded my hadoop is getting
downloaded and these are the two things
which i need to set up my hadoop cluster
let's check what is happening in machine
2 so it has already downloaded wget now
let's also get open ssh server here
and let it install but i will not
download my hadoop and java here because
we have the tar file downloaded on first
machine and once we have a ssh setup we
can always copy the tar files from my
machine 1 to machine 2.
let's go back here and let's give it
just
one minute and it will download the
packages meanwhile what we can also do
is we can go to the terminal and we can
give our user that is sdc root
privileges so that for any other root
related work we don't have to switch to
root user every time so let's click on
this terminal and basically add our user
to the sudo list so here let's clear
screen i'm logged in as root so let's
type in vi sudo hit enter and here
scroll down to the line which says root
and here i can say escape i i can say
htc and i can say my htc user
should have the same privileges as root
now let's say control x twice and just
save it and enter so now your user hdc
will also have the root privileges and
can give a sudo command now we have also
downloaded our
packages in this path so we have hadoop
we have java and we need to basically
unpack them we basically need to untie
them so both of them have been
downloaded so let's close these browsers
let's go in here and first thing what
i'll do is i will untar
or i will change
my
directory to user lib i will create a
directory here called jvm i will switch
to jvm and then i will say tar xvf home
hdc downloads and then given my jdk
package which needs to be untied here
so this is basically unpacking my jdk
tar file which will create a jdk based
directory which will have the binaries
for my java
once this is done we should have java
installed on this machine
it's done
and let's see this is my jdk
and if you look in jdk slash bin these
are my java related programs so my java
path is user lib jvm jdk so let's go to
this directory and let's copy this path
and let's update it in the bash file of
root and my dedicated user so every user
has a bash rc file or a batch profile
now i will update in bash rc
export
java underscore home
let's give this path let's say
export path
java
underscore home
slash pin so i can give my java commands
from anywhere and let's copy this
so that we can update the same thing in
htc user
let's save this and let's refresh this
file using a source bash rc
okay now we can test if my java version
shows up for my root user and that shows
1.8.0 this is done you can optionally
also install vim which basically gives
you a good layout when you are editing
your files in different colors
some people prefer using vim when they
are editing their files and i'll show
you the difference once you have them
installed
we can always look into the same bash rc
which will show in multiple colors
remember we need to update the java path
for our hdc user so now first let's look
at the bash rc file and look at this
this basically tells you the path which
you have set up now same thing we'll do
for our hdc user so let's login as htc
let's get into bash rc
and here
i will say
give your java path
save it
refresh it
and your java
version should show up even if you are
logged in as htc so my java setup is
done now i also need to enter
my hadoop related directory
which we downloaded and we will do that
in a particular location so let's
switch to user local directory now you
could do that anywhere i'm doing it here
and i'll say sudo tar xvf
home htc downloads and then my hadoop
related tar file which i would want to
unpack here and this also shows that my
sudo access works fine for my htc user
this is unpacking my hadoop tar file in
the chosen location
and once this is done we will have a
hadoop directory created under user
local
let's look and i have a hadoop directory
which is owned by hdc user and it will
always be good to have our hadoop path
more simple rather than having user
local hadoop 2.6.5
so i will create a link
and i will call it hadoop
so sometimes you have to use the sudo
permission because you are in local
directory and then let's change the
ownership to hdc
for anything which starts with
once this is done we have our link which
is hadoop pointing to 2.6.5 which is
also beneficial if you would want to use
a different version of hadoop you could
always unlink hadoop and create a link
pointing to your newer version you don't
have to then change the hadoop path in
your bash rc every time you work on a
different version so once this is done
let's look into hadoop
and this basically has a bin directory
which has my binaries or you can say the
programs or commands which we will use
to work with hadoop it has a sbin
directory which basically has the
startup scripts and it has etc directory
which has hadoop and that has my config
files so first let's set the hadoop path
for my user so i will go to bash rc file
again and here
i can add
some lines so i'll say export hadoop
underscore install so earlier the
parameter was hadoop underscore home but
now it said open score install we'll say
user
local
hadoop
then we will say export
path
you can do it in different ways so let's
keep it simple and let's say hadoop
underscore install slash bin so that i
can give my
hadoop commands from anywhere rather
than going to user local hadoop and
similarly i'll say export path
hadoop
underscore install slash s bin so that i
can even give my startup and stop
scripts from anywhere in the machine
rather than going to the hadoop specific
path once this is done save it
and refresh it
and if all is fine we should be able to
check our hadoop version by giving a
hadoop command so we have set up our
java we have unpacked hadoop and we have
given the entries in my bash rc same
things have to be repeated on machine 2
but not yet now first thing what we will
do is we will set up a password-less
access across machines so that i can
login from machine 1 to machine 2 or
vice versa without a password which will
also be needed when you set up a hadoop
cluster and start your processes across
machines if your ssh setup is done it
will avoid you to given password of your
machines individually so let's say ssh
key gen hyphen t rsa hyphen capital p
and without a passphrase let's set up
ssh key which now has created a dot ssh
directory that has a private and public
key and for our ssh to work fine we need
to have the public key transferred to
other machine now let's go to m2 and
let's generate the
ssh key on m2 also so our ssh server is
already installed as we did on my first
machine we will also say at get
installed
we also need to make sure that our user
here has the root access so while this
is getting done you can always open up a
new terminal
you can login as root
and you can go to vi
sudo and here we will add
our user which is hdc like what we did
on first machine all
all
control x twice do a s
and enter so we have given the user here
the privileges to give a sudo command
this is what we did on machine one
now this machine is reacting little slow
where it needs to generate a or it needs
to download a package meanwhile let's
open up a terminal and let's do the ssh
key part which doesn't need downloading
and always remember your ssh keys are
user specific so here ssh key gen
hyphen t rsa hyphen capital p and it's
done
so we can check
even on this machine we have a ssh
directory and that has private and
public keys so what we need to do is we
need to copy our public key from machine
1 to machine 2 and from machine 2 to
machine 1. so here i'll say ssh copy id
hyphen i
i'll give my home directory i'll say
take the rsa public file and let's copy
to sdc
m2
say yes and give your password
so that should have copied your public
key and once you have done that you can
always look in dot ssh now you have a
known underscore host file which has
entry of machine 2 where you have copied
your public key if you look on machine 2
in my other terminal
and if i look in dot ssh it has
authorized keys so when you copy your
public key from machine 1 to machine 2.
in machine 2 we have authorized keys and
in machine 1 we have known underscore
host now let's repeat the same step here
let's say
home dot ssh id underscore rsa.public
and let's copy it to hdc at m1
say yes
and
give the password and that should have
copied your public key to m1 now if you
look in dot ssh this also has known
underscore host
and if we look in m1 that will have
authorized keys which basically means
your ssh setup should be fine let's test
by typing in ssh m2 and that should
allow me to log into m2 without a
password let's log out and let's check
the same thing from m2 ssh m1 and that
works fine
we also need to copy our public keys to
the same machine so i'll say cat
from my home directory
id underscore rsa dot public and let's
append it to the same location
in ssh directory in authorized
underscore keys
once this is done test ssh to m2 from m2
itself
say yes and it works fine to a log out
and let's do the same thing on m1 so cat
home
dot ssh id underscore rsa dot public
let's append it in same location
in authorized underscore keys
let's test ssh to itself say yes and
that's fine
this will also be required when we set
up a cluster and we start our processes
that is hadoop specific processes on the
machine it will not ask for password
because you have set up ssh across
machines and locally to itself now once
this is done we basically have two
machines which can not only ping each
other but they can also do a ssh to each
other let's also check in machine 2 if
my installation of whim is done and
that's also done now what we also need
is on this machine that is m2 we
basically need the java package and we
need the hadoop package so let's copy
from machine one so i can copy the
complete directory or i can copy the tar
file so i would suggest copying the tar
files and then unpacking them so that we
can have less data transferred over
network so i can say scp
home hdc downloads
let's take the jdk package and let's
copy it to hdc at m2 in the temp
directory so this shows that you don't
need to download jdk and hadoop on all
the machines just download it on one
machine and then copy it across once
your ssh is set up similarly we can
copy the hadoop tar file to the other
machine also this is an easier way in
fact you could write your bash scripts
or ansible scripts to deploy all the
packages across the machines
now let's go to m2 and here we can then
first
create a directory in user lib
and call it as jbm like what we did on
first machine and then i can change my
location to jvm i can say sudo tar xvf
and then from temp i'll get the jdk
package and i'll unpack it here
once this is done we need to make sure
that our bash rc is updated or we can
even copy that from machine 1 to machine
2. now this should create a jdk
directory here on machine 2 as it did on
machine 1 and that's owned by if there
is a problem with ownership it's good to
change the ownership manually to root
case that creates a problem later once
this is done we have our jdk let's
see
if everything is fine and it's fine now
similarly i will go to user local
directory i will say sudo tar xvf from
temp
let's unpack the hadoop in user local
location as we did on machine one and
once this is done we need to create a
link we need to change the ownership and
we need to update the bashrc
and this is
done
now i can see i have a hadoop directory
it's owned by hdc okay i can create a
link
to this call it as hadoop
let's change the ownership to htc of
anything that starts with hadoop and we
have our hadoop path also set correctly
now all i need is from my machine one
while i'm logged in as hdc i'll say scp
copy the batch rc from here into hdc
m2
in home hdc which has my java path my
hadoop path updated let's go here and
let's do a source
bash rc and then let's check
if my java version shows up correctly
that's fine let's check if hadoop
version shows up correctly and that's
fine so now we have two machines which
have java which have hadoop package
which can ping each other which have ssh
access and which have firewall disabled
these two machines can then be used to
set up my hadoop cluster
once we start editing the config files
and that config files can be found in
user local
hadoop
etc
in both the machines
user
local
hadoop
etc
this is where we will edit our config
files and then we are ready to bring up
our cluster which will be a two node
cluster for my hadoop my strategy would
be
on m1 machine
i would have a name node i would have a
data node i would have a resource
manager and i would have a node manager
running
on my m2 machine i would have a data
node i would have a node manager
and i would have a secondary name node
running so this is the plan
for cluster setup on these two machines
to set up our hadoop cluster we will
need the config files and i have updated
my config files in github link so let's
go to github you can always refer to
this git link which i am showing on the
screen where i have the config files
updated
and we can just easily copy our config
files from here
so
let's click on
this link
and here i have given the config files
so we can click on hadoop 2.6.5
and this basically has my
five important config files which we
need to update in both the machines now
let's go to machine one and here let's
go to user
local
hadoop
edc
hadoop
and here the first config file which i
will update is core hyphen site file
let's
get into this which has nothing as
configuration specified now as i
mentioned when i was explaining hdfs
that in apache hadoop we would have to
download the hadoop related package we
will have to edit the configs we would
have to do the formatting and then we
would have to start the cluster however
if it was cloudera or hortonworks or any
other vendor-specific distribution
downloading the packages editing the
config files formatting the cluster
would be taken care by your installer
now here let's go to the git link and
let's get the contents of core hyphen
site file which basically tells the sdfs
path the location where my name node
would run and the port to which my name
node will listen to so let's click on
core hyphen site file and get the config
files
or the properties scroll down and we
just need to give this although there
can be many other properties which can
be specified but we will just go for a
simple setup
copy this
come to your terminal and here i can
just paste it now this tells the
property is fs or default fs which is
also used if developers are coding their
file system api and would want to
connect to sdfs now here i will change
my machine name m1 and this is the
machine where my name node will run and
it will use 9000 port sdfs colon slash
m1 9000 let's save this and our first
config file is edited now the next file
which we would want to edit is map red
hyphen site file and what we can do here
is my map red file shows up as template
so i'll just rename it
as map red hyphen site dot xml and then
let's edit it which tells
what processing framework we would be
using or what processing layer we will
be using let's go to the git link again
and
let's pick up the information of map red
hyphen site file which is
here and the processing layer which we
will be using
is yarn so let's copy this again there
can be many more properties specifying
your values of memory for map and reduce
and many other properties we will just
go for a basic setup which is more than
enough even to test out all the
functionalities of adobe cluster so my
processing framework will be yarn let's
save this
and we have edited the second file
similarly we will also edit my third
file which is hdfs hyphen site file so
let's go into this which basically tells
what will be my replication factor where
will my name node store metadata on disk
if i plan to run the data node here
where will data node store the blocks
and so on so let's go to sdfs hyphen
site file
let's give the properties so let's go in
here
and let's get the content of sdfs hyphen
site file scroll down
and let's get all these values that is
replication
the path of metadata on disk the path
where my data blocks will get stored
what is the http port my name node will
use what is the http port my secondary
name node will use
and my secondary name nodes check
pointing frequency which is by default
one hour but we will be setting it up as
10 minutes
let's copy this and
here i will
paste it now let's make some changes
here quickly so i plan to run two data
nodes
so i can go for a replication of at
least two since i am planning to run two
data nodes i have given a metadata path
that this is the path where my name node
will store metadata on disk metadata on
ram is dynamically built metadata on
disk needs a path that's why we are
giving this as we plan to run name node
here we also plan to run a data node
here and we will give the path
for my data node to store its blocks now
remember since we are in apache hadoop
cluster we will have to create this apc
directory the name and data directory
will get automatically created now this
also tells what http port my name node
will use and here i will specify my name
node would run on m1
and it will use an http port 570. for my
secondary name node i would want it to
run on my other machine so i will
specify m2 and it will use 590 port now
since i'm planning to run my secondary
name node on my second machine i don't
need to give this property here i'll
give this property in my m2 machines
hdfs file so let's delete this and our
hdfs setup the next file which we need
to edit is yarn hyphen site file which
tells about your resource manager your
resource tracker and some other
properties
so let's go into yarn hyphen site file
and let's get the values from here which
if you scroll down you should be able to
find
and scroll down and you have these four
properties now there can be many other
properties as i said like specifying how
much memory you want to allocate for
node manager or how many cpu cores or do
you want to enable or disable physical
or virtual memory check or do you want
to enable log aggregation so you can
copy all these properties
from yarn hyphen site file
and
let's place it in
my
machine
these are all my properties let's
carefully check if everything is fine my
resource manager is intended to run on
m1 if you want to run it on some other
machine then you would have to give the
hostname of that machine my resource
tracker which helps your resource
manager to know about resources
will also run on m1 but on a different
port i have some shuffle classes which
are relevant now this property tells how
much amount of memory you would want to
allocate for your node manager on this
machine
now either we could keep it minimum or
we could let yan decided for us so let
me get rid of this
and the cpu cores so the default memory
and the default core which yarn will
assume for your machines for your node
managers would be 8 gb and 8 cores
rest properties can be left as they are
you don't need to make any changes
save them and your yarn is also done now
we will edit a slaves file which tells
on which machines will my data nodes run
and hence my node managers run so i'll
say m1 and m2
so my five main files are edited which
is coresight map red site sdfs yarn and
slaves now you can also edit hadoop
environment and yarn environment but
that's not mandatory
which mentions about your java path
which mentions the heap size that is the
amount of ram which will be used when
your process comes up the default value
is 1gb and you don't need to make
changes so let it be as it is i don't
make any changes to hadoop environment
now once these config files are edited
let's quickly copy them across m2 and
then we can edit them in m2 i'll say scp
take the core file and let's copy to sdc
m2 in user
local
hadoop
etc
hadoop that's the path
done
let's copy the other files also which is
my map red file
so map red file
let's copy this
let's copy the yarn file slaves file and
sdfs file
so that's my on file
let's copy the hdfs file
and let's copy the slaves file
so all my files are copied
or should have been copied by now
to my m2 machine
and then we can accordingly update the
things
in m2 and i don't need to really switch
to m2 i can just say ssh m2
because i can log in from here i can go
into user local
hadoop
etc hadoop
and now we can look in the core file
which doesn't need any changes because
this tells what would be your sdfs path
and where your name node runs
and this would be same because we would
have data nodes running on every machine
talking to the name node so they need to
know where your name node is running on
what port so we don't make any changes
to the core file
map red file doesn't need any change
so here we have the framework as yarn
also what you can do is
to make sure
remove if there is any template file
let's look into hdfs file and this will
have some changes so replication no that
doesn't need a change do we need a path
which tells where metadata is stored no
because our name node does not run on
this machine
do we need a path for data node yes and
let's give just a naming convention
let's add a number 2 here which tells me
that this is second data node http port
is fine secondary name nodes port is
fine and then we can give the checkpoint
period property which tells how
frequently should my secondary name node
do the checkpointing now as i said the
default time frame is one hour but then
we can set it to a lower time frame by
giving a property
that is in my sdfs file which we had
deleted from machine 1 but we will
retain it in machine 2.
this is the property which tells what is
the frequency of check pointing that
secondary name node should follow
so let's give it here
and this says every 10 minutes i would
want my secondary name node to do a
checkpointing and have a copy of
metadata of name node that name node
stores on the disk now i am not
specifying a path where secondary name
node should keep a copy of name notes
metadata on disk and by default my
secondary name node will store it in
temp and that's fine for now so let's
save this
now let's also look in
yarn file if we need any change which
tells resource manager will run on m1
that's fine resource tracker will run on
m1 that's fine shuffle classes some
other properties which tell don't check
for physical and virtual memory and log
aggregation so we really don't make any
change to our yarn file and our slaves
file which tells where my data nodes
will run that means where my data nodes
and node managers will run we don't make
any changes
so all my config files are edited on m1
and on m2 now don't forget to create the
directory which you have mentioned in
the config files that is abc and make
sure that our hdc user has the
permissions to this or you might have
some failures so i'll say
abc that's done let's do the same thing
on m1
and let's change the ownership
of this directory now once all these
steps are done
are both the machines are set up to
basically have a hadoop cluster running
but that cannot happen without be doing
a formatting formatting is the first
step which will create the initial
metadata in the metadata path so as of
now we have nothing we will do a
formatting of sdfs which basically
prepares the sdfs to store the data so
i'll say hdfs name node format and this
has to be given only once because this
creates the initial metadata in the name
nodes path which we have mentioned in
this dfs file once the formatting is
done no matter how many times you
restart your machines you will never do
a formatting again because if you do a
formatting again it will bring your
cluster to the initial state
let's do a formatting which should
create my initial metadata in the abc
directory and that would also create a
slash name directory as we have
specified in our config files once this
is done have a look at your abc
directory and that has name name has
current and in current you have the
initial fs image which is the file
system image which tells as of 2327
your machine has this
now once this is done we can also look
into abc slash name slash current and
here we can look into the version file
which has the initial identifiers that
is your namespace id cluster id and
blockpool id and this was the reason i
mentioned that you should never ever do
a formatting again because reformatting
will change these identifiers and set
them to new ones however your data nodes
which will also have a copy of these
might not get updated now once your
formatting is done once your initial
metadata is created we can just say
start hyphen all dot sh and this script
internally will run two scripts
this script internally triggers start
dfs dot sh and start yarn dot sh and
internally these scripts actually run
hadoop
demon dot sh
start
and then your process name such as name
node or data node or secondary name node
and yarn daemon dot sh start
resource manager and node managers for
more information you can always refer to
the s-bin directory which talks about
these scripts or which shows these
scripts which you can check in user
local hadoop s-bin which has the
individual or startup scripts so now
let's click on start hyphen all dot sh
and if everything is fine it should
basically start your cluster now it says
the script is deprecated use start dfs
and start yarn but it will still work
now since we have set up ssh access it
does not ask or prompt for a password it
starts your name node it starts your
data nodes and then it will basically
start your secondary name node and
resource manager finally your node
managers so we will have a two node
cluster now which uses two machines
which we set up that is m1 and m2 it has
one single name node it has two data
nodes one secondary name node and
it will have one resource manager which
is the master of processing layer and
then two node managers which are the
processing slaves we can always check
the processes using jps command for java
related processes
and we can check on other machine
for my processes
and we have a two node cluster up and
running which has two data nodes two
node managers one name node one resource
manager and one secondary name node we
can also look into the abc directory on
m2 which will now have a directory for
data node
and that will have a version file which
can be looked into for identifiers and
you can always look into a different
version file which is
here so you have two version files and
both of these version file have the
identifiers which they have received
from the name node where will my blocks
get stored it will be stored in current
finalized and then
it will be within this path if we write
data to sdfs where my blocks will come
and get stored let's check the same
thing on machine 2 which only had a name
directory in abc
which now also has a data directory
and similarly it has the version file at
under current directory or a version
file which is under the block pool
directory
so this is my two node cluster we can
quickly give a command that is
hdfs dfs admin report or you can always
check what are the options in sdfs by
typing in hdfs and here you have an
option called dfs admin again you can
check for all the different options with
dfs admin
and here on the top we will have an
option called
report so these are all the commands
used by an admin so you have report live
dead or decommissioning so we can check
how many nodes we have by typing in hdfs
dfs admin report which should show me
that i have two data nodes how much of
those nodes is configured for
distributed file system how much is for
local machine
are they responding to name node by
looking at the last contact time which
will get updated every three seconds and
you have machine one and machine two
which are two nodes or two live data
nodes of your hadoop cluster this is via
a command we can always go
and use the browser
and look at the web ui so i can check m1
using its http port to have a look at my
name node
which tells me what is my cluster id
what is my block pull id
the configured capacity how many live
nodes we have is there a situation of
under replicated blocks
and it tells me that there are no dead
nodes you can click on live nodes
and that gives you your two data nodes
what is their capacity how much is being
used how many blocks does that have is
there any situation of failed volumes
and you can look for more information
you can always look in here and you can
say browse the file system or look at
logs which you can also find from your
machine in your hadoop directory but you
can click on browse the file system as
of now we don't have any data and this
is the web ui for your sdfs for your
name node however this does not allow
you to work with sdfs it only allows you
to browse through sdfs and your adobe
cluster you also have a ui for resource
manager and that should be accessible
using
the default port which is for resource
manager and as i mentioned since we did
not configure the amount of memory and
cpu cores which is allocated to every
node manager on every node it will go
for default memory settings that is 8 gb
and default cores which will be eight
cores per node all of those settings can
be changed but then to begin with you
can have a simple cluster with two node
which says there is 16 gb memory
available although that's not true you
have 16 v codes but then we have two
nodes where we have data nodes running
and we have node managers running which
will be used for processing our data on
this hadoop cluster so this is a simple
two node apache cluster which can then
be used to write data process it and
store data in a distributed fashion
thank you rj for that fascinating
session next up we have both ajay and
richard to take you through the entire
hadoop ecosystem and its components
today we're covering the hadoop
ecosystem at least the very fundamentals
of all the different parts that are in
the hadoop ecosystem and it's very
robust it's grown over the years with
different things added in there's a lot
of overlapping a lot of these tools but
we're just going to cover these basic
tools so you can see what's available in
the hadoop ecosystem so let's go back to
our hadoop ecosystem as you can see we
have all our different setup and let's
focus on the hadoop part of it first
before we look at the different tools we
start with the hadoop or hdfs is for
data storage the hdfs or the hadoop file
system is currently used by companies
all over the world all the big names
uber facebook visa intel amazon web
service douchebank ebay pivotal yahoo
all of these are using the hadoop file
system and way beyond this this is just
like a small picture of some of the main
companies using it this company used
hdfs to overcome the problem of storing
a massive amount of data let's look how
hadoop or hdfs came into existence and
what hdfs is all about in the
traditional approach all the data was
stored in a single central database with
the rise of big data a single database
was not enough for storage and i
remember the old sun computers or the
huge ibm machines with all the flashing
lights now all the data on one of those
can be stored on your phone it's almost
a bit of humor how much this has
accelerated over the years the same
thing with our rise of big data no
longer can you just store it on one
machine no longer can you go out buy a
sun computer and put it on that one sun
computer no more can you buy a craig
machine or an enterprise ibm server it's
not going to work you're not going to
fit it all into one server the solution
was to use distributed approach to store
the massive amount of data data was
divided and distributed amongst many
individual databases and you can see
here where we have three different
databases going on so you might actually
saw this in one where they divided up
the user accounts a through g
so on by the letter and so the first
query would say what's the first letter
of this whatever id it was and then it
would go into that database to find it
so i had a database telling it which
database to look for stuff that was a
long time ago and to be honest it didn't
work really well nowadays so that was a
distributed database you'd have to track
which database you put it in so what is
hdfs hadoop distributed file system hdfs
is a specially designed file system for
storing huge data sets in commodity
hardware and commodities an interesting
term because i mentioned enterprise
versus commodity and i'll touch back
upon that it has two core components
name node and data node name node is the
master
daemon there's only one active name node
it manages the data nodes and stores all
the metadata so it stores all the
mapping of where the data is on your
hadoop file system now the name node is
usually an enterprise machine you spend
a lot of extra money on it so you have a
very solid name known machine and so
then we have our data nodes our data
node data node data node we have three
here the data node is the slave there
can be multiple data nodes and it stores
the actual data and this is where your
commodity hardware comes in the best
definition i've heard of commodity
hardware is the cheap knockoffs this is
where you buy you can buy 10 of these
and you expect one of them not to work
because you know when they come in
they're going to break right away so
you're looking at hardware this not as
high-end so where you might have your
main master node is your enterprise
server then your data nodes are just as
cheap as you can get them with all the
different features you need on them as
said earlier name node stores the
metadata metadata gives information
regarding the file location block size
and so on so our metadata in the hdfs is
maintained by using two files it has the
edit log and the fs image the edit log
keeps track of the recent changes made
on the hadoop file system only recent
changes are tracked here the fs image
keeps track of every change made on the
hdfs since the beginning now what
happens when the edit log file size
increases the name node fails these are
big ones so what happens we get our edit
log it just keeps so big until it's too
big or our main enterprise computer that
we spent all that money on so it would
break actually fails because they still
fail the solution we make copies of the
edit log and the fs image files so
that's pretty straightforward you just
copy them over so you have both the most
recent edits going on and the long term
image of your file system and then we
also create a secondary name node is a
node that maintains a copies of the edit
log and the fs image it combines them
both to get an updated version of the fs
image now the secondary name node only
came in the last oh i guess two three
years where it became as part of the
main system and usually your secondary
name node is also an enterprise computer
and you'll put them on separate racks so
if you have three racks of computers you
would have maybe the first two racks
would have the name node and the second
rack would have the secondary name note
and the reason you put them on different
racks is you can have a whole rack go
down you could have somebody literally
trip over the power cable or the switch
that goes between the racks is most
common goes down well if the switch goes
down you can easily switch to the
secondary name node and while you're
getting your switch replaced and
replacing that hardware because of the
way the hdfs works it still is
completely functional so let's take a
look at the name node we have our edit
log our fs image and we have our
secondary name node and you take that it
copies the edit log over and it copies
the fs image and you can see right here
you have all the different contents on
your main name node now also on your
secondary name node and then your
secondary name node will actually take
these two your edit log and your fs
image and it will make a copy so you
have a full fs image that contains its
current it's up to date the secondary
name node creates a periodic checkpoint
of the files and then it updates the new
fs image into the name node now used to
be this all occurred on the name node
before you had a secondary name note so
now you can use your secondary name to
both backup everything going on the name
node and it does that lifting in the
back where you're combining your edit
log and bring your fs image so it's
current and then you end up with a new
edit log and a new you have your fs
image updated and you start a fresh edit
log this process of updating happens
every hour and that's how it's scheduled
you can actually change those schedules
but that is the standard is to update
every hour so let's we took a look at
the the master node and the you know the
name node and the secondary name node
let's take a look at the cluster
architecture of our hadoop file system
the hdfs cluster architecture so we have
our name node and it stores the metadata
and we have our block location so we
have our fs image plus our edit log and
then we have the backup fs image and
edit log and then we have so you have
your rack we have our switch on top
remember i was talking about the switch
that's the most common thing to go in
the rack is the switches and underneath
the rack you have your different data
nodes you have your data node one two
three four five maybe you have 10 15 on
this rack you can stack them pretty high
nowadays uh used to be you only get
about 10 servers on there but now you
see racks that contain a lot more and
then you have multiple racks so we're
not talking about just one rack we also
have you know rack 2 rack 3 4 5 6 and so
on until you have rack in so if you had
a 100 data nodes we would be looking at
10 racks of 10 data nodes each and that
is literally 10 commodity server
computers hardware and we have a core
switch which maintains network bandwidth
and connects the name node to the data
nodes so just like each rack has a
switch that connects all your nodes on
the rack you now have core switches that
connect all the racks together and these
also connect into our name node setup so
now i can look up your fs image and your
edit log and pull that information your
metadata out so we've looked at the
architecture from the name node coming
down and you have your metadata your
block locations this then sorts it out
you have your core switches which
connect everything all your different
racks and then each individual rack has
their own switches which connect all the
different nodes and to the core switches
so now let's talk about the actual data
blocks what's actually sitting on those
commodity machines and so the hadoop
file system splits massive files into
small chunks these chunks are known as
data blocks each file in the hadoop file
system is stored as a data block and we
have a nice picture here where it looks
like a lego if you ever played with the
legos as a kid it's a good example we
just stacked that data right on top of
each other but each block has to be the
same symmetry has to be the same size so
that it can track it easily and the
default size of one data block is
usually 128 megabytes now you can go in
and change that this standard is pretty
solid as far as most data is concerned
when we're loading up huge amounts of
data and there's certainly reasons to
change it but 128 megabytes is pretty
standard block so why 128 megabytes if
the block size is smaller then there
will be too many data blocks along with
lots of metadata which will create
overhead so that's why you don't really
want to go smaller on these data blocks
unless you have a very certain kind of
data similarly if the block size is very
large then the processing time for each
block increases then as i pointed out
earlier each block is the same size just
like your lego blocks are all the same
but the last block can be the same size
or less so you might only be storing 100
megabytes in the last block and you can
think of this as if you had a terabyte
of data that you're storing on here it's
not going to be exactly divided into 128
megabytes we just store all of it at 128
megabytes except for the last one which
could have anywhere between 1 and 128
megabytes depending on how evenly your
data is divided now let's look into how
files are stored in the hadoop file
system so we have a file a text let's
say it's 520 megabytes we have block a
so we take 128 megabytes out of the 520
and we store it in block a and then we
have block b again we're taking 128
megabytes out of our 520 storing it
there and so on block c block d and then
block e we only have eight megabytes
left so when you add up 128 plus 128
plus 128 plus 128 you only get
and so at last 8 megabytes goes into its
own block the final block uses only the
remaining space for storage data node
failure and replication and this is
really where hadoop shines this is what
makes it this is why you can use it with
commodity computers this is why you can
have multiple racks and have something
go down all the data blocks are stored
in various data notes you take each
block you store it at 128 megabytes and
then we're going to put it on different
nodes so here's our block a block b
block c from our last example and we
have node one node two node three node
four node five node six and so each one
of these represents a different computer
it literally splits the data up into
different machines so what happens if
node five crashes well that's a big deal
i mean we might not even have just node
5 you might have a whole rack go down
and if you're a company that's building
your whole business off of that you're
going to lose a lot of money so what
does happen when node 5 crashes or the
first rack goes down the data stored in
node 5 will be unavailable as there is
no copy stored elsewhere in this
particular image so the hadoop file
system overcomes the issue of data node
failure by creating copies of the data
this is known as the replication method
you can see here we have our six nodes
here's our block a but instead of
storing it just on the first machine
we're actually going to store it on the
second and fourth notes so now it's
spread across three different computers
and in this if these are on a rack one
of these is always on a different rack
so you might have two copies on the same
rack but you never have all three on the
same rack and you always have you never
have more than two copies on one node
there's no reason to have more than one
copy per node and you can see we do the
same thing with block b block c is and
also spread out across to different
machines and same with block d and block
e node 5 crashes will the data blocks b
d and e be lost well in this example no
because we have backups of all three of
those on different machines the blocks
have their copies in the other nodes due
to which the data is not lost even if
the node 5 crashes and again because
they're also stored on different racks
even if the whole rack goes down you are
still up and live with your hadoop file
system the default replication factor is
three in total we'll have three copies
of each data block now that can be
changed for different reasons or
purposes but you gotta remember when
you're looking at a data center this is
all in one huge room these switches are
connecting all these servers so they can
shuffle the data back and forth really
quick and that is very important when
you're dealing with big data and you can
see here each block is by default
replicated three times that's the
standard there is very rare occasions to
do four
and there's even fewer reasons to do two
blocks i've only seen four used once and
it was because they had two data centers
and so each data center kept two
different copies rack awareness in the
hadoop file system rack is a collection
of 30 to 40 data nodes rack awareness is
a concept that helps to decide where the
replica of the data block should be
stored so here we have rack one we have
our data node one to four remember
saying that it used to be only put ten
machines and then it went to 20 now it's
30 to 40 so you can have a rack with 40
servers on it then we have rack 2 and
rack 3 and we put block 1 on there
replicas of block a cannot be in the
same rack and so i'll put the replicas
onto a different rack and notice that
these are actually these two are on the
same rack but you'll never have all
three stored on the same rack in case
the whole rack goes down and replicas of
block a are created in rack two and they
actually do they do by default create
the replicas onto the same rack and that
has to do with the data exchange and
maximizing your processing time and then
we have of course our block b and it's
replicated onto rack 3 and block c which
will then replicate onto rack 1 and so
on for all of your data all the way up
to block d or whatever how much ever
data you have on there hdfs architecture
so let's look at where the architecture
is a bigger picture we looked at the
name node and we store some metadata
names replicas home food data three so
it has all your different infra your
metadata stored on there and then we
have our data nodes and you can see our
data nodes are each on different racks
with our different machines and we have
our name node and you can see we have a
heartbeat or pulse here and a lot of
times one of the things that confuses
people sometimes in classes they talk
about nodes versus machines so you could
have a data node that's a hadoop data
node and you could also have a spark
node on there sparks a different
architecture and these are each daemons
that are running on these computers
that's why you refer to them as nodes
and not just always as servers and
machines so even though i use them
interchangeable be aware that these
nodes you can even have virtual machines
if you're testing something out it
doesn't make sense to have 10 virtual
nodes on one machine and deploy it
because you might as well just run your
code on the machine and so we have our
heartbeat going on here and the
heartbeat is a signal that data nodes
continuously send to the name nodes this
signal shows the status of the data note
so there's a continual pulse going up
and saying hey i'm here i'm ready for
whatever instructions or data you want
to send me and you can see here we've
divided up into rack 1 and rack 2 and
our different data nodes and it also
have the replications we talked about
how to replicate data and replicates it
in three different locations and then we
have a client machine and the client
first requests the name node to read the
data now if you're not familiar with the
client machine the client is you the
programmer the client is you've logged
in external to this hadoop file system
and you're sending it instructions and
so the client whatever instructions or
script you're sending is first request a
name node to read the data the name node
allows a client to read the requested
data from the data nodes the data is
read from the data nodes and sent to the
client and so you can see here that
basically the the name node connects the
client up and says here here's a data
stream and now you have the query that
you sent out returning the data you
asked for and then of course it goes and
finishes it and says oh metadata
operations and it goes in there and
finalizes your request the other thing
the name node does is you're sending
your information because the client
sends the information in there is your
block operations so your block
operations are performs creation of data
so you're going to create new files and
folders you're going to delete the
folders and also it covers the
replication of the folders which goes on
in the background and so we can see here
that we have a nice full picture you can
see where the client machine comes in it
cues the metadata the metadata goes into
it stores a metadata and then it goes
into block operations and maybe you're
sending the data to the hidoo file
system maybe you're querying maybe
you're asking it to delete if you're
sending data in there it then does the
replication on there it goes back so you
have your data client which is writing
the data into the data node and of
course replicating it and that's all
part of the block operations and so
let's talk a little bit about read
mechanisms in the hadoop file system the
hadoop file system read mechanism we
have our hadoop file system client
that's you on your computer and the
client jvm on the client node so we have
our client jvm or the java virtual
machine that is going through and then
your client node and we're zooming in on
the read mechanism so we're looking at
this picture here as you can guess your
client is reading the data and i also
have another client down here writing
data we're going to look a little closer
at that and so we have our name node up
here we have our racks of your data
nodes and your racks of computers down
here and so our client the first thing
it does is it opens a connection up with
the distributed file system to the hdfs
and it goes hey can i get the block
locations and so it goes by using the
rpc remote procedure call it gets those
locations and the name node first checks
if the client is authorized to access
the requested file and if yes it then
provides a block location and a token to
the client which is showing to the slave
for authentication so here's the name
node it tells the client hey here's the
token the client's going to come in and
get this information from you and it
tells the client oh hey here's where the
information is so this is what is
telling your script you sent to query
your data whether you're writing your
script in one of the many setups that
you have available through the hadoop
file system or a connection through your
code and so you have your client machine
at this point then reads so your fs data
input stream comes through and you have
and you can see right here we did one
and two which is verify who you are and
give you all the information you need
then three you're going to read it from
the input stream and then the input
stream is going to grab it from the
different nodes where it's at and it'll
supply the tokens to those machines
saying hey this client needs this data
here's a token for that we're good to go
let me have the data the client will
show the authentication token to the
data nodes for the read process to begin
so after reaching the end of the data
block the connection is closed and we
can see here where we've gone through
the different steps get block locations
we have step one you open up your
connection you get the block locations
by using the rpc then you actively go
through the fs data input stream to grab
all those different data brings it back
into the client and then once it's done
it closes down that connection and then
once the client or in this case the
programmer you know manager has gone in
and pig script you can do that there's
an actual coding in each in hadoop or
pulling data called pig or hive once you
get that data back we close the
connection delete all those randomly
huge series of tokens so they can't be
used anymore and then it's done with
that query and we'll go ahead and zoom
in just a little bit more here and let's
look at this even a little closer here's
our hadoop file system client and our
client jvm our java virtual machine on
the client node and we have the data to
be read block a block b and so we
request to read block a and b and it
goes into the name node 2 then it sends
the location in this case ip addresses
of the blocks for the dn1 and dn2 where
those blocks are stored then the client
interacts with the data nodes through
the switches and so you have here the
core switch so your client node comes in
three and it goes to the core switch and
that then goes to rack switch one rack
switch two and rack switch three now if
you're looking at this you'll
automatically see a point of failure in
the core switch and certainly you want a
high end switch mechanism for your core
switch you want to use enterprise
hardware for that and then when you get
to the racks that's all commodity all
your rack switches if one of those goes
down you don't care as much you just
have to get in there and swap it in and
out really quick you can see here we
have block a which is replicated three
times and so is block b and it'll pull
from there so we come in here and here
the data is read from the dn1 and dn2 as
they are the closest to each other and
so you can see here that it's not going
to read from two different racks it's
going to read from one rack whatever the
closest setup is for that query the
reason for this is if you have 10 other
queries going on you want this one to
pull all the data through one setup and
it minimizes that traffic so the
response from the data nodes to the
client that read the operation was
successful it says ah we've read the
data we're successful which is always
good we like to be successful i don't
know about you i like to be successful
so if we look at the read mechanism
let's go ahead and zoom in and look at
the write mechanism for the hadoop file
system so our hdfs rate mechanism and so
when we have the hdfs write mechanism
here's our client machine this is again
the programmer on their in computer and
it's going through the client java
machine or java virtual machine the jvm
this is all occurring on the client node
somebody's office or maybe it's on the
local server for the office so we have
our name node we have data nodes and we
have the distributed file system so the
client first executes create file on
distributed file system says hey i'm
going to create this file over here then
it goes through the rpc call just like
our read did the client first executes
create file in the distributed file
system then the dfs interacts with the
name node to create a file name node
then provides a location to write the
data and so here we have our hdfs client
and the fs data output stream so this
time instead of the data going to the
client it's coming from the client and
so here the client writes the data
through the fs data output stream keep
in mind that this output stream the
client could be a streaming code it
could be i mean you know i always refer
to the client as just being this
computer that your programmer is writing
on it could be you have your sql server
there where your data is that's current
with all your current sales and it's
archiving all that information through
scoop one of the tools in the hadoop
file system it could be streaming data
it could be a connection to the stock
servers and you're pulling stock data
down from those servers at a regular
time and that's all controlled you can
actually set that code up to be
controlled in many of the different
features in the hadoop file system and
some of the different resources you have
that sit on top of it so here the client
writes the data through the fs data
output stream and the fs data output
stream as you can see goes into right
packet so it divides it up into packets
128 megabytes and the data is written
and the slave further replicates it so
here's our data coming in and then if
you remember correctly that's part of
the fs data setup is it tells it where
to replicate it out but the data node
itself is like oh hey okay i've got the
data coming in and it's also given the
tokens of where to send the replications
to and then acknowledgement is sent
after the required replicas are made so
then that goes back up saying hey
successful i've written data made three
replications on this as far as our you
know going through the pipeline of the
data nodes and then that goes back and
says after the data is written the
client performs the close method so the
client's done it says okay i'm done
here's the end of the data we're
finished and after the date is written
the client performs a close method and
we can see here just a quick reshape we
go in there just like we did with the
read we create the connection this
creates a name node which lets it know
what's going on step two step three that
also includes the tokens and everything
and then we go into step three where
we're now writing through the fs data
output stream and that sorts it out into
whatever data node it's going to go to
and which also tells it how to replicate
it so that data node then sends it to
other data nodes so we have a
replication and of course you finalize
it and close everything up marks it
complete to the name node and it deletes
all those magical tokens in the
background so that they can't be reused
and we can go ahead and just do this
with an example the same setups and
whether you're doing a read or write
they're very similar as we come in here
from our client and our name node and
you can see right here we actually
depicting these as the actual rack and
the switch is going on and so as the
data comes in you have your request like
we saw earlier it sends the location of
the data nodes and this actually turns
your your ip addresses your dynamic node
connections they come back to your
client your hdfs client and at that
point with the tokens it then goes into
the core switch and the core switch says
hey here it goes the client interacts
with the data nodes through the switches
and you can see here where you're
writing in block a replication of block
a and a second replication of block a on
the second server so blocking is
replicated on the second server and the
third server at this point you now have
three replications of block a and it
comes back and says it acknowledges it
says hey we're done and that goes back
into your hadoop file system to the
client who says okay we're done and
finally the
success written to the name node and it
just closes everything down a quick
recap of the hadoop file system and the
advantages and so the first one is
probably one of the all of these are
huge one you have multiple data copies
are available so it's very fault
tolerant whole racks can go down
switches can go down even your main name
node can go down if you have a secondary
name node something we didn't talk too
much about is how scalable it is because
it uses distributed storage you run into
their oh my gosh i'm out of space or i
need to do some heavier processing let
me just add another rack of computers so
you can scale it up very quickly it's a
linear scalability where it used to be
if you bought a server you would have to
pay a lot of money to get that the craig
computer remember the big craig
computers coming out the craig computer
runs 2 million a year just the
maintenance to liquid coolant that's
very expensive compared to just adding
more racks of computer and extending
your data center so it's very cost
effective since commodity hardware is
used we're talking cheap knockoff
computers you still need your high-end
enterprise for the name node but the
rest of them literally it is a tenth of
the cost of storing data on more
traditional high-end computers and then
the data is secure so it has a very
high-end data security and provides data
security for your data so all theory and
no play doesn't make for much fun so
let's go ahead and show you what it
looks like as far as some of the
dimensions when you're getting into
pulling data or putting data into the
hadoop file system and you can see here
i have oracle virtual machine virtual
box manager i have a couple different
things loaded on there cloudera is one
of them so we should probably explain
some of these things if you're new to
virtual machines the oracle virtualbox
allows you to spin up a machine as if it
is a separate computer so in this case
this is running i believe centos linux
and it creates like a box on my computer
so the centos is running on my machine
well i'm running my windows 10 this
happens to be a windows 10 computer and
then underneath here i can actually go
under let me just open up the general
might be hard to see there and you can
see i can actually go down to system
processor i happen to be on an 8 core it
has 16 dedicated threads registers of 16
cpus but eight cores and i've only
designated this for one cpu so it's only
going to use one of my dedicated threads
on my computer and this the oracle
virtual machine is open source you can
see right here we're on the oracle
www.oracle.com i usually just do a
search for downloading virtualbox if you
search for virtualbox all one word it
will come up with this page and then you
can download it for whatever operating
system you're working with there
certainly are a number of different
options and let me go and point those
out if you're setting this up as a for
demoing for yourself the first thing to
note for doing a virtual box and doing a
cloudera or horton setup on that virtual
box for doing the hadoop system to try
it out you need a minimum of 12
gigabytes it cannot be a windows 10 home
edition because you'll have problems
with your virtual setup and sometimes
you have to go turn on the virtual
settings so it knows it's in there so if
you're on a home setup there are other
sources there's cloudera and we'll talk
a little bit about clardera here in just
a second but they have the cloudera
online live we can go try the cloudera
setup i've never used it but cloudera is
a pretty good company cloudera and
hortonworks are two of the common ones
out there and we'll actually be running
a cloudera hadoop cluster on on our demo
here so you have oracle virtual machine
you also have the option of doing it on
different vmware that's another one like
virtual machine this is more of a paid
service there is a free setup for just
doing it for yourself which will work
fine for this and then in the cloudera
like again they have the new online
setup where you can go in there to the
online and for cloudera you want to go
underneath the cloudera quick start if
you type in a search for cloudera quick
start it'll bring you to this website
and then you can select your platform in
this case i did virtualbox there's
vmware we just talked about docker
docker is a very high-end virtual setup
unless you already know it you really
don't want to mess with it then your kvm
is if you're on a linux computer that
sets up multiple systems on that
computer so the two you really want to
use are usually the virtual box or do an
online setup and you can see here with
the download if you're going into the
horton version it's called hortonworks
and they call it sandbox so you'll see
the term hortonworks sandbox and these
are all test demos you're not going to
deploy a single node hadoop systems that
would just be kind of ridiculous and
defeat the whole purpose of having a
horton or having a hadoop system if it's
only installed on one computer in a
virtual node so a lot of different
options if you're not on a professional
windows version or you don't have at
least 12 gigabytes ram to run this uh
you'll want to try and see if you can
find an online version and of course
simplylearn has our own lab so if you
sign up for our classes we set you up i
don't know what it is now but last time
i was in there was a five node uh setup
so you can get around and see what's
going on whether you're studying for the
admin side or for the programming side
in script writing and if i go into my
oracle virtual box and i go under my
cloudera and i start this up and each
one has their own flavors horton uses
just a login so you log everything in
through a local host through your
internet explorer or i might use chrome
cloudera actually opens up a full
interface you actually are in that setup
and you can see when i started it let me
go back here once i downloaded this this
is a big download by the way i had to
import the appliance in virtualbox uh
the first time i ran it it takes a long
time to configure the setup and the
second time it comes up pretty quick and
with the cloudera quick start again this
is a pretend single node it opens up and
you'll see that it actually has firefox
here so here's my web browser i don't
have to go to localhost i'm actually
already in the quickstart for cloudera
and if we come down here you can see
getting started i have some information
analyze your data manage your cluster
your general information on there and
what i always want to start to do is to
go ahead and open up a terminal window
so we'll open up a terminal widen this a
little bit let me just maximize this out
here so you can see so we are now in a
virtual machine this virtual machine is
centos linux so i'm on a linux computer
on my windows computer and so when i'm
on this terminal window this is your
basic terminal if i do list you'll see
documents eclipse these are the
different things that are installed with
the quick start guide on the linux
system so this is a linux computer and
then hadoop is running on here so now i
have hadoop single node so it has both
the name node and the data node and
everything squished together in one
virtual machine we can then do let's do
hdfs telling it that it's a hadoop file
system dfs minus ls now notice the ls is
the same i have ls for list and ls for
list and i click on here it'll take you
just a second reading the hadoop file
system and it comes up with nothing so a
quick recap let's go back over this
three different environments i have this
one out here let's just put this in a
bright red so you can actually see it i
have this environment out here which is
my slides i have this environment here
where i did a list that's looking at the
files on the linuxcentos computer and
then we have this system here which is
looking at the files on the hadoop file
system so three completely separate
environments and then we connect them
and so right now we have i have whatever
files i have my personal files and the
um of course we're also looking at the
screen for my windows 10 and then we're
looking at the screen here
here's our list there's looking at the
files and this is the screen for centos
linux and then this is looking at the
files right here for the hadoop file
system so three completely separate
files this one here which is the linux
is running in a virtual box so this is a
virtual box i'm using one core to run it
or one cpu and everything in there is it
has its own file system you can see we
have our desktop and documents and
whatever in there and then you can see
here we right now have no files in our
hadoop file system and this hadoop file
system currently is stored on the linux
machine but it could be stored across 10
linux machines 20 100 this could be
stored across in petabytes i mean it
could be really huge or it could just be
in this case just a demo we're putting
it on just one computer and then once
we're in here let me just see real quick
if i can go under view zoom in view zoom
in and this is just a standard browser
so i can use any like the control plus
and stuff like that to zoom in and this
is very common to be in a browser window
with the hadoop file system so right now
i'm in a linux and i'm going to do oh
let's just create a file we'll go file
my new file and i'm going to use vi and
this is a vi editor just a basic editor
and we go ahead and type something in
here
one two three four maybe it's columns 44
66 77. of course i do file system just
like your regular computer can also so
in our vi editor you hit your colon i
actually work with a lot of different
other editors and we'll write quit vi so
let's take a look and see what happened
here i'm in my linux system i type in ls
for list and we should see my new file
and sure enough we do over here there it
is let me just highlight that my new
file and if i then go into the hadoop
system hdfs dfs minus ls for list we
still show nothing it's still empty so
what i can simply do is i can go hdfs
dfs
minus put and then we're going to put my
new file and this is just going to move
it from the linux system because i'm in
this file folder into the hadoop file
system and now if we go in and we type
in our list for a new file system you
will see in here that i now have just
the one file on there which is my new
file and very similar to linux we can do
cat and the cat command simply
evokes reading the file so hd fs dfs
minus cat and i had to look it up
remember cloudera the the format is
going to be a user uh then of course the
path location and the file name and in
here when we did the list here's our
list
so you can see it lists our file here
and we realize that this is under user
cloudera and so i can now go user
cloudera my new file and the minus cat
and we'll be able to read the file in
here and you can see right here this is
the file that was in the linux system is
now copied into the cloudera system and
it's one three four five that what i
entered in there and if we go back to
the linux and do list you'll still see
it in here my new file and we can also
do something like this in our hdfs minus
mv i will do my new file and we're going
to change it to my new new file and if
we do that underneath our hadoop file
system the minus mv will rename it so if
i go back here to our hadoop file system
ls you'll now see instead of my new file
it has my new new file coming up and
there it is my new new files we've
renamed it we can also go in here and
delete this so i can now come in here so
in our hdfs dfs we can also do a remove
and this will remove the file and so if
we come in here we run this we'll see
that when i come back and do the list
the file is gone and now we just have
another empty uh folder with our hadoop
file system and just like any file
system we can take this and we can go
ahead and make directory create a new
directory so mk for make directory we'll
call this my dir so we're going to make
a directory in my dir it'll take it just
a second and of course if we do
the list command you'll see that we now
have the directory in there give it just
a second there it comes mydir and just
like we did before i can go in here and
we're going to put the file and if you
remember correctly from our files in the
setup i called it my new file so this is
coming from the linux system and we're
going to put that into my dir that's the
target in my hadoop setup and so if i
hit enter on there i can now do uh the
hadoop list and that's not going to show
the file because remember i put it in a
sub folder so if i do the kajuk just
this will show my directory and i can do
list and then i can do my dur for my
directory and you'll see underneath the
my directory in the hadoop file system
it now has my new file put in there and
with any good operating system we need a
minus help so just like you can type in
help in your linux you can now come in
here and type in hdfs help and it shows
you a lot of the commands in there
underneath the hadoop file system most
of them should be very similar to the
linux on here and we can also do
something like this a hadoop version and
the hadoop version shows up that we're
in hadoop 2.60 um cdh is it we're
cloudera 5 and compiled by jenkins and
it has a date and all the different
information on our hadoop file system so
this is some basics in the terminal
window let me go ahead and close this
out because if you're going to play with
this you should really come in here let
me just maximize the cloud data it opens
up in a browser window and so once we're
in here again this is a browser window
which you could access might look like
any access for a hadoop file system one
of the fun things to do when you're
first starting is to go under hue you'll
see it up here at the top has cloudera
hue hadoop your hbase your impala your
spark these are standard installs now
and hue is basically an overview of the
file system and so come up here and you
can see where you can do queries as far
as if you have a hbase or a hive
the hive database we go over here to the
top where it says file browser and if we
go under file browser now this is a
hadoop file system we're looking at and
once we open up the file browser you can
now see there's my directory which we
created and if i click on my directory
there's my new file which is in here and
if i click on my new file it actually
opens it up and you can see from our
hadoop file system this is in the hadoop
file system the file that we created so
we covered the terminal window you can
see here's a terminal window up here it
might be if you were in a web browser
it'll look a little different because it
actually opens up as a web browser
terminal window and we've looked a
little bit at hue which is one of the
most basic components of hadoop one of
the original components for going
through and looking at your data and
your databases of course now they're up
to the hue four it's gone through a
number of changes and you can see
there's a lot of different choices in
here for other different tools in the
hadoop file system and i'll go ahead and
just close out of this and one of the
cool things with the virtual
box i can either save the machine state
send the shutdown signal or power off
the machine i'll go and just power off
the machine completely now suppose you
have a library that has a collection of
huge number of books on each floor and
you want to count the total number of
books present on each floor what would
be your approach you could say i will do
it myself but then don't you think that
will take a lot of time and that's
obviously not an efficient way of
counting the number of books in this
huge collection on every floor by
yourself now there could be a different
approach or an alternative to that you
could think of asking three of your
friends or three of your colleagues and
you could then say if each friend could
count the books on every floor then
obviously that would make your work
faster and easier to count the books on
every floor now this is what we mean by
parallel processing so when you say
parallel processing in technical terms
you are talking about using multiple
machines and each machine would be
contributing its ram and cpu cores for
processing and your data would be
processed on multiple machines at the
same time now this type of process
involves parallel processing in our case
or in our library example where you
would have person 1 who would be taking
care of books on floor 1 and counting
them person 2 on floor 2 then you have
someone on floor 3 and someone on floor
4. so every individual would be counting
the books on every floor in parallel so
that reduces the time consumed for this
activity and then there should be some
mechanism where all these counts from
every floor can be aggregated so what is
each person doing here each person is
mapping the data of of a particular
floor or you can say each person is
doing a kind of activity or basically a
task on every floor and the task is
counting the books on every floor now
then you could have some aggregation
mechanism that could basically reduce or
summarize this total count and in terms
of map reduce we would say that's the
work of reducer so when you talk about
hadoop mapreduce it processes data on
different node machines now this is the
whole concept of hadoop framework right
that you not only have your data stored
across machines but you would also want
to process the data locally so instead
of transferring the data from one
machine to other machine or bringing all
the data together into some central
processing unit and then processing it
you would rather have the data processed
on the machines wherever that is stored
so we know in case of hadoop cluster we
would have our data stored on multiple
data nodes on their multiple disks and
that is the data which needs to be
processed but the requirement is that we
want to process this data as fast as
possible and that could be achieved by
using parallel processing now in case of
mapreduce we basically have the first
phase which is your mapping phase so in
case of mapreduce programming model you
basically have two phases one is mapping
and one is reducing now who takes care
of things in mapping phase it is a
mapper class and this mapper class has
the function which is provided by the
developer which takes care of these
individual map tasks which will work on
multiple nodes in parallel your reducer
class belongs to the reducing phase so a
reducing phase basically uses a reducer
class which provides a function that
will aggregate and reduce the output of
different data nodes to generate the
final output now that's how your
mapreduce works using mapping and then
obviously reducing now you could have
some other kind of jobs which are map
only jobs wherein there is no reducing
required but we are not talking about
those we are talking about our
requirement where we would want to
process the data using mapping and
reducing especially when data is huge
when data is stored across multiple
machines and you would want to process
the data in parallel so when you talk
about mapreduce you could say it's a
programming model you could say
internally it's a processing engine of
hadoop that allows you to process and
compute huge volumes of data and when we
say huge volumes of data we can talk
about terabytes we can talk about
petabytes exabytes and that amount of
data which needs to be processed on a
huge cluster we could also use mapreduce
programming model and run a mapreduce
algorithm in a local mode but what does
that mean if you would go for a local
mode it basically means it would do all
the mapping and reducing on the same
node using the processing capacity that
is ram and cpu cores on the same machine
which is not really efficient in fact we
would want to have our map reduce work
on multiple nodes which would obviously
have mapping phase followed by a
reducing phase and intermittently there
would be data generated there would be
different other phases which help this
whole processing so when you talk about
hadoop map reduce you are mainly talking
about two main components or two main
phases that is mapping and reducing
mapping taking care of map tasks
reducing taking care of reduced tasks so
you would have your data which would be
stored on multiple machines now when we
talk about data data could be in
different formats we could or the
developer could specify what is the
format which needs to be used to
understand the data which is coming in
that data then goes through the mapping
internally there would be some shuffling
sorting and then reducing which gives
you your final output so the way we
access data from sdfs or the way our
data is getting stored on sdfs we have
our input data which would have one or
multiple files in one or multiple
directories and your final output is
also stored on sdfs to be accessed to be
looked into and to see if the processing
was done correctly so this is how it
looks so you have the input data which
would then be worked upon by multiple
map tasks now how many map tasks that
basically depends on the file that
depends on the input format so normally
we know that in a hadoop cluster you
would have a file which is broken down
into blocks depending on its size so the
default block size is 128 mb which can
then still be customized based on your
average size of data which is getting
stored on the cluster so if i have
really huge files which are getting
stored on the cluster i would certainly
set a higher block size so that my every
file does not have huge number of blocks
creating a load on name notes ram
because that's tracking the number of
elements in your cluster or number of
objects in your cluster so depending on
your file size your file would be split
into multiple chunks and for every chunk
we would have a map task running now
what is this map task doing that is
specified within the mapper class so
within the mapper class you have the
mapper function which basically says
what each of these map tasks has to do
on each of the chunks which has to be
processed this data intermittently is
written to sdfs where it is sorted and
shuffled and then you have internal
phases such as partitioner which decides
how many reduced tasks would be used or
what data goes to which reducer you
could also have a combiner phase which
is like a mini reducer doing the same
reduce operation before it reaches
reduce then you have your reducing phase
which is taken care by a reducer class
and internally the reducer function
provided by developer which would have
reduced task running on the data which
comes as an output from map tasks
finally your output is then generated
which is stored on sdfs now in case of
hadoop it accepts data in different
formats your data could be in compressed
format your data could be in part k your
data could be in afro text csv psv
binary format and all of these formats
are supported however remember if you
are talking about data being compressed
then you have to also look into what
kind of split ability the compression
mechanism supports otherwise when
mapreduce processing happens it would
take the complete file as one chunk to
be processed so sdfs accepts input data
in different formats this data is stored
in sdfs and that is basically our input
which is then passing through the
mapping phase now what is mapping phase
doing as i said it reads record by
record depending on the input format it
reads the data so we have multiple map
tasks running on multiple chunks once
this data is being read this is broken
down into individual elements and when i
say individual element i could say this
is my list of key value pairs so your
records based on some kind of delimiter
or without delimiter are broken down
into individual elements and thus your
mac creates key value pairs now these
key value pairs are not my final output
these key value pairs are basically a
list of elements which will then be
subjected to further processing so you
would have internally shuffling and
sorting of data so that all the relevant
key value pairs are brought together
which basically benefits the processing
and then you have your reducing which
aggregates the key value pairs into set
of smaller tuples or tuples as you would
say finally your output is getting
stored in the designated directory as a
list of aggregated key value pairs which
gives you your output so when we talk
about mapreduce one of the key factors
here is the parallel processing which it
can offer so we know that we have data
is getting stored across multiple data
nodes and you would have huge volume of
data which is split and randomly
distributed across data nodes and this
is the data which needs to be processed
and the best way would be parallel
processing so you could have your data
getting stored on multiple data nodes or
multiple slave nodes and each slave node
would have again one or multiple disks
to process this data basically we have
to go for parallel processing approach
we have to use the map reduce now let's
look at the mapreduce workflow to
understand how it works so basically you
have your input data stored on sdfs now
this is the data which needs to be
processed it is stored in input files
and the processing which you want can be
done on one single file or it can be
done on a directory which has multiple
files you could also later have multiple
outputs merged which we achieve by using
something called as chaining of mappers
so here you have your data getting
stored on sdfs now input format is
basically something to define the input
specification and how the input files
will be split so there are various input
formats now we can search for that so we
can go to google and we can basically
search for
hadoop map reduce
yahoo tutorial this is one of the good
links and if i look into this link i can
search for different input formats and
output formats so let's search for input
format so when we talk about input
format you basically have something to
define how input files are split so
input files are split up and read based
on what input format is specified so
this is a class that provides following
functionality it selects the files or
other objects that should be used for
input it defines the input split that
break a file into tasks provides a
factory for record reader objects that
read the file so there are different
formats if you look in the table here
and you can see that the text input
format is the default format which reads
lines of a text file and each line is
considered as a record here the key is
the byte offset of the line and the
value is the line content it says you
can have key value input format which
passes lines into key value pairs
everything up to the first tab character
is the key and the remainder is the line
you could also have sequence file input
format which basically works on binary
format so you have input format and in
the same way you can also search for
output format which takes care of how
the data is handled after the processing
is done so the key value pairs provided
to this output collector are then
written to output files the way they are
written is governed by output format so
it functions pretty much like input
format as described in earlier right so
we could set what is the output format
to be followed and again you have text
output sequence file output format null
output format and so on so these are
different classes which take care of how
your data is handled when it is being
read for processing or how is the data
being written when the processing is
done so based on the input format the
file is broken down into splits and this
logically represents the data to be
processed by individual map tasks or you
could say individual mapper functions so
you could have one or multiple splits
which need to be processed depending on
the file size depending on what
properties have been set now once this
is done you have your input splits which
are subjected to mapping phase
internally you have a record reader
which communicates with the input split
and converts the data into key value
pairs suitable to be read by mapper and
what is mapper doing it is basically
working on these key value pairs the map
task giving you an intermittent output
which would then be forwarded for
further processing now once that is done
and we have these key value pairs which
is being worked upon my map your map
tasks as a part of your mapper function
are generating your key value pairs
which are your intermediate outputs to
be processed further now you could have
as i said a combiner face or internally
a mini radio surface now combiner does
not have its own class so combiner
basically uses the same class as the
reducer class provided by the developer
and its main work is to do the reducing
or its main work is to do some kind of
mini aggregation on the key value pairs
which were generated by map so once the
data is coming in from the combiner then
we have internally a partitioner phase
which decides how outputs from combiners
are sent to the reducers or you could
also say that even if i did not have a
combiner partitioner would decide based
on the keys and values based on the type
of keys how many reducers would be
required or how many reduced tasks would
be required to work on your output which
was generated by map task now once
partitioner has decided that then your
data would be then sorted and shuffled
which is then fed into the reducer so
when you talk about your reducer it
would basically have one or multiple
reduced tasks now that depends on what
or what partitioner decided or
determined for your data to be processed
it can also depend on the configuration
properties which have been set to decide
how many radio stars should be used now
internally all this data is obviously
going through sorting and shuffling so
that your reducing or aggregation
becomes an easier task once we have this
done we basically have the reducer which
is the code for the reducer is provided
by the developer and all the
intermediate data has then to be
aggregated to give you a final output
which would then be stored on sdfs and
who does this you have an internal
record writer which writes these output
key value pairs from reducer to the
output files now this is how your map
reduce works wherein the final output
data can be not only stored but then
read or access from sdfs or even used as
an input for further mapreduce kind of
processing so this is how it overall
looks so you basically have your data
stored on sdfs based on input format you
have the splits then you have record
reader which gives your data to the
mapping phase which is then taken care
by your mapper function and mapper
function basically means one or multiple
map tasks working on your chunks of data
you could have a combiner phase which is
optional which is not mandatory then you
have a partitioner phase which decides
on how many reduced tasks or how many
reducers would be used to work on your
data internally there is sorting and
shuffling of data happening and then
basically based on your output format
your record reader will write the output
to sdfs directory now internally you
could also remember that data is being
processed locally so you would have the
output of each task which is being
worked upon stored locally however we do
not access the data directly from data
nodes we access it from sdfs so our
output is stored on sdfs so that is your
mapreduce workflow when you talk about
mapreduce architecture now this is how
it would look so you would have
basically edge node or a client program
or an api which intends to process some
data so it submits the job to the job
tracker or you can say resource manager
in case of hadoop yarn framework right
now before this step we can also say
that an interaction with name node would
have already happened which would have
given information of data nodes which
have the relevant data stored then your
master processor so in hadoop version 1
we had job tracker and then the slaves
were called task trackers in hadoop
version 2 instead of job tracker you
have resource manager and of task
trackers you have node managers so
basically your resource manager has to
assign the job to the task trackers or
node managers so your node managers as
we discussed in yarn are basically
taking care of processing which happens
on every node so internally there is all
of this work happening by resource
manager node managers and application
master then you can refer to the yarn
based tutorial to understand more about
that so here your processing master is
basically breaking down the application
into tasks what it does internally is
once your application is submitted your
application to be run on yarn processing
framework is handled by resource manager
now forget about the yarn part as of now
i mean who does the negotiating of
resources who allocates them how does
the processing happen on the nodes right
so that's all to do with how yarn
handles the processing request so you
have your data which is stored in sdfs
broken down into one or multiple splits
depending on the input format which has
been specified by the developer your
input splits are to be worked upon by
your one or multiple map tasks which
will be running within the container on
the nodes basically you have the
resources which are being utilized so
for each map task you would have some
amount of ram which will be utilized and
then further the same data which has to
go through reducing phase that is your
reduced task will also be utilizing some
ram and cpu cores now internally you
have these functions which take care of
deciding on number of reducers doing a
mini reduce and basically reading and
processing the data from multiple data
nodes now this is how your mapreduce
programming model makes parallel
processing work or processes your data
which is stored across multiple machines
finally you have your output which is
getting stored on his dfs
so let's have a quick demo on mapreduce
and see how it works on a hadoop cluster
now we have discussed briefly about
mapreduce which contains mainly two
phases that is your mapping phase and
your reducing phase and mapping phase is
taken care by your mapper function and
your reducing phase is taken care by
your reducer function now in between we
also have sorting and shuffling and then
you have other phases which is
partitioner and combiner and we will
discuss about all those in detail in
later sessions but let's have a quick
demo on how we can run a mapreduce which
is already existing as a package jar
file within your apache hadoop cluster
or even in your cloudera cluster now we
can build our own mapreduce programs we
can package them as jar transfer them to
the cluster and then run it on a hadoop
cluster on yarn or we could be using
already provided default program so
let's see where they are now these are
my two machines which i have brought up
and basically this would have my apache
hadoop cluster running now we can just
do a simple start hyphen all dot sh now
i know that this script is deprecated
and it says instead use start dfs and
start yarn but then it will still take
care of starting off my cluster on these
two nodes where i would have one single
name node two data nodes one secondary
name node one resource manager and two
node managers now if you have any doubt
in how this cluster came up you can
always look at the previous sessions
where we had a walkthrough in setting up
a cluster on apache and then you could
also have your cluster running using
less than 3gb of your total machine ram
and you could have apache cluster
running on your machine now once this
cluster comes up we will also have a
look at the web ui which is available
for name node and resource manager now
based on the settings what we have given
our uis will show us details of our
cluster but remember the ui is only to
browse now here my cluster has come up i
can just do a jps to look at java
related processes and that will show me
what are the processes which are running
on c1 which is your data node resource
manager node manager and name node and
on my m1 machine which is my second
machine which i've configured here i can
always do a jps and that shows me the
processes running which also means that
my cluster is up with two data nodes
with two node managers and here i can
have a look at my web ui so i can just
do a refresh and the same thing with
this one just to refresh so i had
already opened the web pages so you can
always access the web ui using your name
notes host name and 570 port it tells me
what is my cluster id what is my blog
pool id it gives you information of what
is the space usage how many live nodes
you have and you can even browse your
file system so i have put in a lot of
data here i can click on browse the file
system and this basically shows me
multiple directories and these
directories have one or multiple files
which we will use for our mapreduce
example now if you see here these are my
directories which have some sample files
although these files are very small like
8.7 kilobytes if you look into this
directory if you look into this i have
just pulled in some of my hadoop logs
and i have put it on my sdfs these are a
little bigger files and then we also
have some other data which we can see
here and this is data which i've
downloaded from web now we can either
run a mapreduce on a single file or in a
directory which contains multiple files
let's look at that before looking at
demo and map reduce also remember
mapreduce will create a output directory
and we need to have that directory
created plus we need to have the
permissions to run the mapreduce job so
by default since i'm running it using
admin id i should not have any problem
but then if
you intend to run mapreduce with a
different user then obviously you will
have to ask the admin or you will have
to give the user permission to read and
write from sdfs so this is the directory
which i have created which will contain
my output once the mapreduce job
finishes and this is my cluster file
system if you look on this ui this shows
me about my yarn which is available for
taking care of any processing it as of
now shows that i have total of 8 gb
memory and i have 8 v cores now that can
be depending on what configuration we
have set or how many nodes are available
we can look at nodes which are available
and that shows me i have two node
managers running each has 8 gb memory
and 8 v cores now that's not true
actually but then we have not set the
configurations for node managers and
that's why it takes the default
properties that is 8 8gb laminate we
course now this is my yarn ui we can
also look at scheduler which basically
shows me the different cues if they have
been configured where you will have to
run the jobs we'll discuss about all
these in later in detail now let's go
back to our terminal and let's see where
we can find some sample applications
which we can run on the cluster so once
i go to the terminal i can well submit
the mapreduce job from any terminal now
here i know that my hadoop related
directory is here and within hadoop you
have various directories we have
discussed that in binaries you have the
commands which you can run in sbin you
basically have the startup scripts and
here you also notice there is a share
directory in the end if you look in the
shared directory you would find hadoop
and within hadoop you have various sub
directories in which we will look for
map reduce now this mapreduce directory
has some sample jar files which we can
use to run a mapreduce on the cluster
similarly if you are working on a
cloudera cluster you would have to go
into opt cloudera parcel cdh slash lib
and in that you would have directories
for sdfs mapreduce or sdfs yarn where
you can still find the same jars it is
basically a package which contains your
multiple applications now how do we run
a mapreduce we can just type in hadoop
and hit enter and that shows me that i
have an option called jar which can be
used to run a jar file now at any point
of time if you would want to see what
are the different classes which are
available in a particular
jar you could always do a jar minus xvf
for example i could say jar xv f and i
could say user local hadoop
share hadoop mapreduce and then list
down your jar file so i'll say hadoop
mapreduce examples and if i do this this
should basically unpack it to show me
what classes are available within this
particular jar and it has done this it
has created a meta file and it has
created a org directory we can see that
by doing a ls and here if you look in ls
org since i ran the command from your
phone directory i can look into org
patchy hadoop examples which shows me
the classes which i have and those
classes contain which mapper or reducer
classes so it might not be just mapper
and reducer but you can always have a
look so for example i am targeting to
use word count program which does a word
count on files and gives me a list of
words and how many times they occur in a
particular file or in set of files and
this shows me that what are the classes
which belong to word count so we have a
in some reducer so this is my reducer
class i have tokenizer mapper that is my
mapper class right and basically this is
what is used these classes are used if
you run a word code now there are many
other programs which are part of this
jar file and we can expand and see that
so
i can say hadoop jar and give your path
so i'll say hadoop jar user local hadoop
share hadoop map reduce hadoop mapreduce
examples and if i hit on enter that will
show me what are the inbuilt classes
which are already available now these
are certain things which we can use now
there are other jar files also for
example i can look at hadoop and here we
can look at the jar files which we have
in this particular path so this is one
hadoop reduce examples which you can use
you can always look in other jar files
like you can look for
hadoop mapreduce client job client and
then you can look at the test one so
that is also an interesting one so you
can always look into hadoop mapreduce
client job client and then you have
something ending with this so if i would
have tried this one using my hadoop jar
command so in my previous example when
we did this it was showing me all the
classes which are available and that
already has a word count now there are
other good programs which you can try
like teragen to generate dummy data
terasort to check your sorting
performance and so on and terra validate
to validate the results similarly we can
also do a hadoop jar as i said on hadoop
mapreduce i think that was client and
then we have job client and then test
star now this has lot of other classes
which can be used or programs which can
be used for doing a stress testing or
checking your cluster status and so on
one of them interesting one is test dfs
io but let's not get into all the
details in first instance let's see how
we can run a mapreduce now if i would
want to run a mapreduce i need to give
hadoop jar and then my jar file and if i
hit on enter it would say it needs the
input and output it needs which class
you want to run so for example i would
say word count and again if i hit on
enter it tells me that you need to give
me some input and output to process and
obviously this processing will be
happening on cluster that is our yarn
processing framework unless and until
you would want to run this job in a
local mode so there is a possibility
that you can run the job in local mode
but let's first try how it runs on the
cluster so how do we do that now here i
can do a hdfs
ls slash command to see what i have on
my sdfs now through my ui i was already
showing you that we have set of files
and directories which we can use to
process now we can take up one single
file so for example if i pick up new
data and i can look into the files here
what we have and we can basically run a
mapreduce on a single file or multiple
files so let's take this file whatever
that contains and i would like to do a
word count so that i get a list of words
and their occurrence in this file so let
me just copy this now i also need my
output to be written and that will be
written here so here if i want to run a
mapreduce i can say hadoop which we can
pull out from history so hadoop jar word
count now i need to give my input so
that will be new data and then i will
give this file which we just copied now
i am going to run the word count only on
a single file and i will basically have
my output which will be stored in this
directory the directory which i have
created already mr output so let's do
this output and this is fair enough now
you can give many other properties you
can specify how many map jobs you want
to run how many reduced jobs you want to
run do you want your output to be
compressed do you want your output to be
merged or many other properties can be
defined when you are specifying word
count and then you can pass in an
argument to pass properties from the
command line which will affect your
output now once i go ahead and submit
this this is basically running a simple
inbuilt mapreduce job on our hadoop
cluster now obviously internally it will
be looking for name node now we have
some issue here and it says the output
already exists what does that mean so it
basically means that hadoop will create
an output for you you just need to give
a name but then you don't need to create
it so let's give let's append the output
with number one and then let's go ahead
and run this so i've submitted this
command now this can also be done in
background if you would want to run
multiple jobs on your cluster at the
same time so it takes total input paths
to processes one so that is there is
only one split on which your job has to
work now it will internally try to
contact your resource manager and
basically this is done so here we can
have a look and we can see some counters
here now what i also see is
for some property which it is missing it
has run the job but it has run in a
local mode it has run in a local mode so
although we have submitted so this might
be related to my yarn settings and we
can check that so if i do a refresh when
i have run my application it has
completed it would have created an
output but the only thing is it did not
interact with your yarn it did not
interact with your resource manager we
can check those properties and here if
we look into the job it basically tells
me that it went for mapping and reducing
it would have created an output it
worked on my file but then it ran in a
local mode it ran in a local mode so
mapreduce remember is a programming
model right now if you run it on yarn
you get the facilities of running it on
a cluster where yarn takes care of
resource management if you don't run it
on yarn and run it on a local mode it
will use your machine's ram and cpu
cores for processing but then we can
quickly look at the output and then we
can also try running this on yarn so if
i look into my hdfs and if i look into
my output mr output that's the directory
which was not used actually let's look
into the other directory which is ending
with one and that should show me the
output created by this mapreduce
although it ran in the local mode it
fetched an input file from usdfs and it
would have created output in hdfs now
that's my part file which is created and
if you look at part minus r minus these
zeros if you would have more than one
reducer running then you would have
multiple such files created we can look
into this what does this file contain
which should have my word count and here
i can say cat which basically shows me
what is the output created by my
mapreduce let's have a look into this so
the file which we gave for processing
has been broken down and now we have the
list of words which occur in the file
plus a count of those words so if there
is some word which is in is more then it
shows me the count so this is a list of
my words and the count for that so this
is how we run a sample mapreduce job i
will also show you how we can run it on
yeah now let's run mapreduce on yarn and
initially when we tried running a
mapreduce it did not hit yarn but it ran
in a local mode and that was because
there was a property which had to be
changed
in mapreduce hyphen site file so
basically if you look into this file the
error was that i had given a property
which says
mapred.framework.name and that was not
the right property name and it was
ignored and that's why it ran in a local
mode so i changed the property to
mapreduce.framework.name
restarted my cluster and everything
should be fine now and that map red
hyphen site file has also been copied
across the nodes now to run a mapreduce
on a hadoop cluster so that it uses yarn
and yarn takes care of resource
allocation on one or multiple machines
so i'm just changing the output here and
now i will submit this job which should
first connect to the resource manager
and if it connects to the resource
manager that means our job will be run
using yarn on the cluster rather than in
a local mode so now we have to wait for
this application to internally connect
to resource manager and once it starts
there we can always go back to the web
ui and check if our application has
reached yarn so it shows me that there
is one input part to be processed that's
my job id that's my application id which
you can even monitor status from the
command line now here the job has been
submitted so let's go back here and just
do a refresh on my yarn ui which should
show me the new application which is
submitted it tells me that it is an
accepted state application master has
already started and if you click on this
link it will also give you more details
of how many map and reduced tasks would
run so as of now it says the application
master is running it would be using this
node which is m1 we can always look into
the logs we can see that there is a one
task attempt which is being made and now
if i go back to my terminal i will see
that it is waiting to get some resources
from the cluster and once it gets the
resources it will first start with the
mapping phase where the mapper function
runs it does the map tasks one or
multiple depending on the splits so
right now we have one file and one split
so we will have just one map task
running and once the mapping phase
completes then it will get into reducing
which will finally give me my output so
we can be toggling through these
sessions so here i can just do a refresh
to see what is happening with my
application is it proceeding is it still
waiting for resource manager to allocate
some resources now just couple of
minutes back i tested this application
on yarn and we can see that my first
application completed successfully and
here we will have to give some time so
that yarn can allocate the resources now
if the resources were used by some other
application they will have to be freed
up now internally yarn takes care of all
that which we will learn more detail in
yarn or you might have already followed
the yarn based session now here we will
have to just give it some more time and
let's see if my application proceeds
with the resources what yarn can
allocate to it sometimes you can also
see a slowness in what web ui shows up
and that can be related to the amount of
memory you have allocated to your notes
now for apache we can have less amount
of memory and we can still run the
cluster and as i said the memory which
shows up here 16 gb and 16 cores is not
the true one those are the default
settings right but then my yarn should
be able to facilitate running of this
application let's just give it a couple
of seconds and then let's look into the
output here again i had to make some
changes in the settings because our
application was not getting enough
resources and then basically i restarted
my cluster now let's submit the
application again to the cluster which
first should contact the resource
manager and then basically the map and
reduce process to start so here i've
submitted an application it is
connecting to the resource manager and
then basically it will start internally
in app master that is application master
it is looking for the number of splits
which is one it's getting the
application id and it basically then
starts running the job it also gives you
a tracking url to look at the output and
now we should go back and look at our
yarn ui if our application shows up here
and we will have to give it a couple of
seconds when it can get the final status
change to running and that's where my
application will be getting resources
now if you closely notice here i have
allocated specific amount of memory that
is 1.5 gb for node manager on every node
and i have basically given two cores
each which my machines also have and my
yarn should be utilizing these resources
rather than going for default now the
application has started moving
and we can see the progress bar here
which basically will show what is
happening and if we go back to the
terminal it will show that first it went
in deciding map and reduce it goes for
map once the mapping phase completes
then the reducing phase will come into
existence and here my job has completed
so now it has basically used we can
always look at how many map and reduce
sas were run it shows me that there was
one map and one reduced task now with
the number of map tasks depends on the
number of splits and we had just one
file which is less than 128 mb so that
was one split to be processed and
reduced task is internally decided by
the reducer or depending on what kind of
property has been set in hadoop config
files now it also tells me how many
input records were read which basically
means these were the number of lines in
the file it tells me output records
which gives me the number of total words
in the file now there might be
duplicates and that which is processed
by internal combiner further processing
or forwarding that information to
reducer and basically reducer works on 3
35 records gives us a list of words and
their count now if i do a refresh here
this would obviously show my application
is completed it says succeeded you can
always click on the application to look
for more information it tells me where
it ran now we do not have a history
server running as of now otherwise we
can always access more information so
this leads to history server where all
your applications are stored but i can
click on this attempt tasks and this
will basically show me the history url
or you can always look into the logs so
this is how you can submit a sample
application which is inbuilt which is
available in the jar on your hadoop
cluster and that will utilize your
cluster to run now you could always as i
said when you are running a particular
job remember to change the output
directory and if you would not want it
to be processing is a single individual
file you could also point it to a
directory that basically means it will
have multiple files and depending on the
file sizes there would be multiple
splits and according to that multiple
map tasks will be selected so if i click
on this this would submit my second
application to the cluster which should
first connect to resource manager then
resource manager has to start an
application master now here we are
targeting 10 splits now you have to
sometimes give couple of seconds in your
machines so that the resources which
were used are internally already freed
up so that your cluster can pick it up
and then your yarn can take care of
resources so right now my application is
an undefined status but then as soon as
my yarn provides it the resources we
will have the application running on our
yarn cluster so it has already started
if you see it is going further then it
would launch 10 map tasks and it would
the number of reduced stars would be
decided on either the way your data is
or based on the properties which have
been set at your cluster level let's
just do a quick refresh here on my yarn
ui to show me the progress also take
care that when you are submitting your
application you need to have the output
directory mentioned however do not
create it hadoop will create that for
you now this is how you run a mapreduce
without specifying properties but then
you can specify more properties you can
look into what are the things which can
be changed for your mapper and reducer
or basically having a combiner class
which can do a mini reducing and all
those things can be done so we will
learn about that in the later sessions
now in this tutorial we will have some
demos on running a mapreduce and
processing data to solve some real-time
business problems now i have set up some
code in eclipse which can be either
tested on your windows machine by
running it in a local mode or packaging
your code in jar transferring it to your
cluster and then basically running it on
your cluster nodes so we'll see both of
these examples now let's assume and
let's understand about a problem say for
example we have a telecom based company
which would want to process its data say
it would want to find out the number of
subscribers and the kind of calls they
are making or for example let's imagine
a online website or a music website
where users listen to various tracks the
data gets collected and then basically
it has to be processed so imagine you
have a company which is
hosting music online and you have users
who either are subscribers or basically
create their accounts listen to
different tracks and then basically use
these services now what if i would want
to process such data for example if i
would want to find out what is the
number of unique listeners or number of
times the track was shared with other
users or number of times the track was
listened to on the radio or in total or
even was skipped on the radio now in
that case i would want to process the
data to find out information so we will
solve this kind of problem using the
mapreduce programming model the
mapreduce approach which as i explained
earlier goes for mapping and then for
goes for reducing and in between it has
different phases that is shuffling and
sorting you have your partitioner phase
you have a mini reducer which is your
combiner face although all of these
intermittent phases are taken care by
the framework itself the developer or
the person who is developing the
solution is responsible to work on the
mapper function and the reducer function
now for that we can basically be writing
our code to process this data by giving
a mapper and a reducer function data we
can look into example and say for
example let me pull out some data here
let's look in say some files i have and
for example in this case it would be
this kind of data now that magnitude
could be anything right now here i have
the data which the first column talks as
the user id or the membership id the
second is the track id you have then
your if the track was shared online the
fourth one is number of times the track
was listened to in total and the fifth
one is if a particular track was skipped
now i could have this data in huge
numbers and then i could be processing
it but we will take a simple small
example to understand how mapreduce does
this so this is a file which i have
already uploaded on the cluster and
which will be as my input file now let's
look at the code so what we would need
is for this kind of processing we would
first need to understand the data now
here the first column as i said is user
id and second one is track id which can
then be used to basically process the
data we need to write a mapper class
which would emit the track id from this
data so i have it here and let me also
open up a constant class for this which
is here so as i mentioned we will have
to write a mapper class which would emit
track id from the data and user ids with
some intermediate key value pairs now
that is what your mapping phase does it
works on the input splits it basically
does the mapping and it gives you a list
of data elements which are nothing but
your intermediate key value pairs to
explain it in a simple way i would say
just let's work on this data sequence so
let's create a constant class as shown
here so this is my package now i create
a class called last fm constants and
then i am here declaring some variables
with some constant values for each of
the field which i just showed in the
file you have user id you have track id
you have is scrabbled or shared radio
and is skipped now these are my constant
which will be used while i process then
we will have to work on a mapper class
which could or which would immediate
emit intermediate key value pairs that
is your track id and user id now how do
we do that so here is an example so we
basically would have a mapper class
as it's seen here this is my mapper
class which will be used to process or
do the mapping phase now here we have
the class name which is unique listener
and unique listeners mapper which
extends the mapper class that means i
would have to import the relevant
packages for my code which i have done
on the top here then i have variables
that is track id user id which use in
try table so hadoop has its own data
types say in writable long writable
boolean writable which are similar to
what you have in java as int boolean
long but these data types which are used
by hadoop are basically an
implementation of writable and writable
comparable interfaces so those are two
interfaces which are then responsible
for these classes which we are using as
data types in our code here we start our
map task which would then consider key
which is an object value as in text and
then you have your data types that is
incredible text and object we are also
handling exception and then what we do
is we work on the file so we would split
it based on the delimiter now in my case
the delimiter is a pipe then what we do
is we set for the track id using our
constants that is what we have seen here
which is for your user id track id and
so on and we do the same thing we for
our user id we look into the values and
then we basically emit out just the
track id and user id that would be my
intermediate key value pairs now here i
am also using a counter named invalid
record count now that is mainly to count
if there are any invalid records which
do not exist in the file in an expected
format now you know we don't do this
in case of invalid records if we don't
do this what would happen our if we had
invalid records in our file then our
program might fail and that's the reason
i'm using counters.invalidrecord.count
and i'm going to use it for my mapper
once we have our mapper written which
basically will look into the file and
emit the track id and user id then i
would write my reducer class now this is
how my reducer class looks where i am
saying public static class unique
listener reducer which extends reducer
class and then the data types which it
would need so in writable for the values
which it works on so our reduced task
will work on track id and this reducer
class is to aggregate the results so we
cannot directly use some reducer as the
records we are getting are not unique
the records might be duplicates it might
be the same user with the same
membership id listening to a different
track or sharing it and we cannot be
just using a generic reducer so here we
work on the reducer and this is how my
code would look so what my reducer does
it basically would help me in solving
the problem such as basically
aggregating and counting the number of
tracks which were shared or listened to
or overall the number of tracks and then
you have your tracks which were skipped
one of the main task of your reducer
class is on working on the intermediate
data which is created by your mapper or
you can say multiple map tasks which
would be running on multiple splits on
one or multiple nodes and your reducers
work is to aggregate the result based on
the keys here we are using set to
eliminate duplicate user ids now once we
have written our reducer class which
basically works on the user id set it
eliminates the duplicate user ids and
then it basically gives me a count of
the track ids in an aggregated way to
solve my use case once i've done that i
also need a driver class which basically
tells about my overall code so here we
are having a job configuration where i
say my name of the job could be unique
listeners per track i am setting the jar
by class calling it as unique listeners
that's my class i'm mentioning my mapper
i'm mentioning my reducer now if you
notice i'm not using a combiner class
for this use case we would not need that
so combiner class is a mini reducer
which basically helps in reducing the
data or aggregating the data before it
reaches the reducer class i am also
talking about the key which would be
using in writable and then the value
which would also be integratable as all
my values are in numeric if i had my key
in something else or if i had names
instead of user id then i could have
used text class i also specify what
would be my input and output path which
will be specified as an argument and
then basically i am printing out number
of invalid records so this is my
mapreduce program to work on solving our
business use case also notice i am using
the relevant packages which are being
used in the code and for these packages
and for my this code to compile we need
to make sure that we have added the
right dependencies now you could have
created your code with pom and using
maven or based on the classes what you
are using you can always add the jars
the relevant jars to the build path so
here we can look at the build path what
i have and we can see what jars i have
used so the main ones are your commons i
have hadoop core now you can ignore hive
or json json which i have here those are
for different applications so the main
is common cli and hadoop core depending
on what you are using within your
application so that has to be added to
your build path also we are having the
java 1.8 now if i wanted to run this
application or test it on my local
machine i could have also set up the
configurations however it is preferred
to run the code on a yarn based cluster
if you would want to try it on windows
then you can always go to the run
configuration you can basically specify
your application which you would want to
run you can then say what is your class
name you can be passing in your
arguments here and in your environment
you can specify hadoop as a local ip
however i suggest package it as jar and
run it on a cluster so what you could do
is you could select your class now my
unique listeners dot java class is also
getting the constants from last fm
constants so both of them belong to the
same project and i'm using that here
for my mapper and for my reducer so in
mapper i refer to last fm constants
where i've given constant values for all
of these fields once you have your code
ready you can always package it as jar
by saying export and select the jar
option in java click on next and then
you can select your project and give it
a name so i have i'm pointing into a
different jar file but i can do a browse
i've already packaged it as jar and you
can see i have a jar here so i can
select this i can say save and that
would be my jar if i'm making some
changes it will anyways overwrite it
once you have your jar ready what you
need to do is place it on your cluster
now i have already done that i have a
cluster here let me bring it up and what
we can do is you can use different ways
you can have a apache cluster you could
have a cloud data cluster wherein you
need to place so let's get into this now
here i'm using a already set up lab
environment you can be doing an ftp you
can upload your code using hue i have
done an ftp from my local machine and
uploaded it to the cluster i could click
on web console which basically gives me
a console to try out things you could as
i said you need the jar and then you
need to push your jar to your cluster
let me login here and once i'm logged in
i am on a edge node which allows me to
connect to a cluster which is clouderas
based and now i can check on my hdfs
path in my user directory i should have
multiple files and directories and in
one of the directories i have placed in
this file so we can look in here which
is sample mr in and that's my directory
where i have the input so i can look in
sample mr in and the same file which i
showed in the beginning i have uploaded
it here which is the listeners file
which we can even check so i can say
listeners.txt
and i can even do a cat so this is the
file which is already existing here
which has the content which we spoke
about although not huge content but it
is more than enough for us to test our
code and obviously we can upload huge
data and then have the same mapreduce
program helping us in answering our
questions we also need the jar file and
the jar file should be here which i have
uploaded so i need to run this now to
run your mapreduce you can say hadoop
jar you will give your jar name which is
this one now i need to give my package
name with my class name so i'll say org
example hadoop codes and then i need to
give my class which is unique listeners
now if i hit enter here it will ask me
to give an input and output as my code
says to pass in the arguments so we will
pass in the arguments here so i will say
my directory where i have the data now i
could be picking up one file or multiple
files to process this so i will say just
one file which is
here
and that's my
file which is
sample mr in that is what i want to use
so i'll say
sample mr in and i need to give my file
name so i can say listeners.txt
and then i can give an output which will
get created when you run your mapreduce
so i can say sample mr and then i can
say output 1 and this is the directory
which will get created which will have
my output now you can run this job in
this way you can even run it in a local
mode by specifying arguments on the
command line you can give different kind
of properties if you want your mapreduce
jobs output to be in a compressed format
you can do all that so let's run this
and this should connect to the resource
manager the job is processing one input
file it will start with the mapping
phase first now it looks that the job
has failed due to some reason let's have
a look i just looked into the job and i
realized why it failed the main reason
was i was trying to write an output in
the directory to which i don't have
access i need to have access to write
the output in a directory to which my
user id has permissions for this we will
have to submit the job again with the
right path where it can write the output
so we can do this this is my class i
need input so i'll say and then we can
say sample mr in and i'm looking for
listeners dot txt and i need to give an
output which should be in this path and
then we can say sample mr output 1 and
then submit the job now once i have
submitted the job as i said it has one
input part to process it is working on
one split because the file which we are
trying to work on is smaller than the
block size it goes for the mapping phase
and then it goes for reducing and it's
done so if you carefully look at the
mapreduce output here it says the number
of outputs it had to process was just
four so every line by default is
considered as a record and we had
totally four lines the output is
basically working on again giving you
four records right because we are doing
a split based on the delimiter then this
would become an input to combiner if we
had a combiner class but we don't use
that so the output from your map goes to
the reduce which will basically work on
the input records and create output
records now we can have a look at this
the output of this job which is stored
in hdfs and i can either be giving a
complete path or i can just mention the
directory which i used and that should
by default take me to the directory
which should have my output now based on
how many reduced tasks were used you
will have number of part files which
show up here so we have one map and one
reduced task that could have controlled
or that could have been controlled by
giving things on the command line so
here i have run it in a yarn mode where
yarn was used to allocate resources for
my applications and we can always check
that on the yarn ui or also by going to
say cloudera manager if that is
available if you're not using cloudera's
cluster then you can always in apache
cluster go to your yarn and you can go
into the ui wherever your resource
manager is running so that is one option
or if you have a cloud error cluster you
can look in applications which will show
all the applications which were recently
run so this was the thing which failed
earlier because of permissions and this
is the one which succeeded now i have a
job id which can always take me to the
yarn ui the history server where i see
how many map and jobs were run and for
further information you can always go
and look into the map and reduce tasks
so this was a map task which ran within
a container which was allocated by your
yarn and we can also look on the node
and logs what really happened you can
also look into the reduced task you can
also look at the counters which we were
seeing on the command line on how many
map and reduced tasks how many bytes
were read what was the garbage
collection time how much cpu time was
spent in milliseconds and you get all
the counters here you can specifically
be looking at counters for map or for
reduce so your yarn ui helps you to look
into for more information now if i go
back to my console and i have the output
file i can basically look into it by
selecting the output file and i can do a
cat which basically will show me what is
my output so this is my mapreduce and
basically what it has done has it has
aggregated and pulled out the
information for your different listeners
based on the data what we have provided
let's look at one more example of using
mapreduce programming model to solve a
real-time business case or a problem now
the problem in hand is that we have some
data collected from a telecom giant and
basically we have some sample data here
which lists the list of subscribers
which are using the services now if i
look into the file i have call data
records which basically gives me
information about the data collected by
a telecom company so this telecom
company keeps records of its subscribers
and it calls this particular file as
call data records now what does this
call data records contain it basically
has a from phone number as the first
field it has the two phone number that
is call being made to a particular
number then we have the call start time
following a time timestamp you have a
call n time and then we have finally if
this call was a distance call or what we
call as std call now what we need to do
is we need to use our knowledge of
mapreduce we need to use the mapreduce
programming model and we need to come up
with a code to find out all the phone
numbers for example who were making more
than 60 minutes of std calls now here
the flag 1 basically means it was an std
call and 0 means it was a local call how
do we do that using mapreduce so this is
again a problem where you would want to
count through the data and you would
want to aggregate the values to come up
with result so let's look at a sample
code for this one so here i have my
eclipse and again like a previous
example we are having a class which
declares some constants for the fields
so you have phone number with zero phone
number with one call start time call end
time and an std flag so these are the
constants which i would be using in my
code and here is my main class which
will use the mapreduce basically to
solve this problem now i'm importing the
packages and as i explained earlier
these packages are mainly to make sure
that we can use the classes in our code
in the right way so here now the order
of your driver class or your mapper and
reducer does not matter right the first
thing what we need is we need a mapper
which will do the map task so here i am
creating a mapper which is tokenizer
mapper and that extends your mapper
class it accepts the data types that is
object text and long writable as
explained earlier these are your data
types which are hadoop specific and data
types like intritable long writable
boolean writable and many others depend
on the writable and writable comparable
interfaces now here we start with taking
up our phone number we basically also
take duration in minutes so these are
the variables and i'm using the
appropriate data type for those then i
start writing my map task now what does
my map task do it basically works on the
string which we have and it breaks it
into individual elements based on a
delimiter once that is done then we are
also checking if that particular string
which we are looking for has a std flag
because we would want to find out how
many customers or how many of them were
making phone calls which were more than
60 minutes and if these calls were std
calls then basically i work on the phone
number and i set it using the cdr
constants for which we have already
created a class using the phone number
call end time call start time and i also
compute or calculate the long duration
because we need to find out the calls
which were more than 60 minutes finally
we extract the phone numbers and the
duration of the call made by a
particular phone number so this would be
my mapper giving an intermediate output
which would then have to be sorted and
shuffled and then handed over to reducer
what does my reducer do it uses the
right data types it basically starts
with is sum as 0 it will look into all
the keys and values and wherever it
would find keys which are repeating and
the duration is more than 60 it would
give me an aggregated result this is my
reducer and finally we have a driver as
i explained earlier which has job
configuration your mapper reducer and
also we are using just as an example a
combiner class which does not have a
class of its own but it is basically
using the same reducer class once your
code is ready check if it compiles check
if you have all the dependencies met and
package it as jar transfer it to the
cluster and run it with or on top of
yarn so what we can do is i have already
moved it here and we can look into this
machine i already have my jar file which
basically also needs a input which i
have already pushed to my cluster so we
can look in for the file which should be
existing in sample mr in directory which
is within my user and my name directory
and i have the call data records which
basically shows the data which i was
showing in the notepad file now i can
say hadoop jar and point it to my jar
which is
std subscribers jar we need to use the
package so i'll say or example hadoop
codes that's my package and my class
name my class name is
std subscribers so i will say std
subscribers dot and then you need to
give your input so we will say sample m
are in and i will given a particular
file which is call data records dot txt
and then we can point it to an output
directory which will get created
automatically so i will say output 2 and
that should have my result and like we
ran our first example now i am again
running it on one simple file you can
imagine this as you can replace one
single file with a directory which has
multiple files where it might be the
telecom company was already collecting
data for a couple of months and they
would like to analyze this and you can
run it in this way so once this is done
we have our output which can be seen by
going into the directory saying sample
mr output 2 and again this would have
gone for one single reducer so we can
look at whatever we gave as an output so
it was sample mr
output 2 and that is
my directory so since this is a
directory my cat command does not work
on it you need to give the file so the
command is by giving the specific file
not by giving the directory so it is cat
sample mr output to slash part minus r
and then you can give five zeros and
that should be my out which should give
me an information of which were the
users or which were the phone numbers
which made calls greater than 60 minutes
and if these calls were std calls and
what was the duration of the call so
this is how you can use mapreduce
programming model to solve your
real-time business cases always remember
you have to code and create your mapper
and reducer function and rest will be
done by the framework hadoop version 1
or mapreduce version 1. well that's
outdated now and nobody is using hadoop
version 1 but it would be good to
understand what was in hadoop version 1
and what were the limitations of hadoop
version 1 which brought in the thought
for the future processing layer that is
yarn now when we talk about hadoop we
already know that hadoop is a framework
and hadoop has two layers one is your
storage layer that is your sdfs hadoop
distributed file system which allows for
distributed storage and processing which
allows fault tolerance by inbuilt
replication and which basically allows
you to store huge amount of data across
multiple commodity machines when we talk
about processing we know that mapreduce
is the oldest and the most mature
processing programming model which
basically takes care of your data
processing on your distributed file
system so in hadoop person one mapreduce
performed both data processing and
resource management and that's how it
was problematic in mapreduce we had
basically when we talk about the
processing layer we had the master which
was called job tracker and then you had
the slaves which were the task records
so your job tracker was taking care of
allocating resources it was performing
scheduling and even monitoring the jobs
it basically was taking care of
assigning map and reduced tasks to the
jobs running on task trackers and task
trackers which were co-located with data
nodes were responsible for processing
the jobs so task trackers were the
slaves for the processing layer which
reported their progress to the job
tracker so this is what was happening in
hadoop version 1. now when we talk about
hadoop version 1 we would have say
client machines or an api or an
application which basically submits the
job to the master that is job tracker
now obviously we cannot forget that
there would already be an involvement
from name node which basically tells
which are the machines or which are the
data nodes where the data is already
stored now once the job submission
happens to the job tracker job tracker
being the master demon for taking care
of your processing request and also
resource management job scheduling would
then be interacting with your multiple
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines so each machine would
have a task tracker running and that
task tracker which is a processing slave
would be co-located with the data nodes
now we know that in case of hadoop you
have the concept of moving the
processing to wherever the data is
stored rather than moving the data to
the processing layer so we would have
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines and these task
trackers would be responsible for
handling the tasks what are these tasks
these are the application which is
broken down into smaller tasks which
would work on the data which is
respectively stored on that particular
node now these were your slave demons
right so your job tracker was not only
tracking the resources so your task
trackers were sending heartbeats they
were sending in packets and information
to the job tracker which would then be
knowing how many resources and when we
talk about resources we are talking
about the cpu cores we are talking about
the ram which would be available on
every node so task trackers would be
sending in their resource information to
job tracker and your job tracker would
be already aware of what amount of
resources are available on a particular
node how loaded a particular node is
what kind of work could be given to the
task tracker so job tracker was taking
care of resource management and it was
also breaking the application into tasks
and doing the job scheduling part assign
different tasks to these slave demons
that is your task trackers so job
tracker was
eventually overburdened right because it
was managing jobs it was tracking the
resources from multiple task trackers
and basically it was taking care of job
scheduling so job tracker would be
overburdened and in a case if job
tracker would fail then it would affect
the overall processing so if the master
is skilled if the master demand dies
then the processing cannot proceed now
this was one of the limitations of
hadoop version one so when you talk
about scalability that is the capability
to scale due to a single job tracker
scalability would be hitting a bottle
link you cannot have a cluster size of
more than 4000 nodes and cannot run more
than 40 000 concurrent tasks now that's
just a number we could always look into
the individual resources which each
machine was having and then we can come
up with an appropriate number however
with a single job tracker there was no
horizontal scalability for the
processing layer because we had single
processing master now when we talk about
availability job tracker as i mentioned
would be a single point of failure now
any failure kills all the queued and
running jobs and jobs would have to be
resubmitted now why would we want that
in a distributed platform in a cluster
which has hundreds and thousands of
machines we would want a processing
layer which can handle huge amount of
processing which could be more scalable
which could be more available and could
handle different kind of workloads when
it comes to resource utilization now if
you would have a predefined number of
map and reduce slots for each task
tracker you would have issues which
would relate to resource utilization and
that again is putting a burden on the
master which is tracking these resources
which has to assign jobs which can run
on multiple machines in parallel so
limitations in running non-mapreduce
applications now that was one more
limitation of hadoop version 1 and
mapreduce that the only kind of
processing you could do is mapreduce and
mapreduce programming model although it
is good it is oldest it has matured over
a period of time but then it is very
rigid you will have to go for mapping
and reducing approach and that was the
only kind of processing which could be
done in hadoop person one so when it
comes to doing a real time analysis or
doing ad hoc query or doing a graph
based processing or massive parallel
processing there were limitations
because that could not be done in hadoop
version 1 which was having mapreduce
version 1 as the processing component
now that brings us to the need for yarn
so yarn it stands for yet another
resource negotiator so as i mentioned
before yarn in hadoop version one well
you could have applications which could
be written in different programming
languages but then the only kind of
processing which was possible was
mapreduce we had the storage layer we
had the processing but then kind of
limited processing which could be done
now this was one thing which brought in
a thought that why shouldn't we have a
processing layer which can handle
different kind of workloads as i
mentioned might be graph processing
might be real time processing might be
massive parallel processing or any other
kind of processing which would be a
requirement of an organization now
designed to run mapreduce jobs only and
having issues in scalability resource
utilization job tracking etc that led to
the need of something what we call as
yarn now from hadoop version 2 onwards
we have the two main layers have changed
a little bit you have the storage layer
which is intact that is your hdfs and
then you have the processing layer which
is called yarn yet another resource
negotiator now we will understand how
yarn works but then yarn is taking care
of your processing layer it does support
mapreduce so mapreduce processing can
still be done but then now you can have
a support to other processing frameworks
yarn can be used to solve the issues
which hadoop version one was posing
something like resource management
something like different kind of
workload processing something like
scalability resource utilization all
that is now taken care by yarn now when
we talk about yarn we can have now a
cluster size of more than 10 000 nodes
and can run more than 100 000 concurrent
tasks that's just to take care of your
scalability when you talk about
compatibility applications which were
developed for hadoop version 1 which
were primarily mapreduce kind of
processing can run on yarn without any
disruption or availability issues when
you talk about resource utilization
there is a mechanism which takes care of
dynamic allocation of cluster resources
and this basically improves the resource
utilization when we talk about
multi-tenancy so basically now the
cluster can handle different kind of
workloads so you can use open source and
proprietary data access engines you can
perform real-time analysis you can be
doing graph processing you can be doing
ad hoc querying and this can be
supported for multiple workloads which
can run in parallel so this is what yarn
offers so what is yan as i mentioned
yarn stands for yet another resource
negotiator so it is the cluster resource
management layer for your apache hadoop
ecosystem which takes care of scheduling
jobs and assigning resources now just
imagine when you would want to run a
particular application you would
basically be telling the cust cluster
that i would want resources to run my
applications that application might be a
mapreduce application that might be a
hive query which is triggering a
mapreduce that might be a big script
which is triggering a mapreduce that
could be hive with days as an execution
engine that could be a spark application
that could be a graph processing
application in any of these cases you
would still you as in in sense client or
basically an api or the application
would be requesting for resources yan
would take care of that so yarn would
provide the desired resources now when
we talk about resources we are mainly
talking about the network related
resources we are talking about the cpu
cores or as in terms of yarn we say
virtual cpu cores we would talk about
ram that is in gb or mb or in terabytes
which would be offered from multiple
machines and yarn would take care of
this so with yarn you could basically
handle different workloads now these are
some of the workloads which are showing
up here you have the traditional
mapreduce which is
mainly batch oriented you could have an
interactive execution engine something
as space you could have hbase which is a
column oriented or a four dimensional
database and that would be not only
storing data on sdfs but would also need
some kind of processing you could have
streaming functionalities which would be
from storm or kafka or spark you could
have graph processing you could have
in-memory processing such as spark and
its components and you could have many
others so these are different frameworks
which could now run and which can run on
top of yarn so how does the yarn do that
now when we talk about
yarn this is how a overall yarn
architecture looks so at one end you
have the client now client could be
basically your edge node where you have
some applications which are running it
could be an api which would want to
interact with your cluster it could be a
user triggered application which wants
to run some jobs which are doing some
processing so this client would submit a
job request now what is resource manager
doing resource manager is the master of
your processing layer in hadoop version
1 we basically had job tracker and then
we had task trackers which were running
on individual nodes so your task
trackers were sending your heart beats
to the job tracker your task trackers
were sending it their resource
information and job tracker was the one
which was tracking the resources and it
was doing the job scheduling and that's
how as i mentioned earlier job tracker
was overburdened so job tracker is now
replaced by your resource manager which
is the master for your processing layer
your task trackers are replaced by node
managers which would be then running on
every node and we have a temporary demon
which you see here in blue and that's
your app master so this is what we
mentioned when we say yet another
resource negotiator so appmaster would
be existing in a hadoop version 2. now
when we talk about your resource manager
resource manager is the master for
processing layer so it would already be
receiving heartbeats and you can say
resource information from multiple node
managers which would be running on one
or multiple machines and these node
managers are not only updating their
status but they are also giving an
information of the amount of resources
they have now when we talk about
resources we should understand that if i
am talking about this node manager then
this has been allocated some amount of
ram for processing and some amount of
cpu cores and that is just a portion of
what the complete node has so if my node
has say imagine my node has around 100
gb ram and i have saved 60 cores all of
that cannot be allocated to node manager
so node manager is just one of the
components of hadoop ecosystem it is the
slave of the processing layer so we
could say keeping in all the aspects
such as different services which are
running might be cloudera or hortonworks
related services running system
processes running on a particular node
some portion of this would be assigned
to node manager for processing so we
could say for example say 60 gb ram per
node and say 40 cpu cores so this is
what is allocated for the node manager
on every machine similarly we would have
here similarly we would have here so
node manager is constantly giving an
update to resource manager about the
resources what it has probably there
might be some other applications running
and node manager is already occupied so
it gives an update now we also have a
concept of containers which is basically
we will we will talk about which is
about these resources being broken down
into smaller parts so resource manager
is keeping a track of the resources
which every node manager has and it is
also responsible for taking care of the
job request how do these things happen
now as we see here resource manager at a
higher level you can always say this is
the processing master which does
everything but in reality it is not the
resource manager which is doing it but
it has internally different services or
components which are helping it to do
what it is supposed to do now let's look
further now as i mentioned your resource
manager has these
services or components which basically
helps it to do the things it is
basically a an architecture where
multiple components are working together
to achieve what yarn allows so resource
manager has mainly two components that
is your scheduler an applications
manager and these are at high level four
main components here so we talk about
resource manager which is the processing
master you have node managers which are
the processing slaves which are running
on every nodes you have the concept of
container and you have the concept of
application master how do all these
things work now let's look at yarn
components so resource manager basically
has two main components you can save
which assist resource manager in doing
what it is capable of so you have
scheduler and applications manager now
there is when you talk about resources
there is always a requirement for the
applications which need to run on
cluster of resources so your application
which has to run which was submitted by
client needs resources and these
resources are coming in from multiple
machines wherever the relevant data is
stored and a node manager is running so
we always know that node manager is
co-located with data nodes now what does
the scheduler do so we have different
kind of schedulers here we have
basically a capacity scheduler we have a
fair scheduler or we could have a fifo
scheduler so there are different
schedulers which take care of resource
allocation so your scheduler is
responsible for allocating resources to
various running applications now imagine
a particular environment where you have
different teams or different departments
which are working on the same cluster so
we would call the cluster as a
multi-tenant cluster and on the
multi-tenant cluster you would have
different applications which would want
to run simultaneously accessing the
resources of the cluster how is that
managed so there has to be some
component which has a concept of pooling
or queueing so that different
departments or different users can get
dedicated resources or can share
resources on the cluster so scheduler is
responsible for allocating resources to
various running applications now it does
not perform monitoring or tracking of
the status of applications that's not
the part of scheduler it does not offer
any guarantee about restarting the
failed tasks due to hardware or network
or any other failures scheduler is
mainly responsible for allocating
resources now as i mentioned you could
have different kind of schedulers you
could have a fifo scheduler which was
mainly in older version of hadoop which
stands for first in first out you could
have a fair scheduler which basically
means multiple applications could be
running in the cluster and they would
have a fair share of the resources you
could have a capacity scheduler which
would basically have dedicated or fixed
amount of resources across the cluster
now whichever scheduler is being used
scheduler is mainly responsible for
allocating resources then it's your
applications manager now this is
responsible for accepting job
submissions now as i said at higher
level we could always say resource
manager state doing everything it is
allocating the resources it is
negotiating the resources it is also
taking care of listening to the clients
and taking care of job submissions but
who is doing it in real it is these
components so you have applications
manager which is responsible for
accepting job submissions it negotiates
the first container for executing the
application specific application master
it provides the service for restarting
the application master now how does this
work how do these things happen in
coordination now as i said your node
manager is the slave process which would
be running on every machine slave is
tracking the resources what it has it is
tracking the processes it is taking care
of running the jobs and basically it is
tracking each container resource
utilization so let's understand what is
this container so normally when you talk
about a application request which comes
from a client so let's say this is my
client which is requesting or which is
coming up with an application which
needs to run on the cluster now this
application could be anything it first
contacts your master that's your
resource manager which is the master for
your processing layer now as i mentioned
and as we already know that your name
node which is the master of your cluster
has the metadata in its ram which is
aware of the data being split into
blocks the blocks when stored on
multiple machines and other information
so obviously there was a interaction
with the master which has given this
information of the relevant nodes where
the data exists now for the processing
need your client basically the
application which needs to run on the
cluster so your resource manager which
basically has the scheduler which takes
care of allocating resources and
resource manager has mainly these two
components which are helping it to do
its work now for a particular
application which might be needing data
from multiple machines now we know that
we would have multiple machines where we
would have node manager running we would
have a data node running and data nodes
are responsible for storing the data on
disk so your resource manager has to
negotiate the resources now when i say
negotiating the resources it could
basically ask each of these node
managers for some amount of resources
for example it would be saying can i
have 1 gb of ram and 1 cpu core from you
because there is some data residing on
your machine and that needs to be
processed as part of my application can
i again have 1 gb and 1 cpu core from
you and this is again because some
relevant data is stored and this request
which resource manager makes of holding
the resources of total resources which
the node manager has your resource
manager
is negotiating or is asking for
resources from the processing slave so
this request of holding resources can be
considered as a container so resource
manager now we know it is not actually
the resource manager but it is the
application manager which is negotiating
the resources so it negotiates the
resources
which are called container so this
request of holding resource can be
considered as a container so basically a
container can be of different sizes we
will talk about that so resource manager
negotiates the resources with node
manager now node manager which is
already giving an update of the
resources it has what amount of
resources it holds how much busy it is
can basically approve or deny this
request so node manager would basically
approve in saying yes i could hold these
resources i could give you this
container of this particular size now
once the container has been approved or
allocated or you can say granted by your
node manager
resource manager now knows that
resources to process the application are
available and guaranteed by the node
manager so resource manager starts a
temporary demon called appmaster so this
is a piece of code which would also be
running in one of the containers it
would be running in one of the
containers which would then take care of
execution of tasks in other containers
so your application master is per
application so if i would have 10
different applications coming in from
the client then we would have 10 app
masters one app master being responsible
for per application now what does this
app master do it basically is a piece of
code which is responsible for execution
of the application so your app master
would run in one of the containers and
then it would use the other containers
which node manager is guaranteed that it
will give when the request application
request comes to it and using these
containers the app master will run the
processing tasks within these designated
resources so it is mainly the
responsibility of application master to
get the execution done and then
communicate it to the master so resource
manager is tracking the resources it is
negotiating the resources and once the
resources have been negotiated it
basically gives the control to
application master application master is
then running within one of the
containers on one of the nodes and using
the other containers to take care of
execution this is how it looks so
basically container as i said is a
collection of resources like cpu memory
your disk which would be used or which
already has the data and network so your
node manager is basically looking into
the request from application master and
it basically is granting this request or
basically is allocating these containers
now again we could have different sizing
of the containers let's take an example
here so as i mentioned from the total
resources which are available for a
particular node some portion of
resources are allocated to the node
manager so let's imagine this is my node
where node manager as a processing slave
is running so from the total resources
which the node has some portion of ram
and cpu cores is basically allocated to
the node manager so i could say out of
total 100 gb ram we can say around
60 cores which the particular node has
so this is my ram which the node has and
these are the cpu cores which the node
has some portion of it right so we can
say might be
70 or 60
of the total resources so we could say
around
60 gb ram and then we could say around
40 v cores have been allocated to node
manager so there are these
settings which are given in the yarn
hyphen site file now apart from this
allocation that is 60gb ram and for tv
cores we also have some properties which
say what will be the container sizes so
for example we could have a small
container setting which could say my
every container could have 2gb ram and
say one virtual cpu core so this is my
smallest container so based on the total
resources you could calculate how many
such small containers could be running
so if i say 2gb ram then i could have
around 30 containers but then i am
talking about one virtual cpu core so
totally i could have around 30
small containers which could be running
in parallel on a particular node and as
of that calculation you would say 10 cpu
cores are not being utilized you could
have a bigger container size which could
say i would go for 2 cpu cores and 3 gb
ram
so 3 gb ram and 2 cpu cores so that
would give me around 20 containers of
bigger size
so this is the container sizing which is
again defined in the yarn hyphen site
file so what we know is on a particular
node which has this kind of allocation
either we could have 30 small containers
running or we could have 20 big
containers running and same would apply
to multiple nodes so node manager based
on the request from application master
can allocate these containers now
remember it is within this one of these
containers you would have an application
master running and other containers
could be used for your processing
requirement application master which is
per application it is the one which uses
these resources it basically manages or
uses these resources for individual
application so remember if we have 10
applications running on yarn then it
would be 10 application masters one
responsible for each application your
application master is the one which also
interacts with the scheduler to
basically know how much amount of
resources could be allocated for one
application and your application master
is the one which uses these resources
but it can never negotiate for more
resources to node manager application
master cannot do that application master
has to always go back to resource
manager if it needs more resources so it
is always the resource manager an
internally resource manager component
that is application manager which
negotiates the resources at any point of
time due to some node failures or due to
any other requirements if application
master needs
more resources on one or multiple nodes
it will always be contacting the
resource manager internally the
applications manager for more containers
now this is how it looks so your client
submits the job request to resource
manager now we know that resource
manager internally has scheduler and
applications manager node managers which
are running on multiple machines are the
ones which are tracking their resources
giving this information to the source
manager so that resource manager or i
would say its component applications
manager could request resources from
multiple node managers when i say
request resources it is these containers
so your resource manager basically will
request for the resources on one or
multiple nodes node manager is the one
which approves these containers
and once the container has been approved
your resource manager triggers a piece
of code that is application master which
obviously needs some resources so it
would run in one of the containers and
will use other containers to do the
execution so your client submits an
application to resource manager resource
manager allocates a container or i would
say this is at a high level right
resource manager is negotiating the
resources and internally who is
negotiating the resources it is your
applications manager who is granting
this request it is node manager and
that's how we can say resource manager
locates a container application master
basically contacts the related node
manager because it needs to use the
containers node manager is the one which
launches the container or basically
gives those resources within which an
application can run and application
master itself will then accommodate
itself in one of the containers and then
use other containers for the processing
and it is within these containers the
actual execution happens now that could
be a map task that could be a reduced
task that could be a spark executor
taking care of spark tasks and many
other processing
so before we look into the demo on how
yarn works i would suggest looking into
one of the blogs from cloudera so you
can just look for yarn untangling and
this is really a good blog which
basically talks about the overall
functionality which i explained just now
so as we mentioned here so you basically
have the master process you have the
worker process which basically takes
care of your processing your resource
manager being the master and node
manager being the slave this also talks
about the resources which each node
manager has
it talks about the yarn configuration
file where you give all these properties
it basically shows you node manager
which reports the amount of resources it
has to resource manager now remember if
worker node shows 18 to 8 cpu cores and
128 gb ram and if your node manager says
64 v cores and ram 128 gb then that's
not the total capacity of your node it
is some portion of your node which is
allocated to node manager now once your
node manager reports that your resource
manager is requesting for containers
based on the application what is a
container it is basically a logical name
given to a combination of vcore and ram
it is within this container where you
would have basically the process running
so once your application starts and once
node manager is guaranteed these
containers your application or your
resource manager has basically already
started an application master within the
container and what does that application
master do it uses the other containers
where the tasks would run so this is a
very good blog which you can refer to
and this also talks about mapreduce if
you have already followed the mapreduce
tutorials in past then you would know
about the different kind of tasks that
is map and reduce and these map and
reduce tasks could be running within the
container in one or multiple as i said
it could be map task it could be reduced
task it could be a spark based task
which would be running within the
container now once the task finishes
basically that resources can be freed up
so the container is released and the
resources are given back to yarn so that
it can take care of further processing
if you'll further look in this blog you
can also look into the part two of it
where you talk mainly about
configuration settings you can always
look into this which talks about why and
how much resources are allocated to the
node manager it basically talks about
your operating system overhead it talks
about other services it talks about
cloudera hortonworks related services
running and other processes which might
be running and based on that some
portion of ram and cpu cores would be
allocated to node manager so that's how
it would be done in the yarn hyphen site
file and this basically shows you what
is the total amount of memory and cpu
cores which is allocated to node manager
then within every machine where you have
a node manager running on every machine
in the yarn hyphen site file you would
have such properties which would say
what is the minimum container size what
is the maximum container size in terms
of ram what is the minimum for cpu cores
what is the maximum for cpu cores and
what is the incremental size in where
ram and cpu cores can increment so these
are some of the properties which define
how containers are allocated for your
application request so have a look at
this and this could be a good
information which talks about different
properties now you can look further
which talks about scheduling if you look
in this particular blog which also talks
about scheduling where it talks about
scheduling in yarn which talks about
fair scheduler or you basically having
different queues in which allocations
can be done you also have different ways
in which queues can be managed and
different schedulers can be used so you
can always look at this series of blog
you can also be checking for yarn
schedulers and then search for uh
hadoop
definitive
guide and that could give you some
information on how it looks when you
look for hadoop definitive guide so if
you look into this book which talks
about the different resources as i
mentioned so you could have a fee for
scheduler that is first in first out
which basically means if a long running
application is submitted to the cluster
all other small running applications
will have to wait there is no other way
but that would not be a preferred option
if you look in fifo scheduler if you
look for capacity scheduler it basically
means that you could have different
queues created and those queues would
have resources allocated so then you
could have a production queue where
production jobs are running in a
particular queue which has fixed amount
of resources allocated you could have a
development queue where development jobs
are running and both of them are running
in parallel you could then also look
into fair scheduler which basically
means again multiple applications could
be running on the cluster however they
would have a fair share so when i say
fair share in brief what it means is
if i had given fifty percent of
resources to a queue for production and
fifty percent of resources for a queue
of development and if both of them are
running in parallel then they would have
access to fifty percent of cluster
resources however if one of the queue is
unutilized then second queue can utilize
all cluster resources so look into the
fair scheduling part it also shows you
about how allocations can be given and
you can learn more about schedulers and
how cues can be used for managing
multiple applications now we will spend
some time in looking into few ways or
few quick ways in interacting with yarn
in the form of a demo to understand and
learn on how yarn works we can look into
a particular cluster now here we have a
designated cluster which can be used you
could be using the similar kind of
commands on your apache based cluster or
a cloudera quick start vm if you already
have or if you have a cloud error or a
hortonworks cluster running there are
different ways in which we can interact
with yarn and we can look at the
information one is basically looking
into the admin console so if i would
look into cloudera manager which is
basically an admin console for a cloud
era's distribution of hadoop similarly
you could have a hortonworks cluster
than access to the admin console so if
you have even read access for your
cluster and if you have the admin
console then you can search for yarn as
a service which is running you can click
on yarn as a service and that gives you
different tabs so you have the instances
which tells basically what are the
different roles for your yarn service
running so we have here multiple node
managers now some of them show in stop
status but that's nothing to worry so we
have three and six node managers we have
resource manager which is one but then
that can also be in a high availability
where you can have active and standby
you also have a job history server which
would show you the applications once
they have completed now you can look at
the yarn configurations and as i was
explaining you can always look for the
properties which are related to the
allocation so you can here search for
course
and that should show you the properties
which talk about the locations so here
if we see we can be looking for
yarn app mapreduce application master
resource cpu course what is the cpu
course allocated for mapreduce map task
reduce task you can be looking at yarn
node manager resource cpu cores which
basically says every node manager on
every node would be allocated with 6 cpu
cores and the container sizing is with
minimum allocation of 1 cpu core and the
maximum could be 2 cpu codes similarly
you could also be searching for
memory allocation and here you could
then scroll down to see what kind of
memory allocation has been done for the
node manager so if we look further it
should give me information of node
manager which basically says here that
the container minimum allocation is 2 gb
the maximum is 3 gb and we can look at
node manager which has been given 25 gb
per node so it's a combination of this
memory and cpu cores which is the total
amount of resources which have been
allocated to every node manager now we
can always look into applications tab
that would show us different
applications which are submitted on yarn
for example right now we see there is a
spark application running which is
basically a user who is using spark
shell which has triggered a application
on spark and that is running on yarn you
can look at different applications
workload information you can always do a
search based on the number of days how
many applications have run and so on you
can always go to the web ui and you can
be searching for the resource manager
web ui and if you have access to that it
will give you overall information of
your cluster so this basically says that
here we have 100 gb memory allocated so
that could be say 25 gb per node and if
we have four node managers running and
we have 24 cores which is six cores per
node if we look further here into nodes
i could get more information so this
tells me that i have four node managers
running and node managers basically have
25 gb memory allocated per node and six
scores out of which some portion is
being utilized we can always look at the
scheduler here which can give us
information what kind of scheduler has
been allocated so we basically see that
there is just a root cue and within root
you have default queue and you have
basically user's queue based on
different users we can always scroll
here and that can give us information if
it is a fair share so here we see that
my root dot default has 50 percent of
resources and the other queue also has
50 percent of resources which also gives
me an idea that a fair scheduler is
being used we can always confirm that if
we are using a fair scheduler or a
capacity scheduler which takes care of a
location so search for scheduler and
that should give you some understanding
of what kind of scheduler is being used
and what are the allocations given for
that particular scheduler so here we
have fair scheduler it shows me you have
under root you have the root q which has
been given hundred percent capacity and
then you have within that default which
also takes hundred percent so this is
how you can understand about yarn by
looking into the yarn web ui you can be
looking into the configurations you can
look at applications you can always look
at different actions now since we do not
have admin access the only information
we have is to download the client
configuration we can always look at the
history server which can give us
information of all the applications
which have successfully completed now
this is from your yarn ui what i can
also do is i can be going into hue which
is the web interface and your web
interface also basically allows you to
look into the jobs so you can click on
hue web ui and if you have access to
that it should show up or you should
have a way to get to your hue which is a
graphical user interface mainly comes
with your cloud error you can also
configure that with apache hortonworks
has a different way of giving you the
web ui access you can click and get into
hue and that is also one way where you
can look at yarn you can look at the
jobs which are running if there are some
issues with it and these these are your
web interfaces so either you look from
yarn web ui or here in hue you have
something called as job browser which
can also give you information of your
different applications which might have
run so here i can just remove this one
which will basically give me a list of
all the different kind of jobs or
workflows which were run so either it
was a spark based application or it was
a map reduce or it was coming from hive
so here i have list of all the
applications and it says this was a
mapreduce this was a spark something was
killed something was successful and this
was basically probably a hive query
which triggered a mapreduce job you can
click on the application and that tells
you how many tasks were run for it so
there was a map task which ran for it
you can get into the metadata
information which you can obviously you
can also look from the yarn ui to look
into your applications which can give
you a detailed information of if it was
a mapreduce how many map and reduced
tasks were run what were the different
counters if it was a spark application
it can let you follow through spark
history server or job history server so
you can always use the web ui to look
into the jobs you can be finding in lot
of useful information here you can also
be looking at how many resources were
used and what happened to the job was it
successful did it fail and what was the
job status now apart from
web ui which always you might not have
access to so in a particular cluster in
a production cluster there might be
restrictions and the organization might
not have
access given to all the users to
graphical user interface like you or
might be you would not have access to
the cloudera manager or admin console
because probably organization is
managing multiple clusters using this
admin console so the one way which you
would have access
is your web console or basically your
edge node or client machine from where
you can connect to the cluster and then
you can be working so let's log in here
and now here we can give different
commands so this is the command line
from where you can have access to
different details you can always check
by just typing in map red which gives
you different options where you can look
at the map reduce related jobs you can
look at different queues if there are
queues configured you can look at the
history server or you can also be doing
some admin stuff provided you have
access so for example if i just say map
red and q here this basically gives me
an option says what would you want to do
would you want to list all the queues do
you want information on a particular
queue so let's try a list
and that should give you different
queues which were being used now here we
know that per user a queue dynamically
gets created which is under root dot
users and that gives me what is the
status of the queue what is the capacity
has there been any kind of maximum
capacity or capping done so
we get to see a huge list of queues
which dynamically get configured in this
environment and then you also look at
your root dot default i could have also
picked up one particular queue and i
could have said show me the jobs so i
could do that now here we can
also give a yarn command so let me just
clear the screen and i will say yarn and
that shows me different options so apart
from your web interface
something like web ui apart from your
yarn's web ui you could also be looking
for information using yarn commands here
so these are some list of commands which
we can check now you can just type in
yarn
and version if you would want to see the
version which basically gives you
information of what is the hadoop
version being used and what is the
vendor specific distribution version so
here we see we are working on cloudera's
distribution 5.14 which is internally
using hadoop 2.6 now similarly you can
be doing a yarn application list so if
you give this that could be an
exhaustive list of all the applications
which are running or applications which
have completed so here we don't see any
applications because right now probably
there are no applications which are
running it also shows you you could be
pulling out different status such as
submitted accepted or running now you
could also say i would want to see the
services that have finished running so i
could say yarn application list and app
states as finished so here we could be
using our command so i could say yarn
application
list
and then i would want to see the app
states which gives me the applications
which have finished and we would want to
list all the applications which finished
now there that might be applications
which succeeded right and there is a
huge list of application which is coming
in from the history server which is
basically showing you the huge list of
applications which have completed so
this is one way and then you could also
be searching for one particular
application if you would want to search
a particular application if you have the
application id you could always be doing
a grip that's a simple way i could say
basically let's pick up this one and if
i would want to search for this if i
would want more details on this i could
obviously do that
by calling in my previous command and
you could do a grip if that's what you
want to do and if you would want to
search is there an application which is
in the list of my applications that
shows my application i could pull out
more information about my application so
i could look at the log files for a
particular application by giving the
application id so i could say yarn logs
now that's an option and every time
anytime you have a doubt just hit enter
it will always give you options what you
need to give with a particular command
so i can say yarn logs application
id now we copied an application id and
we could just give it here we could give
other options like app owner or if you
would want to get into the container
details or if you would want to check on
a particular node now here i'm giving
yarn logs and then i'm pointing it to
an application id and it says the log
aggregation has not completed might be
this was might be this was an
application which was triggered based on
a particular
interactive shell or based on a
particular query so there is no log
existing for this particular application
you can always look at the status of an
application you can kill an application
so here you can be saying yarn yarn
application
and then what would you want to do with
an application hit and enter it shows
you the different options so we just
tried app states you could always look
at the last one which says status and
then for my status i could be giving my
application id so that tells me what is
the status of this application it
connects to the resource manager it
tells me what's the application id what
kind of application it was who ran it
which was the queue where the job was
running what was the start and end time
what is the progress the status of it if
it is finished or if it has succeeded
and then it basically gives me also an
information of where the application
master was running it gives me the
information where you can find this job
details in history server if you are
interested in looking into it also gives
you a aggregate resource allocation
which tells how much gb memory and how
many c core seconds it used so this is
basically looking out at the application
details now i could kill an application
if the application was already running i
could always do a yarn application
minus skill and then i could be giving
my application now i could try killing
this however it would say the
application is already finished if i had
an application running and if my
application was already given an
application id by the source manager i
could just kill it i can also say yarn
node list which should give me a list of
the node managers now this is what we
were looking from the yarn web ui and we
were pulling out the information so we
can get this and kind of information
from your command line always remember
and always try to be well accustomed
with the command line so you can do
various things from the command line and
then obviously you have the web uis
which can help you with a graphical
interface easily able to access things
now you could be also starting the
resource manager which we would not be
doing here because we are already
running in a cluster so you could give a
yarn resource manager you could get the
logs of resource manager if you would
want by giving yarn demon so we can try
that so you can say yarn and then demon
so it says it does not find the demon so
you can give something like this get
level and here i will have to give the
node and the ip address where you want
to check the logs of resource manager so
you could be giving this for which we
will have to then get into cloud era
manager to look into the nodes and the
ip address you could be giving a command
something like this which basically
gives you the level of the log which you
have and i got this resource manager
address from the web ui now i can be
giving in this command to look into the
demand log and it basically says you
would want to look at the resource
manager related log and you have the log
4j which is being used for logging the
kind of level which has been set as info
which can again be changed in the way
you're logging the information now you
can try any other commands also from
yarn for example looking at the yarn rm
admin so you can always do a yarn rm
admin and this basically gives you a lot
of other informations like refreshing
the cues or refreshing the nodes or
basically looking at the admin acls or
getting groups so you could always get
group names for a particular user now we
could search for a particular user such
as yarn or hdfs itself so i could just
say here i would want get
groups and then i could be searching for
say username hdfs so that tells me sdfs
belongs to a hadoop group similarly you
could search for say map red or you
could search for yarn so these are
service related users which
automatically get created and you can
pull out information related to these
you can always do a refresh nodes kind
of command and that is mainly done
internally this can be useful when you
are doing commissioning decommissioning
but then in case of cloudera hortonworks
kind of cluster you would not be
manually giving this command because if
you are doing a commissioning
decommissioning from an admin console
and if you are an administrator then you
could just restart the services which
are affected and that will take care of
this but if you were working in an
apache cluster and if you were doing
commissioning decommissioning then you
would be using in two commands refresh
nodes and basically that's for
refreshing the nodes which
should not be used for processing and
similarly you could have a command
refresh nodes which comes with sdfs so
these are different options which you
can use with your yarn on the command
line you could also be using curl
commands to get more information about
your cluster by giving curl minus x and
then basically pointing out to your
resource manager web ui address now here
i would like to print out the cluster
related metrics and i could just simply
do this which basically gives me a high
level information of how many
applications were submitted how many are
pending what is the reserved resources
what is the available amount of memory
or cpu cores and all the information
similarly you can be using the same curl
commands to get more information like
scheduler information so you would just
replace the metrics with scheduler and
you could get the information of the
different queues now that's a huge list
we can cancel this and that would give
me the list of all the queues which are
allocated and what are the resources
allocated for each queue you could also
get cluster information on application
ids and status running of applications
running in yarn so you would have to
replace the last bit of it and you would
say i would want to look at the
applications and that gives me a huge
list of applications then you can do a
grip and you can be filtering out
specific application related information
similarly you can be looking at the
nodes so you can always be looking at
node specific information which gives
you how many nodes you have but this
could be mainly used when you have an
application which wants to or a web
application which wants to use a curl
command and would want to get
information about your cluster from an
http interface now when it comes to
application we can basically try running
a simple or a sample mapreduce job which
could then be triggered on yarn and it
would use the resources now i can look
at my application here and i can be
looking into my specific directory which
is this one which should have a lot of
files and directories which we have here
now i could pick up one of these and i
could be using a simple example to do
some processing let's take up this file
so there is a file and i could run a
simple word count or i could be running
a hive query which triggers a mapreduce
job i could even run a spark application
which would then show that the
application is running on the cluster so
for example if i would say spark to
shell now i know that this is an
interactive way of working with spark
but this internally triggers a spark
submit and this runs an application so
here when you do as spark to shell by
default it will contact yarn so it gets
an application id it is running on yarn
with the master being yarn and now i
have access to the interactive way of
working with spark now if i go and look
into applications i should be able to
see my application which has been
started here and it shows up here so
this is my application 3827
which has been started on yarn and as of
now we can also look into the yarn ui
and that shows me the application which
has been started which basically has
one running container which has one cpu
core allocated 2gb ram and it's in
progress although we are not doing
anything there so we can always look at
our application from the yarn ui or as i
mentioned from your applications tab
within yarn services which gives us the
information and you can even click on
this application to follow and see more
information but you should be given
access to that now this is just a simple
application which i triggered using
spark shell similarly i can basically be
running a mapreduce now to run a
mapreduce i can say hadoop jar and that
basically needs a class so we can look
for the default path which is opt
cloudera parcels cdh
lib hadoop mapreduce hadoop mapreduce
examples and then we can look at this
particular jar file and if i hit on
enter it shows me the different classes
which are part of this jar and here i
would like to use word count so i could
just give this i could say word count
now remember i could run the job in a
particular queue by giving in an
argument here so i could say minus d map
red dot job dot q dot name and then i
can point my job to a particular queue i
can even give different arguments in
saying i would want my mapreduce output
to be compressed or i want it to be
stored in a particular directory and so
on so here i have the word count and
then basically what i can be doing is i
can be pointing it to a particular input
path
and then i can have my output which can
be getting stored here again a directory
which we need to choose and i will say
output new and i can submit my job now
once i have submitted my job it connects
to resource manager it basically gets a
job id it gets an application id it
shows you from where you can track your
application you can always go to the
yarn ui and you can be looking at your
application and the resources it is
using so my application was not a big
one and it has already completed it
triggered one map task it launched one
reduced task it was working on around 12
466 records where you have then the
output of map which is these many number
of output records which was then taken
by a combiner and finally by a reducer
which basically gives you the output so
this is my on application which has
completed now i could be looking into
the yarn ui and if my job has completed
you might not see your application here
so as of now it shows up here the word
count which i ran it also shows me my
previous spark shell job it shows me my
application is completed and if you
would want further information on this
you can click and go to the history
server if you have been given access to
it or directly go to the history server
web ui where your application shows up
it shows how many map and reduce tasks
it was running you can click on this
particular application which basically
gives you information of your map and
reduce tasks you can look at different
counters for your application right you
can always look at map specific tasks
you can always look into one particular
task what it did on which node it was
running or you can be looking at the
complete application log so you can
always click on the logs and here you
have click here for full log which gives
you the information and you can always
look for your application which can give
you information of app master being
launched or you could have search for
the word container so you could see a
job which needs one or multiple
containers and then you could say
container is being requested then you
could see container is being allocated
then you can see what is the container
size and then basically your task moves
from initializing to running in the
container and finally you can even
search for release which will tell you
that the container was released so you
can always look into the log for more
information so this is how you can
interact with yarn this is how you can
interact with your command line to look
for more information or using your yarn
web ui or you can also be looking into
your hue for more information we're
going to start getting into the tools
because you had all those pictures of
all those cool tools we have so we're
gonna look at the first two of those
tools and uh in the tools we have scoop
and flume and this is for your data
collection and ingestion so where does
the need for scoop come in in our big
data hadoop file system processing huge
volumes of data requires loading data
from diverse sources into hadoop cluster
you can see here we have our data
processing and this process of loading
data from the heterogeneous sources
comes with a set of challenges so what
are the challenges maintaining data
consistency ensuring efficient
utilization of resources especially when
you're talking about big data we can
certainly use up the resources when
importing terabytes and petabytes of
data over the course of time loading
bulk data to hadoop was not possible
it's one of the big challenges that came
up when they first had the hadoop file
system going and loading data using
script was very slow in other words
you'd write a script in whatever
language you're in and then it would
very slowly load each piece and parse it
in so the solution scoop scooped helped
in overcoming all the challenges to
traditional approach and could lead bulk
data from rdbms to hadoop very easily so
thank your enterprise server you want to
take the from mysql or your sql and you
want to bring that data into your hadoop
warehouse your data filing system and
that's where scoop comes in so what
exactly is scoop scoop is a tool used to
transfer bulk of data between hadoop and
external data storage such as relational
databases and mysql server or the
microsoft sql server or mysql server so
scoop equals sql plus hadoop and you can
see here we have our rdbms all the data
we have stored on there and then your
scoop is the middle ground and brings
the import into the hadoop file system
it also is one of the features that goes
out and grabs the data from hadoop and
exports it back out into an rdbms let's
take a look at scoop features scoop
features has parallel import and export
it has import results of sql query
connectors for all major rdbms databases
kerberos security integration provides
full and incremental load so we look at
parallel import and export scoop uses
yarn yet another resource negotiator
framework to import and export data this
provides fault tolerance on a top of
parallelism scoop allows us to import
the result returned from an sql carry
into the hadoop file system or the hdfs
and you can see here where the import
results of sql query come in scoop
provides connectors for multiple
relational database management system
rdbms databases such as mysql and
microsoft sql server and it has
connectors for all major rdbms databases
scoop supports kerberos computer network
authentication protocol that allows
nodes communicating over a non-secure
network to prove their identity to one
another in a secure manner scoop can
load the whole table or parts of the
table by a single command hence it
supports full and incremental load let's
dig a little deeper into the scoop
architecture we have our client in this
case a hooded wizard behind his laptop
you never know who's going to be
accessing the hadoop cluster and the
client comes in and sends their command
which goes into scoop the client submits
the import export command to import or
export data data from different
databases is fetched by scoop and so we
have
enterprise data warehouse document based
systems you have connect connector for
your data warehouse a connector for
document based systems which reaches out
to those two entities and we have our
connector for the rdbms so connectors
help in working with a range of popular
databases multiple mappers perform map
tasks to load the data onto hdfs a
hadoop file system and you can see here
we have the map task if you remember
from hadoop hadoop is based on map
reduce because we're not reducing the
data we're just mapping it over it only
accesses the mappers and it opens up
multiple mappers to do parallel
processing and you can see here the hdfs
hbase high is where the target is for
this particular one similarly multiple
map tests will export the data from hdfs
onto rdbms using scoop export command so
just like you can import it you can now
export it using the multiple map
routines scoop import so here we have
our dbms data store and we have the
folders on there so maybe it's your
company's database maybe it's an archive
at google with all the searches going on
whatever it is usually you think with
scoop you think sql you think my sequel
server or microsoft sql server that kind
of setup
so it gathers the metadata and you see
the scoop import so introspect database
to gather metadata primary key
information and then it submits uh so
you can see submits map only job
remember we talked about map reduce it
only needs the map side of it because
we're not reducing the data we're just
mapping it over scoop divides the input
data set into splits and uses individual
map tests to push the splits into hdfs
so right into the hadoop file system and
you can see down on the right is kind of
a small depiction of a hadoop cluster
and then you have scoop export so we're
going to go the other direction and with
the other direction you have your hadoop
file system storage which is your hadoop
cluster you have your scoop job and each
one of those clusters then gets a map
mapper comes out to each one of the
computers that has data on it
so the first step is you've got to
gather the metadata so step one you
gather the metadata step two submits map
only job introspect database together
metadata primary key information scoop
divides the input data set into splits
and uses individual map tests to push
the splits to rdbms scoop will export
hadoop files back to rdms tables you can
think of this in a number of different
manners one of them would be if you're
restoring a backup from the hadoop file
system into your enterprise machines
there's certainly many others as far as
exploring data and data science so as we
dig a little deeper into scoop input we
have our connect our jdbc and our url so
specified the jdbc connect string
connecting manager we specify the
connection manager class to use you can
see here driver with the class name
manually specify the jdbc driver class
to use hadoop map reduce home directory
override hadoop mapped home username set
authentication username and of course
help print usage instructions and with
the export you'll see that we can
specify the jdbc connect string specify
the connection manager class to use
manually specify jdbc driver class to
use you do have to let it know to
override the hadoop map reduce home and
that's true on both of these and set
authentication username and finally you
can print out all your help setup so you
can see the format for scoop is pretty
straightforward both import and export
so let's uh continue on our path and
look at scoop processing and what the
computer goes through for that and we
talk about scoop processing first scoop
runs in the hadoop cluster it imports
data from the rdbms the nosql database
to the hadoop file system so remember we
might not be importing the data from a
rdbms it might actually be coming from
nosql and there's many out there it uses
mappers to slice the incoming data into
multiple formats and load the data into
hdfs it exports data back into an rdbms
while making sure that the schema of the
data in the database is maintained so
now we've looked at the basic commands
in our scoop in the scoop processing or
at least the basics as far as
theory is concerned let's just jump in
and take a look at a demo on scoop
for this demo i'm going to use our
cloudera quick start if you've been
watching our other demos we've done
you'll see that we've been using that
pretty consistently certainly this will
work in any of your
your horton sandbox which is also a
single node testing machine cloudera is
one of um there's a docker version
instead of virtualbox and you can also
set up your own hadoop cluster plan a
little extra time if you're not an admin
it's actually a pretty
significant endeavor for an admin if
you've been admitting linux machines for
a very long time and you know a lot of
the commands i find it for most admins
it takes them about two to four hours
the first time they go in and create a
virtual machine and set up their own
hadoop in this case though when you're
just learning and getting set up best to
start with cloudera cloudera also
includes an install version of mysql
that way you don't have to install the
the sql version for importing data from
into once you're in the cloudera quick
start you'll see it opens a nice centos
linux
interface and it has the desktop set up
on there this is really nice for
learning so you're not just looking at
command lines and from in here it should
open up by default to hue if not you can
click on hue here's a kind of a fun
little web-based interface under hue i
can go under query i can pick an editor
and we'll go right down to scoop so now
i'm just going to load the scoop editor
inner hue now i'm going to switch over
and do this all in command line i just
want to show that you can actually do
this in a hue through the web-based
interface the reason i like to do the
command line is specifically on my
computer it runs much quicker or if i do
the command line here and i run it it
tends to have an extra lag or an added
layer in it so for this we're going to
go ahead and open our command line the
second reason i do this is we're going
to need to go ahead and edit our
mysql so we have something to scoop in
otherwise i don't have anything going in
there and of course we zoom in we'll
zoom in this and increase the size of
our screen so for this demo our hands-on
i'm going to use oracle virtualbox
manager and the cloudera quick start if
you're not familiar with this we do have
another tutorial we put out and you can
send a note in the youtube video below
and let our team know and they'll send
you a link or come visit
www.simplylearn.com now this creates a
linux box on my windows computer so
we're going to be in linux and it'll be
the cloudera version
with scoop and we'll also be using mysql
my mysql server once inside the cloudera
virtualbox we'll go under the hue editor
now we're going to do everything in
terminal window but i just want you to
be aware that under the hue editor you
can go under query editor and you'll see
as we come down here here's our scoop on
this so you can run your scoop from in
here now before we do this we have to do
a little exploration in my sql and my
sql server that way we know what data is
coming in so let me go ahead and open up
a terminal window in cloudera you have a
terminal window at the top here that you
can just click on and open it up and let
me just go ahead and zoom in on here go
view and zoom in now to get into my sql
server you simply type in mysql and this
part will depend on your setup now the
cloudera quickstart comes up that the
username is root and the password is
cloudera kind of a strange quirk is that
you can put a space between the minus u
and the root but not between the minus p
and the cloudera usually you put in a
minus capital p and then it prompts you
for your password on here for this demo
i don't worry too much about you knowing
the password on that so we'll just go
right into my sql server since this is
the standard password for this quick
start and you can see we're now into
mysql and we're going to do just a
couple of quick
commands in here there's show databases
and you follow by the semicolon that's
standard in most of these shell commands
so it knows it's the end of your shell
command and you'll see in here in the
quick start cloudera quickstart the
mysql comes with a standard set of
databases these are just
some of these have to do like with the
uzi which is the uzi part of hadoop or
others of these like customers and
employees and stuff like that those are
just for demo purposes they come as a
standard setup in there so that people
going in for the first time have a
database to play with which is really
good for us so we don't have to recreate
those databases and you will see in the
list here we have a retail underscore db
and then we can simply do
use
retail underscore db this will set that
as a default in mysql and then we want
to go ahead and show the tables and if
we show the tables you can see under the
database the retail db database we have
categories customers departments order
items orders products so there's a
number of tables in here and we're going
to go ahead and just use a standard
sql command and if you did our hive
language you'll note remember it's the
same for hql also on this we're just
going to select star everything from
departments
so there's our departments table and
we're going to list everything on the
department's table and you'll see we
have about six lines in here and it has
a department id and a department name
2 for fitness 3 for footwear so on and
so forth now at this point i can just go
ahead and exit but it's kind of nice to
have this data up here so we can look at
it and flip back and forth between the
screens so i'm going to open up another
terminal window and we'll go ahead and
zoom in on this also and it isn't too
important for this particular setup but
it's always kind of fine fun to know
what your setup you're working with what
is your host name and so we'll go ahead
and just type that in this is a linux
command and it's a
hostname minus f and you see we're on
quick start cloudera no surprise there
now this next command is going to be a
little bit longer because we're going to
be doing our first scoop command and i'm
going to do two of them we're going to
list databases and list tables it's
going to take just a moment to get
through this
because there's a bunch of stuff going
on here so we have scoop we have list
databases we have connect and under the
connect command we need to let it know
how we're connecting we're going to use
the jdbc this is a very standard one uh
jdbc mysql so you'll see that if you're
doing an sql database that's how you
started off with and then the next part
this is where you have to go look it up
it's however it was created so if your
admin created a mysql server with a
certain setup that's what you have to go
by and you'll see that usually they list
this as localhost so you'll see
something like localhost sometimes
there's a lot of different formats but
the most common is either local host or
the actual connection so in this case we
want to go ahead and do quick start
3306 and so quick start use the name of
the local host database and how it's
hosted on here and when you set up the
quickstart for um for hadoop under
cloudera it's port 3306 is where that's
coming in so that's where all that's
coming from uh and so there's our path
for that and then we have to put in our
password we typically type password if
you look it up password on the cloudera
quickstart is cloudera and we have to
also let it know the username and again
if you're doing this you'd probably put
in a minus capital you can actually just
do it for a prompt
for the password so if you leave that
out it'll prompt you uh but for this
doesn't really matter i don't care if
you see my password it's the default one
for cloudera quickstart and then the
username on here is simply root and then
we're going to put our semicolon at the
end and so we have here our full setup
and we go ahead and list the databases
and you'll see you might get some
warnings on here i haven't run the
updates on the quick start i suggest
you're not running the updates either if
you're doing this for the first time
because it'll do some reformatting on
there and it quickly pass up and you can
see here's all of our the tables we went
in there and if we go back to
on the previous window we should see
that these tables match so here we come
in and here we have our databases and
you can see back up here where we had
the cm customers employees and so on so
the databases match and then we want to
go ahead and list the
tables for a specific database so let's
go ahead and do that i'm a very lazy
typist so i'll put the up arrow in and
you can see here scoop list databases
we're just going to go back and change
this from databases to list tables so we
want to list the tables in here same
connection so most the connection is the
same except we need to know which tables
we're listing an interesting fact is you
can create a table without being under a
database so if you left this blank it
will show the open tables that aren't
connected directly to a database or
under a database but what we want to do
is right past this last slash on the
3306 we want to put that retail
underscore db because that's the
database we're going to be working with
and this will go in there and show the
tables listed under that database and
here we go we got categories customers
departments order items and products if
we flip back here real quick there it is
the same thing we had we had categories
customers departments order items and so
on and so let's go ahead and run our
first import command and again i'm that
lazy typer so we're going to do scoop
and instead of list tables we want to go
ahead and import so there's our import
command and so once we have our import
command in there then we need to tell it
exactly what we're going to import so
everything else is the same we're
importing from the retail db so we keep
that and then at the very end we're
going to tag on dash dash table that
tells us we can tell what table we're
importing from and we're going to import
departments
there we go so this is pretty
straightforward because it what's nice
about this is you can see the commands
are the same i got the same connection
um i change it for whatever database i'm
in um then i come in here our password
and the username are going to be the
same that's all under the mysql server
setup and then we let it know what table
we're entering in we run this and this
is going to actually go through the
mapper process in hadoop so this is a
mapping process it takes the data and it
maps it up to different parts in the
setup in hadoop on there and then saves
that data into the hadoop file system
and it does take it a moment to zip
through which i kind of skipped over for
you since it is running a you know it's
designed to run across a cluster not on
a single node so when you're running on
a single node it's going to run slow
even if you dedicate
a couple cores to it i think i put
dedicated four cores to this one uh and
so you can see right down here we get to
the end it's now mapped in that
information and then we can go in here
we can go under can flip back to our
hue and under hue on the top i have
there's databases and the second icon
over is your hadoop file system and we
can go in here and look at the hadoop
file system and you'll see it show up
underneath our documents there it is
departments cloudera departments and you
can see there's always a delay when i'm
working in hue which i don't like and
that's the quick start issue that's not
necessarily running out on a server when
i'm running it on a server you pretty
much have to run through some kind of
server interface i still prefer the
terminal window it still runs a lot
quicker but we'll flip back on over here
to the command line and we can do the
hadoop type in the hadoop fs and then
list minus ls and if we run this you'll
see underneath our hadoop file system
there is our departments which has been
added in and we can also do
hadoop
fs and this is kind of interesting for
those who've gone through the hadoop
file system everything you'll you'll
recognize this on here but i'm going to
list it the contents of departments and
you'll see underneath departments uh we
have part in part
m0001002003 and so this is interesting
because this is how hadoop saves these
files and this is in the file system
this is not in hive so we didn't
directly import this into hive we put
this in the hadoop file system depending
on what you're doing you would then
write the schema for hive to look at the
hadoop file system certainly visit our
hive tutorial for more information on
hive specific
so you can see in here are different
files that it forms that are part of
departments and we can do something like
this we can look at the contents of one
of these files fs minus ls or a number
of the files and we'll simply do the
full path which is user cloudera and
then we already know the next one is
departments
and then after departments we're going
to put slash part
star so this is going to say anything
that has part in it
so we have part dash m 0 0 0 and so on
we can go ahead and cat use that cut
command or that list command to bring
those up and then we can use the cat
command to actually display the contents
and that's a linux command hadoop linux
command the cat captinate not to be
confused with catatonic catastrophic
there's a lot of cat got your tongue and
we see here fitness footwear apparel
that should look really familiar because
that's what we had in our my sequel
server we went in here we did a select
all on here there it is fitness footwear
apparel golf outdoors and fan shop and
then of course it's really important
let's look back on over here to be able
to tell it where to put the data so we
go back to our import command so here's
our scoop import we have our connect we
have the db underneath our connection
our mysql server we have our password
our username the table going where it's
going to i mean the table where it's
coming from uh and then we can add a
target on here we can put in a target
dash directory and you do have to put
the full path that's a hadoop thing it's
a good practice to be in and we're going
to add it to department we'll just do
department one and so here we now add a
target directory in here and user
cloudera department one and this will
take just a moment before so i'll go
ahead and skip over the process since
it's going to run very slowly it's only
running on like i said a couple cores
and it's also on a single node and now
we can do the uh hadoop let's just do
the up arrow file system list we want
just straight list and when we do the
hadoop file system
minus ls or list you'll see that we now
have department one and we can of course
do list department one and you can see
we have the files inside department one
and they mirrored what we saw before
with the same files in there in the part
mm-00 and so on if we want to look at
him it'd be the same thing we did before
with the cat so except instead of
departments uh we'd be department one
there we go something that's going to
come up with the same data we had before
now one of the important things when
you're importing data and it's always a
question to ask is do you filter the
data before it comes in do we want to
filter this data as it comes in so we're
not storing everything in our file
system you would think hadoop big data
put it all in there i know from
experience that putting it all in there
can turn a couple hundred terabytes into
a petabyte very rapidly and suddenly
you're having to really add on to that
data store and you're storing duplicate
data sometimes so you really need to be
able to filter your data out and so
let's go ahead and use our up arrow to
go to our last import since it's still a
lot the same stuff so we have all of our
commands under import we have the target
we're going to change this to department
2 so we're going to create a new
directory for this one and then after
departments uh there's another command
that we didn't really slide in here and
that's our mapping and i'll show you
what this looks like in a minute but
we're going to put m3 in there that
doesn't have nothing to do with the
filtering i'll show you that in a second
though what that's for and we just want
to put in where uh so where and what is
the where in this case we want to know
where department
id and if you wanna know where that came
from we can flip back on over here we
have department underscore ids this is
where that's coming from that's just the
name of the column on here so we come in
here to department id
is greater than four simple
logic there you can see where you'd use
that for maybe creating buckets for ages
uh you know age from 10 to 15 20 to 30.
you might be looking for i mean there's
all kinds of reasons why you could use
the where command on here in filter
information out maybe you're doing word
counting and you want to know words that
are used less than 100 times you want to
get rid of the and is and and all the
stuff that's used over and over again uh
so we'll go ahead and put the where and
then department id is greater than four
we'll go ahead and hit enter on here and
this will create our department 2 set up
on this and i'll go ahead and skip over
some of the run time again it runs
really slow on a single node real quick
page through our commands
let's see here we go
our list and we should see underneath
the list the department two on here now
and there it is department two and then
i can go ahead and do list department
two you'll see the contents in here and
you'll see that there is only three maps
and it could be that the data created
three maps but remember i set it up to
only use three mappers uh so there's
zero one and two and we can go ahead and
do a cat on there remember this is
department two so you wanna look at all
the contents of these three different
files and there it is it's greater than
four so we have golf is five outdoor six
uh fan shop is seven so we've
effectively filtered out our data and
just storing the data we want on our
file system so if you're going to store
data on here the next stage is to export
the data remember a lot of times you
have my sql server and we're continually
dumping that data into our long-term
storage and access the hadoop file
system but what happens when you need to
pull that data out and
restore a database or
maybe you have
you just merged with a new company a
favorite topic merging companies
emerging databases
that's listed under nightmare and how
many different names for company can you
have so you can see where being able to
export is also equally important and
let's go ahead and do that and i'm going
to flip back over to my sql server here
and we'll need to go ahead and create
our database we're going to export into
now i'm not going to go too much in
detail on this command we're simply
creating a table and the table is going
to have
it's pretty much the same table we
already have in here from departments
but in this case we're going to create a
table called dept
so it's the same setup but it's just
gonna we're just giving a different name
with different schema and so we've done
that and we'll go ahead and do a select
star from dept
there we go and it's empty that's what
we expect a new database a new data
table and it's empty in there so now we
need to go ahead and export our data
that we just filtered out into there so
let's flip back on over here to our
scoop setup which is just our linux
terminal window and let's go back up to
one of our commands here's scoop import
in this case instead of import we're
going to take the scoop and we're going
to export so we're going to just change
that export and the connection is going
to remain the same so same connect same
database we're also we're still doing
the retail db uh we have the same
password so none of that changes uh the
big change here is going to be the table
instead of departments uh remember we
changed it and gave it a new name and so
we want to change it here also dept so
department we're not going to worry
about the mapper account and the where
was part of our import there we go and
then finally it needs to know where to
export from so instead of target
directory we have an export directory
that's where it's coming from uh still
user cloudera and we'll keep it as
department 2. just so you can see how
that data is coming back with that we
filtered in and let's go ahead and run
this it'll take it just a moment to go
through with steps and again because
it's glow i'm just going to go and skip
this so you don't have to sit through it
and once we've wrapped up our export
we'll flip back on over here to mysql
use the up arrow and this time we're
going to select star from department and
we can see that there it is it exported
the golf outdoors and fan shop and you
can imagine also that you might have to
use the where command in your export
also so there's a lot of mixing the
command line for scoop is pretty
straight forward you're changing the
different variables in there whether
you're creating a table listing a table
listing databases very powerful tool for
bringing your data into the hadoop file
system and exporting it so now that
we've wrapped up our demo on scoop and
gone through a lot of basic commands now
flume is a distributed service for
collecting aggregating and moving large
amounts of log data so kind of focused a
little bit on a slightly different set
of data although you'll find these
overlap a lot you can certainly use
flume to do a lot of things you can do
in scoop and vice versa flume ingests
the data so we're looking at like say a
json call to a website xml documents
unstructured and semi-structured data is
most commonly digested by flume best
example i saw was a twitter account
pulling twitter feeds into a hadoop
system so it ingests online streaming
data from social media twitter log files
so we want to know what's going on with
error codes on your servers and all
those log files web server what's going
on your web server we can bring all this
stuff in and just dump it into the
hadoop data file system to be looked at
and processed later and it's a web
server cloud social media data again all
those different sources it can be it's
kind of endless you know it just depends
on what your company needs versatility
of hadoop is what makes it such a
powerful source to add into a company
and so it comes in there you have your
source it goes through the channels it
then goes through kind of a sync feature
to make sure everything is in sync and
then it dumps it into the hadoop file
system so we've covered in the hadoop
file system the first two things let's
look at some of the scripting languages
they have and so we have the two here
and you can also think of these it
actually says scripting and sql queries
a lot of times they're both referred to
as queries so you have both the pig and
the hive so the history of hive begins
with facebook facebook began using
hadoop as a solution to handle the
growing big data and we're not talking
about a data that fits on one or two or
even five computers we're talking due to
the fits on if you've looked at any of
our other hadoop tutorials you'll know
we're talking about very big data and
data pools and facebook certainly has a
lot of data it tracks as we know the
hadoop uses mapreduce for processing
data mapreduce required users to write
long codes and so you have these really
extensive java codes very complicated
for the average person to use not all
users were versed in java and other
coding languages this proved to be a
disadvantage for them users were
comfortable with writing queries in sql
sql has been around for a long time the
standard
sql query language hive was developed
with the vision to incorporate the
concepts of tables columns just like sql
so why hive well the problem was for
processing and analyzing data users
found it difficult to code as not all of
them were well versed with the coding
languages you have your processing ever
analyzing and so the solution was
required a language similar to sql which
was well known to all the users and thus
the hive or hql language evolved what is
hive hive is a data warehouse system
which is used for querying and analyzing
large data sets stored in the hdfs or
the hadoop file system hive uses a query
language that we call hive ql or hql
which is similar to sql so if we take
our user the user sends out their hive
queries and then that is converted into
a map reduce tasks and then accesses the
hadoop mapreduce system let's take a
look at the architecture of hive
architecture of hive we have the hive
client
so that could be the programmer or maybe
it's a manager who knows enough sql to
do a basic query to look up the data
they need the hive client supports
different types of client applications
in different languages prefer for
performing queries and so we have our
thrift application in the hive thrift
client thrift is a software framework
hive server is based on thrift so it can
serve the request from all programming
language that support thrift and then we
have our jdbc application and the hive
jdbc driver jdbc java database
connectivity jdbc application is
connected through the jdbc driver and
then you have the odbc application or
the hive odbc driver the odbc or open
database connectivity the odbc
application is connected through the
odbc driver with the growing development
of all of our different scripting
languages python c plus plus spark java
you can find just about any connection
in any of the main scripting languages
and so we have our hive services as we
look at deeper into the architecture
hive supports various services
so you have your hive server basically
your thrift application or your hive
thrift client or your jdbc or your hive
jdbc driver your odbc application or
your hive odbc driver they all connect
into the hive server and you have your
hive web interface you also have your
cli now the hive web interface is a gui
is provided to execute hive queries and
we'll actually be using that later on
today so you can see kind of what that
looks like and get a feel for what that
means commands are executed directly in
cli and then the cli is a direct
terminal window and i'll also show you
that too so you can see how those two
different interfaces work these then
push the code into the hive driver hive
driver is responsible for all the
queries submitted so everything goes
through that driver let's take a closer
look at the hive driver the hive driver
now performs three steps internally one
is a compiler hive driver passes query
to compiler where it is checked and
analyzed then the optimizer kicks in and
the optimized logical plan in the form
of a graph of mapreduce and hdfs tasks
is obtained and then finally in the
executor in the final step the tasks are
executed we look at the architecture we
also have to note the meta store
metastore is a repository for hive
metadata stores metadata for hive tables
and you can think of this as your schema
and where is it located and it's stored
on the apache derby db processing and
resource management is all handled by
the mapreduce v1 you'll see mapreduce v2
the yarn and the tez these are all
different ways of managing these
resources depending on what version of
hadoop you're in hive uses mapreduce
framework to process queries and then we
have our distributed storage which is
the hdfs and if you looked at our hadoop
tutorials you'll know that these are on
commodity machines and are linearly
scalable that means they're very
affordable a lot of time when you're
talking about big data you're talking
about a tenth of the price of storing it
on enterprise computers and then we look
at the data flow and hive
so in our data flow and hive we have our
hive in the hadoop system and underneath
the user interface or the ui we have our
driver our compiler our execution engine
and our metastore that all goes into the
mapreduce and the hadoop file system so
when we execute a query you see it
coming in here it goes into the driver
step one step two we get a plan what are
we going to do refers to the query
execution uh then we go to the metadata
it's like well what kind of metadata are
we actually looking at where is this
data located what is the schema on it uh
then this comes back with the metadata
into the compiler then the compiler
takes all that information and the syn
plan returns it to the driver the driver
then sends the execute plan to the
execution engine once it's in the
execution engine the execution engine
acts as a bridge between hive and hadoop
to process the query and that's going
into your mapreduce and your hadoop file
system or your hdfs and then we come
back with the metadata operations it
goes back into the metastore to update
or let it know what's going on which
also goes to the between it's a
communication between the execution
engine and the metastore execution
engine communications is
bi-directionally with the metastore to
perform operations like create drop
tables metastore stores information
about tables and columns so again we're
talking about the schema of your
database and once we have that we have a
bi-directional send results
communication back into the driver and
then we have the fetch results which
goes back to the client so let's take a
little bit look at the hive data
modeling hive data modeling so you have
your high data modeling you have your
tables you have your partitions and you
have buckets the tables in hive are
created the same way it is done in rdbms
so when you're looking at your
traditional sql server or my sql server
where you might have enterprise
equipment and a lot of
people pulling and removing stuff off of
there the tables are going to look very
similar and this makes it very easy to
take that information and let's say you
need to keep current information but you
need to store all of your years of
transactions back into the hadoop hive
so you match those those all kind of
look the same the tables are the same
your databases look very similar and you
can easily import them back you can
easily store them into the hive system
partitions here tables are organized
into partitions for grouping same type
of data based on partition key this can
become very important for speeding up
the process of doing queries so if
you're looking at dates as far as like
your employment dates of employees if
that's what you're tracking you might
add a partition there because that might
be one of the key things that you're
always looking up as far as employees
are concerned and finally we have
buckets
data present in partitions can be
further divided into buckets for
efficient querying again there's that
efficiency at this level a lot of times
you're taught you're working with the
programmer and the admin of your hadoop
file system to maximize the efficiency
of that file system so it's usually a
two-person job and we're talking about
hive data modeling you want to make sure
that they work together and you're
maximizing your resources hive data
types so we're talking about hive data
types we have our primitive data types
and our complex data types a lot of this
will look familiar because it mirrors a
lot of stuff in sql in our primitive
data types we have the numerical data
types string data type date time data
type and
miscellaneous data type and these should
be very they're kind of self-explanatory
but just in case numerical data is your
floats your integers your short integers
all of that numerical data comes in as a
number a string of course is characters
and numbers and then you have your date
time stamp and then we have kind of a
general way of pulling your own created
data types in there that's your
miscellaneous data type and we have
complex data types so you can store
arrays you can store maps you can store
structures uh and even units in there as
we dig into hive data types
and we have the primitive data types and
the complex data types so we look at
primitive data types and we're looking
at numeric data types data types like an
integer a float a decimal those are all
stored as numbers in the hive data
system a string data type data types
like characters and strings you store
the name of the person you're working
with uh you know john doe the city
memphis the state tennessee maybe it's
boulder colorado usa or maybe it's hyper
bad
india that's all going to be string and
stored as a string character and of
course we have our date time data type
data types like timestamp date interval
those are very common as far as tracking
sales anything like that you just think
if you can type a stamp of time on it or
maybe you're dealing with the race and
you want to know the interval how long
did the person take to complete whatever
task it was all that is date time data
type and then we talk miscellaneous data
type these are like boolean and binary
and when you get into boolean binary you
can actually almost create anything in
there but your yes knows zero one now
let's take a look at complex data types
a little closer uh we have arrays so
your syntax is of data type and it's an
array and you can just think of an array
as a collection of same entities one two
three four if they're all numbers and
you have maps this is a collection of
key value pairs
so understanding maps is so central to
hadoop
so we store maps you have a key which is
a set you only have one key per mapped
value and so you in hadoop of course you
collect
the same keys and you can add them all
up or do something with all the contents
of the same key but this is our map as a
primitive type data type in our
collection of key value pairs and then
collection of complex data with comment
so we can have a structure we have a
column name data type comment call a
column comment so you can get very
complicated structures in here with your
collection of data and your commented
setup and then we have units and this is
a collection of heterogeneous data types
so the syntax for this is union type
data type data type and so on so it's
all going to be the same a little bit
different than the arrays where you can
actually mix and match different modes
of hive hive operates in two modes
depending on the number and size of data
nodes we have our local mode and our map
reduce mode when we talk about the local
mode it is used when hadoop is having
one data node and the data is small
processing will be very fast on a
smaller data sets which are present in
local machine and this might be that you
have a local file stuff you're uploading
into the hive and you need to do some
processes in there you can go ahead and
run those high processes and queries on
it usually you don't see much in the way
of a single node hadoop system if you're
going to do that you might as well just
use like an sql database or even a java
sqlite or something python is sqlite so
you don't really see a lot of single
node hadoop databases but you do see the
local mode in hive where you're working
with a small amount of data that's going
to be integrated into the larger
database and then we have the map reduce
mode this is used when hadoop is having
multiple data nodes and the data is
spread across various data nodes
processing large datasets can be more
efficient using this mode and this you
can think of instead of it being one two
three or even five computers we're
usually talking with the hadoop file
system we're looking at 10 computers 15
100 where this data is spread across all
those different hadoop nodes difference
between hive and
rdbms remember rdbms stands for the
relational database management system
let's take a look at the difference
between hive and the rdbms with hive
hive enforces schema on read and it's
very important that whatever is coming
in that's when hive's looking at it and
making sure that it fits the model
the rdbms enforces a schema when it
actually writes the data into the
database so it's read the data and then
once it starts to write it that's where
it's going to give you the error tell
you something's incorrect about your
scheme hive data size is in petabytes
that is hard to imagine you know we're
looking at your personal computer on
your desk maybe you have 10 terabytes if
it's a high-end computer we're talking
petabytes so that's hundreds of
computers grouped together when
rdbms data size is in terabytes very
rarely do you see an rdbms system that's
spread over more than five computers and
there's a lot of reasons for that with
the rdbms it actually has a high end
amount of writes to the hard drive
there's a lot more going on there you're
writing and pulling stuff so you really
don't want to get too big with an rd bms
or you're going to run into a lot of
problems with hive you can take it as
big as you want hive is based on the
notion of write once and read many times
this is so important and they call it
worm which is write w wants o read are
many times m they refer to it as worm
and that's true of any a lot of your
hadoop setup it's it's altered a little
bit but in general we're looking at
archiving data that you want to do data
analysis on we're looking at pulling all
that stuff off your rd bms from years
and years and years of business or
whatever your company does or scientific
research and putting that into a huge
data pool so that you can now do queries
on it and get that information out of it
with the rdbms it's based on the notion
of read and write many times so you're
continually updating this database
you're continually bringing up new stuff
new sales
the account changes because they have a
different licensing now whatever
software you're selling all that kind of
stuff where the data is continually
fluctuating and then hive resembles a
traditional database by supporting sql
but it is not a database it is a data
warehouse this is very important it goes
with all the other stuff we've talked
about that we're not looking at a
database but a data warehouse to store
the data and still have fast and easy
access to it for doing queries you can
think of
twitter and facebook they have so many
posts that are archived back
historically those posts aren't going to
change they made the post they're posted
they're there and they're in their
database but they have to store it in a
warehouse in case they want to pull it
back up with the rdbms it's a type of
database management system which is
based on the relational model of data
and then with hive easily scalable at a
low cost again we're talking maybe a
thousand dollars per terabyte um the
rdbms is not scalable at a low cost when
you first start on the lower end you're
talking about 10 000 per terabyte of
data including all the backup on the
models and all the added necessities to
support it as you scale it up you have
to scale those computers and hardware up
so you might start off with a basic
server and then you upgrade to a sun
computer to run it and you spend you
know tens of thousands of dollars for
that hardware upgrade with hive you just
put another computer into your hadoop
file system so let's look at some of the
features of hive uh when we're looking
at the features of hive we're talking
about the use of sql like language
called hive ql a lot of times you'll see
that as hql which is easier than long
codes this is nice if you're working
with your shareholders you come to them
and you say hey you can do a basic sql
query on here and pull up the
information you need this way you don't
have to take off have your programmers
jump in every time they want to look up
something in the database they actually
now can easily do that if they're not
skilled in programming and script
writing tables are used which are
similar to the rdbms hints easier to
understand and one of the things i like
about this is when i'm bringing tables
in from a mysql server or sql server
there's almost a direct reflection
between the two so when you're looking
at one which is the data which is
connelly changing and then you're going
into the archive database it's not this
huge jump where you have to learn a
whole new language
you mirror that same schema into the
hdfs into the hive making it very easy
to go between the two and then using
hive ql multiple users can
simultaneously query data so again you
have multiple clients in there and they
send in their query that's also true
with the rdbms which kind of queues them
up because it's running so fast you
don't notice the lag time well you get
that also with the hql as you add more
computers in the query can go very
quickly depending on how many computers
and how much resources each machine has
to pull the information and hive
supports a variety of data types
so with hive it's designed to be on the
hadoop system which you can put almost
anything into the hadoop file system so
with all that let's take a look at a
demo on hive ql or hql before i dive
into the hands-on demo let's take a look
at the website
hive.apache.org that's the main website
since apache it's an apache open source
uh software this is the main software
for the main site for the build and if
you go in here you'll see that they're
slowly migrating hive into beehive and
so if you see beehive versus hive note
the beehive as the new release is coming
out that's all it is it reflects a lot
of the same functionality of hive it's
the same thing and then we like to pull
up some kind of documentation on
commands and for this i'm actually going
to go to hortonworks
hive cheat sheet and that's because
hortonworks and cloudera are two of the
most common used builds for hadoop and
for which include hive and all the
different tools in there and so
hortonworks has a pretty good pdf you
can download cheat sheet on there i
believe cloudera does too but we'll go
ahead and just look at the horton one
because it's the one that comes up
really good and you can see when we look
at the query language it compares my sql
server to hive ql or hql and you can see
the basic select we select from columns
uh from table where conditions exist the
most basic uh command on there and they
have different things you can do with it
just like you do with your
sql and if you scroll down you'll see
data types so here's your integer your
flow your binary double string timestamp
and all the different data types you can
use some different semantics different
keys features functions
for running a hive query command line
setup and of course the hive shell uh
set up in here so you can see right here
if we loop through it it has a lot of
your basic stuff it is we're basically
looking at sql across a horton database
we're going to go ahead and run our
hadoop cluster hive demo and i'm going
to go ahead and use the cloudera quick
start this is in the virtual box so
again we have an oracle virtual box
which is open source and then we have
our cloudera quick start which is the
hadoop setup on a single node now
obviously hadoop and hive are designed
to run across a cluster of computers so
we talk about a single node is for
education testing that kind of thing and
if you have a chance you can always go
back and look at our demo we had on
setting up a hadoop system in a single
cluster just set a note down below in
the youtube video and our team will get
in contact with you and send you that
link if you don't already have it or you
can contact us at the
www.simplylearn.com now in here it's
always important to note that you do
need
on your computer if you're running on
windows because i'm on a windows machine
you're going to need a probably about 12
gigabytes to actually run this it used
to be you could buy with a lot less but
as things have evolved they take up more
and more resources and you need the
professional version if you have the
home version i was able to get that to
run but boy did it take a lot of extra
work to get the home version to let me
use the virtual setup on there and we'll
simply click on the cloud era quick
start and i'm going to go and just start
that up and this is starting up our
linux so we have our windows 10 which is
a computer i'm on and then i have the
virtual box which is going to have a
linux operating system in it and we'll
skip ahead so you don't have to watch
the whole install something interesting
to know about the cloudera is that it's
running on linuxcentos and for whatever
reason i've always had to click on it
and hit the escape button for it to spin
up and then you'll see the dos come in
here now that our cloud dara is spun up
on our virtual machine with the linux on
we can see here we have our it uses the
thunderbird browser on here by default
and automatically opens up a number of
different tabs for us and a quick note
because i mentioned like the
restrictions on getting set up on your
own computer if you have a home edition
computer and you're worried about
setting it up on there you can also go
in there and spin up a one month free
service on amazon web service to play
with this uh so there's other options
you're not stuck with just doing it on
the quick start menu you can spin this
up in many other ways now the first
thing we want to note is that we've come
in here into cloudera and i'm going to
access this in two ways
the first one is we're going to use hue
and i'm going to open up hue and i'll
take a moment to load from
the setup on here and
hue is nice if i go in and use hue as an
editor into hive or into the hadoop
setup usually i'm doing it as a
from an admin side because it has a lot
more information a lot of visuals less
to do with you know actually diving in
there and just executing code and you
can also write this code into files and
scripts and there's other things you can
other ways you can upload it into hive
but today we're going to look at the
command lines and we'll upload it into
hue and then we'll go into and actually
do our work in a terminal window under
the hive shell now in the hue browser
window if you go under query and click
on the pull down menu and then you go
under editor and you'll see hive there
we go there's our hive setup i go and
click on hive and this will open up our
query down here and now it has a nice
little b that shows our hive going and
we can go something very simple down
here like show
databases and we follow it with the
semicolon and that's the standard in
hive as you always add our
punctuation at the end there and i'll go
ahead and run this and the query will
show up underneath and you'll see down
here since this is a new quick start i
just put on here you'll see it has the
default down here for the databases
that's the database name i haven't
actually created any databases on here
and then there's a lot of other like
assistant function tables um your
databases up here there's all kinds of
things you can research you can look at
through hue as far as a bigger picture
the downside of this is it always seems
to lag for me whenever i'm doing this i
always seem to run slow so if you're in
cloudera you can open up a terminal
window they actually have an icon at the
top you can also go under applications
and under applications system tools and
terminal either one will work it's just
a regular terminal window and this
terminal window is now running
underneath our linux so this is a linux
terminal window or on our virtual
machine which is resting on our regular
windows 10 machine and we'll go ahead
and zoom this in so you can see the text
better on your own video i simply just
clicked on view and zoom in and then all
we have to do is type in hive and this
will open up the shell on here and it
takes it just a moment to load when
starting up hive i also want to note
that depending on your rights on the
computer you're on interaction you might
have to do hql command show databases
and if we do that we'll see here that we
don't have any databases so we can go
ahead and create a database and we'll
just call it office for today for this
moment now if i do show we'll just do
the up arrow up arrow is a hotkey that
works in both linux and in hive so i can
go back and paste through all the
commands i've typed in and we can see
now that i have my there's of course a
default database and then there's the
office database so now we've created a
database it's pretty quick and easy and
we go ahead and drop the database we can
do drop database
office now this will work on this
database because it's empty if your
database was not empty you would have to
do cascade and that drops all the tables
in the database and the database itself
now if we do show database and we'll go
ahead and recreate our database because
we're going to use the office database
for the rest of this hands-on demo a
really handy command to now
set with the sql or hql is to use office
and what that does is that sets office
as a default database so instead of
having to reference the database every
time we work with a table it now
automatically assumes that's the
database being used whatever tables
we're working on the difference is you
put the database name period table and
i'll show you in just a minute what that
looks like and how that's different if
we're going to have a table and a
database we should probably load some
data into it so let me go ahead and
switch gears here and open up a terminal
window you can just open another
terminal window and it'll open up right
on top of the one that you have hive
shell running in and when we're in this
terminal window first we're going to go
ahead and just do a list which is of
course a linux command you can see all
the files i have in here this is the
default load we can change directory to
documents we can list in documents and
we're actually going to be looking at
employee.csv
a linux command is the cat you can use
this actually to combine documents
there's all kinds of things that cat
does but if we want to just display the
contents of our employee.csv
file we can simply do cat employee csv
and when we're looking at this we want
to know a couple things one there's a
line at the top okay so the very first
thing we notice is that we have a header
line the next thing we notice is that
the data is comma separated and in this
particular case you'll see a space here
generally with these you've got to be
real careful with spaces there's all
kinds of things you got to watch out for
because they can cause issues these
bases won't because these are all
strings that the space is connected to
if this was a space next to the integer
you'd get a null value that comes into
the database without doing something
extra in there now with most of hadoop
that's important to know that you're
writing the data once reading it many
times and that's true of almost all your
hadoop things coming in so you really
want to process the data before it gets
into the database and for those who of
you have studied data transformation
that's the adult where you extract
transfer form and then load the data so
you really want to extract and transform
before putting it into the hive then you
load it into the hive with the
transformed data and of course we also
want to note the schema we have an
integer string string integer integer so
we kept it pretty simple in here as far
as the way the data is set up the last
thing that you're going to want to look
up
is the source since we're doing local
uploads we want to know what the path is
we have the whole path in this case it's
home slash cloudera slash documents and
these are just text documents we're
working with right now we're not doing
anything fancy so we can do a simple get
edit employee.csv
and you'll see it comes up here it's
just a text document so i can easily
remove these added spaces there we go
and then we go and just save it and so
now it has the new setup in there we've
edited it the g edit is usually one of
the default that loads into linux so any
text editor will do back to the hive
shell so let's go ahead and create a
table employee and what i want you to
note here is i did not put the semicolon
on the end here semicolon tells it to
execute that line so this is kind of
nice if you're you can actually just
paste it in if you have it written on
another sheet and you can see right here
where i have create table employee and
it goes into the next line on there so i
can do all of my commands at once now
just so i don't have any typo errors i
went ahead and just pasted the next
three lines in and the next one is our
schema if you remember correctly from
the other side we had the different
values in here which was id
name department year of joining and
salary and the id is an integer name is
a string department string air joining
energy salary an integer and they're in
brackets we put close brackets around
them and you could do this all as one
line and then we have row format
delimited fields terminated by comma and
this is important because the default is
tabs so if i do it now it won't find any
terminated fields so you'll get a bunch
of null values loaded into your table
and then finally our table properties we
want to skip the header line count
equals one now this is a lot of work for
uploading a single file it's kind of
goofy when you're uploading a single
file that you have to put all this in
here but keep in mind hive and hadoop is
designed for writing many files into the
database you write them all in there and
then you can they're saved it's an
archive it's a data warehouse and then
you're able to do all your queries on
them so a lot of times we're not looking
at just the one file coming up we're
loading hundreds of files you have your
reports coming off of your main database
all those reports are being loaded and
you have your log files you have i mean
all this different data is being dumped
into hadoop and in this case hive on top
of hadoop and so we need to let it know
hey how do i handle these files coming
in and then we have the semicolon at the
end which lets us know to go ahead and
run this line and so we'll go ahead and
run that and now if we do a show tables
you can see there's our employee on
there we can also describe if we do
describe employee
you can see that we have our id integer
name string department string year of
joining integer and salary integer and
then finally let's just do a select star
from employee very basic sql nhql
command selecting data it's going to
come up and we haven't put anything in
it so as we expect there's no data in it
so if we flip back to our
linux terminal window you can see where
we did the cat
employee.csv and you can see all the
data we expect to come into it and we
also did our pwd and right here you see
the path you need that full path when
you are loading data you know you can do
a browse and if i did it right now with
just the employee.csv as a name it will
work but that is a really bad habit in
general when you're loading data because
it's
you don't know what else is going on in
the computer you want to do the full
path almost in all your data loads so
let's go ahead and flip back over here
to our hive shell we're working in and
the command for this is load data so
that says hey we're loading data that's
a hive command hql and we want local
data so you got to put down local in
path so now it needs to know where the
path is now to make this more legible
i'm just going to go ahead and hit enter
then we'll just paste the full path in
there which i have stored over on the
side like a good prepared demo and
you'll see here we have home cloudera
documents employee.csv so it's a whole
path for this text document in here and
we go ahead and hit enter in there and
then we have to let it know where the
data is going so now we have a source
and we need a destination and it's going
to go into the table and we'll just call
it employee we'll just match the table
in there and because i want it to
execute we put the semicolon on the end
it goes ahead and executes all three
lines now if we go back if you remember
we did the select star from employee
just using the up arrow to page through
my different commands i've already typed
in you can see right here we have as we
expect we have rows sam mike and nick
and we have all their information
showing in our four rows and then let's
go ahead and do uh select
and count let's look at a couple of
these different select options you can
do we're going to count everything from
employee now this is kind of interesting
because the first one just pops up with
the basic uh select because it doesn't
need to go through the full map reduce
phase but when you start doing a count
it does go through the full map redo
setup in the hive in hadoop and because
i'm doing this demo on a single node
cloudera virtual box on top of a windows
10 all the benefits of running it on a
cluster are gone and instead it's now
going through all those added layers so
it takes longer to run you know like i
said when you do a single node as i said
earlier it doesn't do any good as an
actual distribution because you're only
running it on one computer and then
you've added all these different layers
to run it and we see it comes up with
four and that's what we expect we have
four rows we expect four at the end and
if you remember from
our cheat sheet which we brought up here
from hortons it's a pretty good one
there's all these different commands we
can do we'll look at one more command
where we do the uh what they call sub
queries right down here because that's
really common to do a lot of sub queries
and so we'll do select
star or all different columns from
employee now if we weren't using the
office database it would look like this
from office dot employee and either one
will work on this particular one because
we have office set as a default on there
so from office employee and then the
command where creates a subset and in
this case we want to know where the
salary is greater than 25
000. there we go and of course we end
with our semicolon and if we run this
query you can see it pops up and there's
our salaries of people top earners we
have rose and i t and mike and hr kudos
to them of course they're fictional i
don't actually we don't actually have a
rose and a mic in those positions or
maybe we do so finally we want to go
ahead and do is we're done with this
table now remember you're dealing with a
data warehouse so you usually don't do a
lot of dropping of tables and
databases but we're going to go ahead
and drop this table here before we drop
it one more quick note is we can change
it so what we're going to do is we're
going to alter table office employee and
we want to go ahead and rename it
there's some other commands you can do
in here but renames pretty common and
we're going to rename it to
and it's going to stay in office and
turns out one of our
shareholders really doesn't like the
word employee he wants employees plural
it's a big deal to him so let's go ahead
and change that name for the table it's
that easy because it's just changing the
metadata on there and now if we do show
tables you'll see we now have employees
not employee and then at this point
maybe we're doing some house cleaning
because this is all practice so we're
going to go ahead and drop table and
we'll drop table employees because we
changed the name in there so if we did
employee just give us an error and now
if we do show tables you'll see all the
tables are gone now the next thing we
want to take a look at and we're going
to walk back through the loading of data
just real quick because we're going to
load two tables in here and let me just
float back to our terminal window so we
can see what those tables are that we're
loading and so up here we have a
customer we have a customer um file and
we have an order file we want to go
ahead and put the customers and the
orders into here so those are the two
we're doing and of course it's always
nice to see what you're working with uh
so let's do our cat
customer.csv we could always do g edit
but we don't really need to edit these
we just want to take a look at the data
in customer and important in here is
again we have a header so we have to
skip a line comma separated uh nothing
odd with the data we have our schema
which is
integer string integer string integer so
you know you'd want to take that note
that down or flip back and forth when
you're doing it and then let's go ahead
and do cat order dot csv and we can see
we have oid which i'm guessing is the
order id we have a date up something new
we've done integers and strings but we
haven't done date when you're importing
new and you never worked with the date
date's always one of the more trickier
fields to port in when that's true of
just about any scripting language i've
worked with all of them have their own
idea of how date's supposed to be
formatted what the default is this
particular format or its year and it has
all four uh digits dash month two digits
dash day is the standard import for the
hive so you'll have to look up and see
what the different formats are if you're
going to do a different format in there
coming in or you're not able to
pre-process the data but this would be a
pre-processing of the data thing coming
in if you remember correctly from our
edel which is uh e just in case you
weren't able to hear me last time etl
which stands for extract transform then
load so you want to make sure you're
transforming this data before it gets
into here and so we're going to go ahead
and bring
both this data in here and really we're
doing this so we can show you the basic
join there is if you remember from our
setup merge join all kinds of different
things you can do but joining different
data sets is so common so it's really
important to know how to do this we need
to go ahead and bring in these two data
sets and you can see where i just
created a table customer here's our
schema the integer name age address
salary here's our eliminated by commas
and our table properties where we skip a
line well let's go ahead and load the
data first and then we'll do that with
our order and let's go ahead and put
that in here and i've got it split into
three lines so you can see it easily
we've got load data local in path so we
know we're loading data we know it's
local and we have the path here's the
complete path for
oops this is supposed to be order csv
grab the wrong one of course it's going
to give me errors because you can't
recreate the same table on there and
here we go create table here's our
integer date customer the basic setup
that we had coming in here for our
schema row format commas table
properties skip header line and then
finally let's load the data into
our order table load data local in path
home cloudera documents order.csv into
table order now if we did everything
right we should be able to do select
star from customer and you can see we
have all seven customers and then we can
do select star from order and we have uh
four orders uh so this is just like a
quick frame we have a lot of times when
you have your customer databases in
business you have thousands of customers
from years and years and some of them
you know they move they close their
business they change names all kinds of
things happen uh so we want to do is we
want to go ahead and find just the
information connected to these orders
and who's connected to them and so let's
go ahead and do it's a select because
we're going to display information so
select and this is kind of interesting
we're going to do c dot id
and i'm going to define c as customer as
a customer table in just a minute then
we're going to do c dot name and again
we're going to define the c c dot age so
this means from the customer we want to
know their id their name their age and
then you know i'd also like to know the
order amount uh so let's do o for dot
amount and then this is where we need to
go ahead and define uh what we're doing
and i'll go and capitalize from customer
so we're gonna take the customer table
in here and we're gonna name it c that's
where the c comes from so that's a
customer table c and we want to join
order as o that's where our o comes from
so the o dot amount is what we're
joining in there and then we want to do
this on we got to tell it how to connect
the two tables c dot id equals o dot
customer underscore id so now we know
how they're joined and remember we have
seven customers in here we have four
orders and as a processes we should get
a return of four different names joined
together and they're joined based on of
course the orders on there and once
we're done we now have the order number
the person who made the order their age
and the amount of the order which came
from the order table so you have your
different information you can see how
the join works here very common use of
tables and hql and sql and let's do one
more thing with our database and then
i'll show you a couple other hive
commands and let's go ahead and do a
drop and we're going to drop database
office
and if you're looking at this and you
remember from earlier this will give me
an error and this to see what that looks
like it says failed to execute exception
one or more tables exist so if you
remember from before you can't just drop
a database unless you tell it to cascade
that lets it know i don't care how many
tables are in it let's get rid of it and
in hadoop since it's an our it's a
warehouse a data warehouse usually don't
do a lot of dropping maybe at the
beginning when you're developing the
schemas and you realize you messed up
you might drop some stuff but down the
road you're really just adding commodity
machines to take up so you can store
more stuff on it so you usually don't do
a lot of database dropping and some
other
fun commands to know is you can do
select round 2.3 is round value you can
do a round off in
hive we can do as floor value which is
going to give us a 2 so it turns it into
an integer versus a float it goes down
you know basically truncates it but it
goes down and we can also do ceiling
which is going to round it up so we're
looking for the next integer above
there's a few commands we didn't show in
here because we're on a single node as
as an admin to help spediate the process
you usually add in partitions for the
data and buckets you can't do that on a
single node because the when you add a
partition it partitions it across
separate nodes but beyond that you can
see it's very straightforward we have
sql coming in and all your basic queries
that are in sql are very similar to hql
what exactly is pick pig is a scripting
platform that runs on hadoop clusters
designed to process and analyze large
data sets and so you have your pig which
uses sql like queries they're definitely
not sql but some of them resemble sql
queries and then we use that to analyze
our data pig operates on various types
of data like structured semi-structured
and unstructured data let's take a
closer look at mapreduce versus hive
versus pig so we start with a compiled
language your mapreduce and we have hive
which is your sql like query and then we
have pig which is a scripting language
it has some similarities to sql but it
has a lot of its own stuff remember sql
like query which is what hive is based
off looks for structured data and so we
get into scripting languages like pig
now we're dealing more with
semi-structured and even unstructured
data with a hadoop map reduced we have a
need to write long complex codes with
hive no need to write complex codes you
could just put it in a simple sql query
or hql hive ql and in pig no need to
write complex codes as we have pig latin
now remember in the mapreduce it can
produce structured semi-structured and
unstructured data and as i mentioned
before hive can process only structured
data think rows and columns where pig
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data you can think of
structured data as rows and columns
semi-structured as your html xml
documents like you have on your web
pages and unstructured could be anything
from groups of documents and written
format twitter tweets any of those
things come in as very unstructured data
and with our hadoop map reduce we have a
lower level of abstraction with both
hive and pig we have a higher level
abstraction so it's much more easy for
someone to use without having to dive in
deep and write a very lengthy map reduce
code and those map and reduce codes can
take 70 80 lines of code when you can do
the same thing in one or two lines with
hive or pig this is the advantage pig
has over hive it can process only
structured data and hive while in pig it
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data some other
features to note that separates the
different query languages as we look at
map and reduce mapreduce supports
partitioning features as does hive pig
no concept of partitioning in pix it
doesn't support your partitioning
feature your partitioning features allow
you to partition the data in such a way
that it can be queried quicker you're
not able to do that in pig mapreduce
uses java and python while hive uses an
sql like query language known as hive ql
or hql pig latin is used which is a
procedural data flow language mapreduce
is used by programmers pretty much as
straightforward on java hive is used by
data analysts pig is used by researchers
and programmers certainly there's a lot
of mix between all three programmers
have been known to go in and use a hive
for quick query and anybody's been able
to use pig for quick query or research
under map and reduce code performance is
really good under hive code performance
is lesser than map and reduce in
under pig code performance is lesser
than mapreduce but better than hive so
if we're going to look at speed and time
the map reduce is going to be the
fastest performance on all of those
where pig will have second and high
follows in the back let's look at
components of pig pig has two main
components we have pig latin pig latin
is the procedural data flow language
used in pig to analyze data it is easy
to program using piglet and it is
similar to sql and then we have the
runtime engine runtime engine represents
the execution environment created to run
pig latin programs it is also a compiler
that produces mapreduce programs uses
hdfs or your hadoop file system for
storing and retrieving data and as we
dig deeper into the pig architecture
we'll see that we have pig latin scripts
programmers write a script in pig latin
to analyze data using pig then you have
the grunt shell and it actually says
grunt when we start it up and we'll show
you that here in a little bit which goes
into the pig server and this is where we
have our parser parser checks the syntax
of the pig script after checking the
output will be a dag directed acylic
graph and then we have an optimizer
which optimizes after your dag your
logical plan is passed to the logical
optimizer where an optimization takes
place finally the compiler converts the
dag into map reduce jobs and then that
is executed on the map reduce under the
execution engine the results are
displayed using dump statement and store
it in hdfs using store statement and
again we'll show you that
the kind of end you always want to
execute everything once you've created
it and so dump is kind of our execution
statement and you can see right here as
we were talking about earlier once we
get to the execution engine and it's
coded into mapreduce then the mapreduce
processes it onto the hdfs working of
pig pig latin script is written by the
users so you have load data and write
pig script and pig operations so we look
at the working of pig pig latin script
is written by the users there's step one
we load data and write pig script and
step two in this step all the pig
operations are performed by parser
optimizer and compiler so we go into the
pig operations and then we get to step
three execution of the plan in this days
the results are shown on the screen
otherwise stored in the hdfs as per the
code so it might be of a small amount of
data you're reducing it to and you want
to put that on the screen or you might
be converting a huge amount of data
which you want to put back into the
hadoop file system for other use let's
take a look at the pig latin data model
the data model of pig latin helps pig to
handle various types of data for example
we have adam rob or 50. atom represents
any single value of primitive data type
in pig latin like integer float string
it is stored as a string tuple so we go
from our atom which are most basic
things so if you look at just rob or
just 50 that's an atom that's our most
basic object we have in pig latin then
you have a tuple tuple represents
sequence of fields that can be of any
data type it is the same as a row in
rdbms for example a set of data from a
single row and you can see here we have
rob comma five and you can imagine with
many of our other examples we've used we
might have the id number the name where
they live their age their date of
starting the job that would all be one
row and stored as a tuple and then we
create a bag a bag is a collection of
tuples it is the same as a table in
rdbms and is represented by brackets and
you can see here we have our table with
rob5 mic 10 and we also have a map a map
is a set of key value pairs key is of
character array type and a value can be
of any type it is represented by the
brackets and so we have name and age
where the key value is mic in 10. pig
latin has a fully nestable data model
that means one data type can be nested
within another here's a diagram
representation of pig latin data model
and in this particular example we have
basically an id number a name and age
and a place and we break this apart we
look at this model from pig latin
perspective we start with our field and
if you remember a field contains
basically an atom it is one particular
data type and the atom is stored as a
string which then converts it into
either an integer or number or character
string next we have our tuple and in
this case you can see that it represents
a row so our tuple would be three comma
joe comma 29 comma california and
finally we have our bag which contains
three rows in it in this particular
example let's take a quick look at pig
execution modes pig works in two
execution modes depending on where the
data is reciting and where the pig
script is going to run we have local
mode here the pig engine takes input
from the linux file system and the
output is stored in the same file system
local mold local mode is useful in
analyzing small data sets using pic and
we have the map reduce mode here the pig
engine directly interacts and executes
in hdfs and mapreduce in the map reduce
mode queries written in pig latin are
translated into mapreduce jobs and are
run on a hadoop cluster by default pig
runs in this mode there are three modes
in pig depending on how a pig latin code
can be written we have our interactive
mode batch mode and embedded mode the
interactive mode means coding and
executing the script line by line when
we do our example we'll be in the
interactive mode in batch mode all
scripts are coded in a file with the
extension.pig
and the file is directly executed and
then there's embedded mode pig lets its
users define their own functions udfss
in a programming language such as java
so let's take a look and see how this
works in a use case in this case use
case twitter users on twitter generate
about 500 million tweets on a daily
basis the hadoop mapreduce was used to
process and analyze this data analyzing
the number of tweets created by a user
in the tweet table was done using
mapreduce and java programming language
and you can see the problem it was
difficult to perform map reduce
operations as users were not well versed
with written complex java codes so
twitter used apache pig to overcome
these problems and let's see how let's
start with the problem statement analyze
the user table and tweet table and find
out how many tweets are created by a
person and here you can see we have a
user table we have alice tim and john
with their id numbers one two three and
we have a tweet table in the tweet table
you have your um the id of the user and
then what they tweeted
google was a good whatever it was tennis
dot dot spacecraft olympics politics
whatever they're tweeting about the
following operations were performed for
analyzing given data first the twitter
data is loaded into the pig storage
using load command and you can see here
we have our data coming in and then
that's going into pig storage and this
data is probably on an enterprise
computer so this is actually active
twitter's going on and then it goes into
hadoop file system remember the hadoop
file system is a data warehouse for
storing data and so the first step is we
want to go ahead and load it into the
pig storage into our data storage system
the remaining operations performed are
shown below in join and group operation
the tweet and user tables are joined and
grouped using co-group command and you
can see here where we add a whole column
when we go from
user names and tweet to the id linked
directly to the name so alice was user 1
10 was 2 and john 3. and so now they're
listed with their actual tweet the next
operation is the aggregation the tweets
are counted according to the names the
command used is count so it's very
straightforward we just want to count
how many tweets each user is doing and
finally the result after the count
operation is joined with the user table
to find out the username and you can see
here where alice had 3 tim 2 and john 1.
pig reduces the complexity of the
operations which would have been lengthy
using mapreduce in joining group
operation the tweet and user tables are
joined and grouped using cogroup command
the next operation is the aggregation
the tweets are counted according to the
names the command used is count the
result after the count operation is
joined with the user table to find out
the username and you can see we're
talking about three lines of script
versus a map reduce code of about 80
lines finally we could find out the
number of tweets created by a user in a
simple way so let's go quickly over some
of the features of pig that we already
went through most of these
first ease of programming is pig latin
is similar to sql lesser lines of code
need to be written short development
time as the code is simpler so we can
get our queries out rather quickly
instead of having to have a programmer
spend hours on it handles all kinds of
data like structured semi-structured and
unstructured pig lets us create
user-defined functions pig offers a
large set of operators such as join
filter and so on it allows for multiple
queries to process unparallel and
optimization and compilation is easy as
it is done automatically and internally
so enough theory let's dive in and show
you a quick demo on some of the commands
you can do in pick today's setup will
continue as we have in the last three
demos to go and use cloudera quick start
and we'll be doing this in virtual box
we do have a tutorial in setting that up
you can send a note to our simply learn
team and then get that linked to you
once your cloudera quick start has spun
up and remember this is virtualbox we've
created a virtual machine and this
virtual machine is centos linux once
it's spun up you'll be in a full linux
system here and as you can see we have
thunderbird browser which opens up to
the hadoop basic system browser and we
can go underneath the hue where it comes
up by default if you click on the pull
down menu and go under editor you can
see there's our impala our hive
pig along with a bunch of other query
languages you can use and we're going
under pig and then once you're in pig we
can go ahead and use our command line
here and just click that little blue
button to start it up and running we
will actually be working in terminal
window so if you're in the cloudera
quickstart you can open up the terminal
window up top or if you're in your own
setup and you're logged in you can
easily use all of your commands here in
terminal window and we'll zoom in that
way you get a nice view of what's going
on there we go now for our first command
we're going to do a hadoop command and
import some data into the hadoop system
in this case a pig input and let's take
a look at this we have a hadoop now
listen no it's going to be a hadoop
command dfs there's actually four
variations of dfs so if you have hdfs or
whatever that's fine all four of them
point used to be different setups
underneath different things and now they
all do the same thing and we want to put
this file which in this case is under
home cloudera documents and sample and
we just want to take that and put it
into the pig input now let's take a look
at that file if i go under my document
browsers and open this up you'll see
it's got a simple id name profession and
age we have one jack engineer 25 and
that was in one of our earlier things we
had in there and so let's go ahead and
hit enter and execute this and now we've
uploaded that data and it's gone into
our pig input and then a lot of the
hadoop commands mimic the linux commands
and so you'll see we have cat as one of
our commands or we has a hyphen before
it so we execute that with hadoop dfs
hyphen cat slash pig input because
that's what we called it that's where we
put our sample csv at and we execute
this you can see from our hadoop system
it's going to go in and pull that up and
sure enough it pulls out the data file
we just put in there and then we can
simply enter the pig latin or pig editor
mode by typing in pick and we can see
here uh by our grunt i told you that's
how it was going to tell you you were in
pig latin there's our grunt command line
so we are now in the pig shell and then
we'll go ahead and put our load command
in here and the way this works is i'm
going to have office equals load and
here's my load in this case it's going
to be pig input we have that in single
brackets you remember that's where the
data is in the hadoop file system where
we dumped it into there we're going to
using pig storage our data was separated
as with a comma so there's our comma
separator and then we have as in this
case we have an id character array name
character array profession character a
and age character ray and we're just
going to do them all as character arrays
just to keep this simple for this one
and then when i hit put this all in here
you can see that's our full command line
going in and we have our semicolon at
the end so when i hit enter it's now set
office up but it hasn't actually done
anything yet it doesn't do anything
until we do dump office so there's our
command to execute whatever we've loaded
or whatever setup we have in here and we
run that you can see it go through the
different languages and this is going
through the map reduce remember we're
not doing this locally we're doing this
on the hadoop setup and once we finished
our dump you can see we have id name
profession age and all the information
that we just dumped into our pick oh we
can now do let's say oh let's say we
have a request just for we'll keep it
simple in here but just for the name and
age and so we can go office we'll call
it each as our variable underscore each
and we'll say for each office generate
name comma h and for each means that
we're going to do this for each row and
if you're thinking map reduce you know
that this is a map function because it's
mapping each row and generating name and
age on here and of course we want to go
ahead and close it with a semicolon and
then once we've created our query or the
command line in here let's go ahead and
dump office underscore each in with our
semicolon and this will go through our
setup on here and if we were on a large
cluster the same processing time would
happen in fact it's really slow because
i have multiple things on this computer
and this particular virtual box is only
using a quarter of my processor it's
only dedicated to this and you can see
here there it is name and age and it
also included the top row since we
didn't delete that out of there or tell
it not to and that's fine for this
example but you need to be aware of
those things when you're processing a
significantly large amount of data or
any data then we can also do office and
we'll call this dsc for descending so
maybe the boss comes to you and says hey
can we order office by id
descending and of course your boss
you've taught them how to uh your
shareholder sounds a little druggatory
and say boss you've talked to the
shareholder and you said and you've
taught them a little bit of pig latin
and they know that they can now create
office description and we can order
office by id description and of course
once we do that we have to dump office
underscore description so that it'll
actually execute and there goes into our
map reduce we'll take just a moment for
it to come up because again i'm running
on only a quarter of my processor and
you can see we now have our ids in
descending order returned let's also
look at and this is so important with
anytime you're dealing with big data
let's create office with a limit and you
can of course do any of this instead of
with office we could do this with office
descending so you get just the top two
ids on there we're gonna limit just to
two and of course to execute that we
have to dump office underscore limit you
can just think of dumping uh your
garbage into the pig pen for the pig to
eat there we go dump office limit two
and that's going to just limit our
office to the top two and for our output
we get our first row which had our id
name profession and age and our second
row which is jack who's an engineer
let's do an filter we'll call it office
underscore
filter you guessed it equals filter
office by profession equals and keep
note this is similar to how python does
it with the double equal signs for equal
for doing a true false statement so for
your logic statement remember to use two
equal signs in pig and we're going to
say it equals doctor so we want to find
out how many doctors do we have on our
list and we'll go ahead and do our dump
we're dumping all our garbage into the
pig pen and we're letting pig take over
and see what it can find out and see
who's a doctor on our list and we find
uh employee id number two bob is a
doctor 30 years old for this next
section uh we're going to cover
something we see a lot nowadays in data
analysis and that's word counting
tokenization that is one of the next big
steps as we move forward in our data
analysis where we go from say stock
market analysis of highs and lows and
all the numbers to what are people
saying about companies on twitter what
are they saying on the web pages and on
facebook suddenly you need to start
counting words and finding out how many
words are totaled how many in the first
part of the document and so on we're
going to cover a very basic word count
example and in this case i've created a
document called wordrose.txt
and you can see here we have simplylearn
is a company supporting online learning
simplylearn helps people attain their
certifications simply learn is an online
community i love simply learn i love
programming i love data analysis and i
went and saved this into my documents
folder so we could use it and let me go
ahead and open up a new terminal window
for our word count let me go and close
the old one so we're going to go in here
and instead of doing this as pig we're
going to do pig minus x local and what
i'm doing is i'm telling the pig to
start the pig shell but we're going to
be looking at files local to our
virtualbox or this centos machine and
let me go ahead and hit enter on there
just maximize this up there we go and it
will load pig up and it's going to look
just the same as the pig we were doing
which was defaulted too high to our
hadoop system to our hdfs this is now
defaulted to the local system now we're
going to create lines we're going to
load it straight from the file remember
last time we took the hdfs and loaded it
into there and then loaded it into pig
since we're gone the local we're just
going to run a local script we have
lines equals load home the actual full
path home cloud area documents and i
called it wordrose.txt
and as line is a character array so each
line and i've actually you can change
this to read each document i certainly
have done a lot of document analysis and
then you go through and do word counts
and different kind of counts in there so
once we go ahead and create our line
instead of doing the dump we're going to
go ahead and start entering all of our
different setups for each of our steps
we want to go through and let's just
take a look at this next one because the
load is straightforward we're loading
from this particular file since we're
locals loading it directly from here
instead of going into the hadoop file
system and it says as and then each line
is read as a character array now we're
going to do words equal for each of the
lines generate flat tokenize line space
as word now there's a lot of ways to do
this this is if you're a programmer
you're just splitting the line up by
spaces there's actual ways to tokenize
it you gotta look for periods
capitalization there's all kinds of
other things you play with with this but
for the most basic word count we're just
going to separate it by spaces the
flatten takes the line and just creates
a
it flattens each of the words out so
this is uh we're just going to generate
a bunch of words for each line and then
each each of those words is as a word a
little confusing in there but if you
really think about it we're just going
down each line separating it out and
we're generating a list of words one
thing to note is the default for
tokenize you can just do tokenized line
without the space in there if you do
that it'll automatically tokenize it by
space you can do either one and then
we're gonna do group we're gonna group
it by words so we're gonna group words
by word so when we we split it up each
token is a word and it's a list of words
and so we're to group equals group words
by word so we're going to group all the
same words together and if we're going
to group them then we want to go ahead
and count them and so for count we'll go
ahead and create a word count variable
and here's our four each so for each
group grouped is our line where we group
all the words in the line that are
similar we're going to generate a group
and then we're going to count the words
for each group so for each line we group
the words together we're going to
generate a group and that's going to
count the words we want to know the word
count in each of those and that comes
back in our word count and finally we
want to take this and we want to go
ahead and dump word count and this is a
little bit more what you see when you
start looking at grunt scripts you'll
see right here these these lines right
here we have each of the steps you take
to get there so we load our file for
each of our
lines we're going to generate and
tokenize it into words then we're going
to take the words and we're going to
group them by same words for each group
we're going to generate a group and
we're just going to count the words so
we're going to summarize all the words
in here and let's go ahead and do our
dump word count which executes all this
and it goes through our map reduce it's
actually a local runner you'll see down
here you start seeing where they still
have map reduced but as a special runner
we're mapping it that's a part of each
row being counted and grouped and then
when we do the word count that's a
reducer the reducer creates these keys
and you can see i is used three times a
came up once and came up once is to
continue on down here to attain online
people company analysis simply learn
they took the top rating with four
certification so all these things are
encountered in the how many words are
used uh in a data analysis this is
probably the very the beginnings of data
analysis where you might look at it and
say oh they mentioned love
three times so whatever's going on in
this post it's about love and
what do they love and then you might
attach that to the different objects in
here so you can see that pig latin is
fairly easy to use there's nothing
really you know it might it takes a
little bit to learn the script uh
depending on how good your memory is as
i get older my memory leaks a little bit
more so i don't memorize it as much but
that was pretty straightforward the
script we put in there and then it goes
through the full map reduce localized
run comes out and like i said it's very
easy to use that's why people like pig
latin is because it's intuitive one of
the things i like about pig latin is
when i'm troubleshooting when we're
troubleshooting a lot of times you're
working with a small amount of data and
you start doing one line at a time and
so i can go lines equal load and there's
my loaded text and maybe i'll just dump
lines and then it's going to rot it's
going to show me all the lines that i'm
working on in the small amount of data
and that way i can test that if i got an
error on there that said oh this isn't
working maybe they'll be oh my gosh i'm
in map reduce or i'm in the basic
grunt shell instead of the local path
grunt so maybe it'll generate an error
on there and you can see here it just
shows each of the lines going down so
spark real time data analysis and i told
you spark is its own animal so we're
going to touch very little on spark as
far as how big and robust it is but
we're going to talk a little bit about
spark spark is an open source
distributed computing engine for
processing and analyzing huge volumes of
real-time data so it runs 100 times
faster than map reduce map reduces the
basics of the hadoop system which is
usually set up in a java code in spark
the map reduce instead of running what
happens in map reduces it goes pulls it
into the ram writes it to the hard drive
reads it off the hard drive shuffles it
around writes it back to the hard drive
pulls it off the hard drive does this
processing and you get the impressions
going in and out of ram to the hard
drive and back up again so if you don't
have a lot of ram and you have older
computers and you don't have the ram to
process something then spark and hadoop
are going to run the same speed
otherwise spark goes hey let's keep this
all on the ram and run faster and that's
what we're talking about is provides
in-memory computation of data so it's
fast you can see the guy running through
the door there speedy versus a very slow
hadoop wandering around and it's used to
process and analyze real-time streaming
data such as stock market and baking
data so the spark can have its own stuff
going on and then it can access the
hadoop database it can pull data just
like scoop and flume do so it has all
those features in it and you can even
run spark with its own yarn outside of
hadoop there's also spark on mesos which
is another resource manager although
yarn is most commonly used and currently
spark pretty much becomes installed with
hadoop and so your spark running on top
of hadoop will use the same nodes it has
its own manager and it utilizes the ram
so you'll have both you can have the
spark on top of there and here we go you
have your driver program your spark
context it goes into your cluster
manager your yarn then you have your
worker nodes which are going to be
executing tasks and cache and it's
important to remember when you're
running the spark setup even though
these are commodity machines we're still
using a lot of them are like 128
gigabytes of ram so that spark can run
these high-end processes certainly if
it's not accessed very much and you're
building a
hadoop cluster you could drop that ram
way down if you're doing just queries
without any kind of processing on there
and you're not doing a lot of queries
but you know generally spark you're
looking at higher end they're still
commodity machines to do your work and
now we get into the hadoop machine
learning and so machine learning is its
own animal i keep saying that these are
all kind of unique things howt is being
phased out i mean people still use it
it's still important if you can write
your basic machine learning that has
most of the tools in there you certainly
can do it in mahout and how it again
writes to the hard drive reads from the
hard drive you can do all that in spark
and it's faster because it's just in
ramp and so spark has its own machine
learning tools in it and you can also
use pi spark which then accesses all the
different python tools and there's just
so many tools you can dump into spark
the hout is very limited but it's also
very basic which in itself can be really
good sometimes simple is better so how
it is used to create scalable and
distributed machine learning algorithms
so here we have our major environment it
builds a machine learning application so
you're doing linear regression you're
doing clustering you're doing
classification models it has a library
that contains inbuilt algorithms for all
of these and then it has collaborative
filtering and again there's our
classification and there's our
clustering regression so you have your
different machine learning tools we can
easily classify a large amount of data
using the hout so this brings us to the
next set of tools we have or the next
tool which is the apache ambari a bari
is an open source tool responsible for
keeping track of running applications
and their statuses think of this as like
a traffic cop
more like a security guard you can open
it up and see what's going on and so the
apache ambari manages monitors and
provisions hadoop clusters provides a
central management service to start stop
and configure hadoop services so again
it's like a traffic cop hey stop over
there start keep going hey what's going
on over that area in the through lane on
the high speed freeway and you can open
this up and you have a really easy view
of what's going on and so you can see
right here you have the ambari web the
ambari web is what you're looking at
that's your interface that you've logged
into the ambari server this will be
usually on the master node it's usually
if you're going to install embarrassment
you'll just install it on the same node
and it connects up to the database and
then it has agents and each agent takes
a look and see what's going on with its
host server and if you're going to have
uh two more systems and we talked about
spark streaming there's also kafka and
apache for streaming data coming in and
kafka is distributed streaming platform
to store and process streams of records
and it's written in scala builds
real-time screaming data pipelines that
reliably get data between applications
builds real-time streaming applications
that transforms data into streams so it
kind of goes both ways on there so kafka
uses a messaging system for transferring
data from one application to another so
we have our sender we have our message
queue and then we have our receiver
pretty straightforward very solid setup
on there with the kafka patchy storm
storm is a processing engine that
processes real-time streeting at a very
high speed and it's written in closure
they utilize the function based
programming style of closure and it's
based on lisp to give it the speed
that's why apache storm is built on
there so you could think of kafka as a
slow-moving very solid communication
network where storm is looking at the
real-time data and grabbing that
streaming data that's coming in fast so
it has a ability to process over a
million jobs in a fraction of seconds on
a node so it's massive it can really
reach out there and grab the data and
it's integrated with hadoop to harness
higher thorough puts so this is the two
big things about storm if you are
pulling i think they mentioned stock
coming in or something like that where
you're looking for the latest data
popping up storm is a really powerful
tool to use for that so we've looked at
a couple more tools for bringing data in
we probably should talk a little bit
about security security has in hadoop
has the apache ranger and apache knox
are the two most popular one and the
ranger the apache ranger ranger is a
framework to enable monitor and manage
data securities across the hadoop
platform so the first thing it does is
it provides centralized security
administration to manage all security
related tasks the second thing it does
is it has a standardized authorization
across all hadoop components and third
it uses enhanced support for different
authorization methods role based access
control attribute based access control
etc so your apache ranger can go in
there and your administrator coming in
there can now very easily monitor who
has what rights and what they can do and
what they can access so there's also
apache knox nox is an application
gateway for interacting with the rest
apis and the uis of hadoop developers
and so we have our application
programmer interfaces our user
interfaces and we talk about rest apis
this means we're pulling this is looking
at the actual data coming in what
applications are going on so if you have
an application where people are pulling
data off of the hadoop system or pushing
data into the dupe system the nox is
going to be on that setup and it
delivers three groups of user-facing
services one proxy services provides
access to hadoop via proxying the http
request two authentication services
authentication for rest api access and
web sso flow for user interfaces so
there's our rest and finally client
services client development can be done
with the scripting through dsl or using
the knox shell classes so the first one
is if you have a website coming in and
out your http request again your three
different services are what's coming in
and out of the hadoop file system so
there's a couple of the security setups
let's go ahead and take a look at
workflow system the uzi and there's some
other ones out there uzi is the one
that's specific to hadoop there's also
like a zookeeper out there and some
other ones
uzi's pretty good uzi is a workflow
scheduler system to manage hadoop jobs
and so you have a workflow engine and a
coordinator engine so it consists of two
parts what's going on and coordinating
what's going on and
directed acelic graph dags which
specifies a sequence of actions to be
executed these consist of workflow jobs
triggered by time and data available and
if you're not familiar with directed
acylic graphs or dags or whatever
terminology you want to throw at this
this is basically a flow chart you start
with process a then the next process
would be process b when process a is
done and it might be that process c can
only be done when process d e and f are
done so you want to be able to control
this you don't want it to process the
machine learning script and then pull
the data in that you want to process it
on you want to make sure it's going in
the right order so these consist of
workflow jobs and they're triggered by
time and data availability so maybe
you're pulling stocks in the middle of
the night and once the stock is all
pulled so there's our time sequence it
says hey they've been posted on the
other websites they post them usually
after the stock market closes the highs
and lows and everything then once that
data has been brought in you know in a
time specifics bringing the data in a
certain time once the data is available
then we want to trigger our machine
learning script for what's going to
happen next and so we can see here we
have start our map reduce program our
action node and it begins and either we
have a success then we notify the client
of success usually an email sent out in
successful completion quick demo on
hbase you can see some hands-on let's
start with an introduction to hbase back
in the days data used to be less and was
mostly structured you see we have
structured data here we usually had it
like in a database where you had uh
every field was exactly the correct
length so if you had a name fill that
exactly 32 characters remember the old
access database in microsoft the files
are small if we had you know hundreds of
people in one database that was
considered big data this data could be
easily stored in relational database or
rdbms when we talk about relational
database you might think of oracle you
might think of sql microsoft sql
mysql all of these have evolved even
from back then to do a lot more today
than they did but they still fall short
in a lot of ways and they're all
examples of an rdms or relationship
database then internet evolved and huge
volumes of structured and
semi-structured data got generated and
you can see here with the
semi-structured data we have email if
you look at my spam folder you know
we're talking about all the html pages
xml which is a lot of time is displayed
on our html and help desk pages json all
of this really has just even in the last
each year it almost doubles from the
year before how much of this is
generated so storing and processing this
data on an rdbms has become a major
problem and so the solution is we use
apache age base apache hbase was the
solution for this let's take a look at
the history the hbase history and we
look at the hbase history we're going to
start back in 2006 november google
released the paper on big table and then
in 2017 just a few months later age
based prototype was created as a hadoop
contribution later on in the year 2007
in october first usable hbase along with
the hadoop .15 was released and then in
january of 2008 hbase became the
subproject of hadoop and later on that
year in october all the way into
september the next year hbase was
released the 0.81 version the 0.19
version and 0.20 and finally in may of
2010 hbase became apache top level
project and so you can see in the course
of about four years hbase started off as
just an idea on paper and has evolved
all the way till 2010 as a solid project
under the apache and since 2010 has
continued to evolve and grow as a major
source for storing data in
semi-structured data so what is hbase
hbase is a column oriented database
management system derived from google's
nosql database bigtable that runs on top
of the hadoop file system or the hdfs
it's an open source project that is
horizontally scalable and that's very
important to understand that you don't
have to buy a bunch of huge expensive
computers you're expanding it by
continually adding commodity machines
and so it's a linear cost expansion as
opposed to being exponential no sql
database written in java which permits
faster querying so java is the back end
for the hbase setup and it's well suited
for sparse data sets so can contain
missing or n a values and this doesn't
boggle it down like it would in other
database companies using hbase so let's
take a look and see who is using this
nosql database for their servers and for
storing their data and we have
hortonworks which isn't a surprise
because they're one of the like cloudera
hortonworks they are behind hadoop and
one of the big developments and backing
of it and of course apache hbase is the
open source behind it and we have
capital one as banks you also see bank
of america where they're collecting
information on people and tracking it so
their information might be very sparse
they might have one bank way back when
they collected information as far as the
person's family and what their income
for the whole family is and their
personal income and maybe another one
doesn't collect the family income as you
start seeing where you have data that is
very difficult to store where it's
missing a bunch of data hubspot's using
it facebook
certainly all of your facebook twitter
most of your social medias are using it
and then of course there's jp morgan
chase and company another bank that uses
the hbase as their data warehouse for
nos sql let's take a look at an hbase
use case so we can dig a little bit more
into it to see how it functions
telecommunication company that provides
mobile voice and multimedia services
across china the china mobile and china
mobile they generate billions of call
detailed records or cdr and so these
cdrs and all these records are these
calls and how long they are and
different aspects of the call maybe the
tower they're broadcasted from all that
is being recorded so they can track it a
traditional database systems were unable
to scale up to the vast volumes of data
and provide a cost-effective solution no
good so storing and real-time analysis
of billions of call records was a major
problem for this company solution apache
hbase hbase stores billions of rows of
detailed call records hbc performs fast
processing of records using sql queries
so you can mix your sql and no sql
queries and usually just say no sql
queries because of the way the query
works applications of hbase one of them
would be in the medical industry hbase
is used for storing genome sequences
storing disease history of people of an
area and you can imagine how sparse that
is as far as both of those a genome
sequence might be only have pieces to it
that each person is unique or is unique
to different people and the same thing
with disease you really don't need a
column for every possible disease a
person could get you just want to know
what those diseases those people have
had to deal with in that area e-commerce
hbase is used for storing logs about
customer search history performs
analytics and target advertisement for
better business insights sports hba
stores match details in the history of
each match uses this data for better
prediction so when we look at hbase we
all want to know what's the difference
between hbase versus rdbms that is a
relational database management system
hbase versus rdbms so the hbase does not
have a fixed schema it's schema-less
defines only column families and we'll
show you what that means later on rdbms
has a fixed schema which describes the
structure of the tables and you can
think of this as you have a row and you
have columns and each column is a very
specific structure how much data can go
in there and what it does with the hbase
it works well with structured and
semi-structured data with the rdbms it
works only well with structured data
with the age base it can have
denormalized data it can contain missing
or null values with the rdbms it can
store only normalized data now you can
still store a null value in the rdbms
but it still takes up the same space as
if you're storing a regular value in
many cases and it also for the hbase is
built for y tables it can be scaled
horizontally for instance if you were
doing a tokenizer of words and word
clusters you might have 1.4 million
different words that you're pulling up
and combinations of words so with an
rdbms it's built for thin tables that
are hard to scale you don't want to
store 1.4 million columns in your sql
it's going to crash and it's going to be
very hard to do searches with the age
base it only stores that data which is
part of whatever row you're working on
let's look at some of the features of
the hbase it's scalable data can be
scaled across various nodes as it is
stored in the hdfs and always think
about this it's a linear add-on for each
terabyte of data i'm adding on roughly a
thousand dollars in commodity computing
with an enterprise machine we're looking
at about 10 000 at the lower end for
each terabyte of data and that includes
all your backup and redundancy so it's a
big difference it's like a tenth of the
cost to store it across the h base it
has automatic failure support right
ahead log across clusters which provides
automatic support against failure
consistent read and write hbase provides
consistent read and write of the data
it's a java api for client access
provides easy to use java api for
clients block cache and bloom filters so
the hbase supports block caching and
bloom filters for high volume query
optimization let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase storage hbase column
oriented storage and i told you we're
going to look into this to see how it
stores the data and here you can see you
have a row key this is really one of the
important references is each row has to
have its own key or your row id and then
you have your column family and in here
you can see we have column family one
column family two column family three
and you have your column qualifiers so
you can have in column family one you
can have three columns in there and
there might not be any data in that so
when you go into column family 1 and do
a query for every column that contains a
certain thing that row might not have
anything in there and not be queried
where in column family 2 maybe you have
column 1 filled out and column 3 filled
out and so on and so forth and then each
cell is connected to the row where the
data is actually stored let's take a
look at this at what it looks like when
you fill the data in so in here we have
a row key with a row id and we have our
employee id 123. that's pretty
straightforward you probably would even
have that on an sql server and then you
have your column family this is where it
starts really separating out your column
family you might have personal data and
under personal data you would have name
city age you might have a lot more than
just that you might have number of
children you might have degree all those
kinds of different things that go under
personal data and some of them might be
missing you might only have the name and
the age of an employee you might only
have the name the city and how many
children and not the age and so you can
see with the personal data you can now
collect a large variety of data and
store it in the hbase very easily and
then maybe you have a family of
professional data your designation your
salary all the stuff that the employee
is doing for you in that company let's
dig a little deeper into the hbase
architecture and so you can see here
what looks to be a complicated chart
it's not as complicated as you think
from the apache a space we have the
zookeeper which is used for monitoring
what's going on and you have your h
master this is the hbase master of
science regions and load balancing and
then underneath the region or the hbase
master then under the h master or hbase
master you have your read your server
serves data for read and write and the
region server which is all your
different computers you have in your
hadoop cluster you'll have a region an h
log you'll have a store memory store and
then you have your different files for h
file that are stored on there and those
are separated across the different
computers and that's all part of the
hdfs storage system so we look at the
architectural components or regions and
we're looking at we're drilling down a
little bit hbase tables are divided
horizontally by a row so you have a key
range into regions so each of those ids
you might have ids 1 to 20 21 to 50 or
whatever they are regions are assigned
to the nodes in the cluster called
region servers a region contains all
rows in the table between the regions
start key and the end key again 1 to 10
11 to 20 and so forth these servers
serve data for read and write and you
can see here we have the client and the
get and the git sends it out and it
finds out where that start if it's
between which start keys and n keys and
then it pulls the data from that
different region server and so the
region sign data definition language
operation create delete are handled by
the h master so the h master is telling
it what are we doing with this data
what's going out there assigning and
reassigning regions for recovery or load
balancing and monitoring all servers so
that's also part of it so you know if
your ids if you have 500 ids across
three servers you're not going to put
400 ids on server 1 and 100 on the
server 2 and leaves region 3 and region
4 empty you're going to split that up
and that's all handled by the h master
and you can see here it monitors region
servers assigns regions to region
servers assigns regions to reason
servers and so forth and so forth hbase
has a distributed environment where
h-master alone is not sufficient to
manage everything hence zookeeper was
introduced it works with h-master so you
have an active h-master which sends a
heartbeat signal to zookeeper indicating
that it's active and the zookeeper also
has a heartbeat to the region servers so
the region servers send their status to
zoo keeper indicating they are ready for
read and write operation inactive server
acts as a backup if the active h-master
fails it will come to the rescue active
h-master and region servers connect with
a session to zoo keeper so you see your
active h-master selection region server
session they're all looking at the
zookeeper keeping that pulse an active
h-master region server connects with a
session to the zookeeper and you can see
here where we have ephemeral nodes for
active sessions via heartbeats to
indicate that the region servers are up
and running so let's take a look at
hbase read or write going on there's a
special hbase catalog table called the
meta table which holds the location of
the regions in the cluster here's what
happens the first time a client reads or
writes data to hbase the client gets the
region server the host the meta table
from zookeeper and you can see right
here the client has a request for your
region server and goes hey zookeeper can
you handle this the zookeeper takes a
look at it goes ah middle location is
stored in zookeeper so it looks at his
meta data on there and then the metadata
table location is sent back to the
client the client will query the meta
server to get the region server
corresponding to the row key if it wants
to access the client caches this
information along with the meta table
location and you can see here the client
going back and forth to the region
server with the information and it might
be going across multiple region servers
depending on what you're querying so we
get the region server for row key from
the meta table that's where that row key
comes in and says hey this is where
we're going with this and so once it
gets a row key from the corresponding
region server we can now put row or git
row from that region server let's take a
look at the hbase meta table special
hbase catalog table that maintains a
list of all the region servers in the
hbase storage system so you see here we
have the meta table we have a row key
and a value table key region region
server so the meta table is used to find
the region for the given table key and
you can see down here your meta table
comes in it's going to fire out where
it's going with the region server and we
look a little closer at the right
mechanism in hbase we have right ahead
log or wall as you abbreviate it kind of
a way to remember wall is right ahead
log is a file used to store new data
that is yet to be put on permanent
storage it is used for recovery in the
case of failure so you can see here
where the client comes in and it
literally puts the new data coming in
into this kind of temporary storage or
the wall on there once it's gone into
the wall then the memory store memstor
is the right cache that stores a new
data that has not yet been written to
disk there is one mem store per column
family per region and once we've done
that we have three ack once the data is
placed in memstor the client then
receives the acknowledgement when the
mim store reaches the threshold it dumps
or commits the data into h file as you
can see right here we've taken our our
gun into the wall the wall then source
it into the different memory stores uh
and then the memory stores it says hey
we've reached we're ready to dump that
into our h files and then it moves it
into the h files h files store the rows
as data as stored key value on disk so
here we've done a lot of theory let's
dive in and just take a look and see
what some of these commands look like
and what happens in our age base when
we're manipulating a nosql setup
[Music]
so if you're learning a new setup it's
always good to start with where is this
coming from it's open source by apache
and you can go to
hbase.apache.org and you'll see that
there's a lot of information you can
actually download the hbase separate
from the hadoop although most people
just install the hadoop because it's
bundled with it and if you go in here
you'll find a reference guide and you
can go through the apache reference
guide and there's a number of things to
look at but we're going to be going
through apache hbase shell that's what
we're going to be working with and
there's a lot of other interfaces on the
setup and you can look up a lot of the
different commands on here so we go into
the apache hbase reference guide we go
down to read hbase shell commands from a
command file you can see here where it
gives you different options of formats
for putting the data in and listing the
data certainly can also create files and
scripts to do this too but we're going
to look at the basics we're going to go
through this on a basic hbase shell and
one last thing to look at is of course
if you continue down the setup you can
see here where they have more detail as
far as how to create and how to get to
your data on your hbase now i will be
working in a virtual box and this is by
oracle you can download the oracle
virtual box you can put a note in below
for the youtube as we did have a
previous session on setting up virtual
setup to run your hadoop system in there
i'm using the cloudera quick start
installed in here there's hortons you
can also use the amazon web service
there's a number of options for trying
this out in this case we have cloudera
on the oracle virtualbox the virtual box
has linux centos installed on it and
then the hadoop has all the different
hadoop flavors including hbase and i
bring this up because my computer is a
windows 10 the operating system of the
virtual box is linux and we're looking
at the hbase data warehouse and so we
have three very different entities all
running on my computer and that can be
confusing if it's the first time in and
working with this kind of setup now
you'll notice in our cloudera setup they
actually have some hbase monitoring so i
can go underneath here and click on
hbase and master and it'll tell me
what's going on with my region servers
it'll tell me what's going on with our
backup tables right now i don't have any
user tables because we haven't created
any and this is only a single node and a
single hbase tour so you're not going to
expect anything too extensive in here
since this is for practice and education
and perhaps testing out package you're
working on it's not for really you can
deploy cloudair of course but when you
talk about a quick start or a single
node setup that's what it's really for
so we can go through all the different
hbase and you'll see all kinds of
different information with zookeeper if
you saw it flash by down here what
version we're working in since zookeeper
is part of the hbase setup where we want
to go is we want to open up a terminal
window and in cloudera it happens to be
up at the top and when you click on here
you'll see your cloudera terminal window
open and let me just expand this so we
have a nice full screen and then i'm
also going to zoom in that way you have
a nice big picture and you can see what
i'm typing what's going on and to open
up your hbase shell simply type hbase
shell to get in and hit enter and you'll
see it takes just a moment to load and
we'll be in our hbase shell for doing
hbase commands once we've gotten into
our hbase shell you'll see it'll have
the hbase prompt information ahead of it
we can do something simple like list
this is going to list whatever tables we
have and it so happens that there's a
base table that comes with hbase now we
can go ahead and create and i'm going to
type in just create what's nice about
this is it's going to throw me kind of a
it's going to say hey there's no just
straight create it does come up and tell
me all these different formats we can
use for create so we can create our
table and one of our families you can
add splits names versions all kinds of
things you can do with this let's just
start with a very basic one on here and
let's go ahead and create and we'll call
it new table now let's just call it new
tbl for table new table and then we also
want to do let's do knowledge so let's
take a look at this i'm creating a new
table and it's going to have a family of
knowledge in it and let me hit enter
it's going to come up it's going to take
it a second to go ahead and create it
now we have our new table in here so if
i go list you'll now see table and new
table so you can now see that we have
the new table and of course the default
table that's set up in here and we can
do something like
describe we can describe and then we're
going to do new tbl and when we describe
it it's going to come up it's going to
say hey name i have knowledge data block
encoding none bloom filter row or
replication scope version all the
different information you need new
minimum version zero forever deleted
cells false block size in memory and you
can look this stuff up on apache.org to
really track it down one of the things
that's important to note is versions so
you have your different versions of the
data that's stored and that's always
important to understand that we might
talk about that a little bit later on
and then we have to describe it we can
also do a status the status says i have
one active master going on that's our
hbase as a whole we can do status
summary it should do the same thing as
status so we got the same thing coming
up and now that we've created let's go
ahead and put something in it so we're
going to put new tbl and then we want
row one you know what before i even do
this let's just type in put and you can
see when i type in put it gives us like
a lot of different options of how it
works and different ways of formatting
our data as it goes in and all of them
usually begin with the new table new tbl
then we have in this case we'll call it
row one and then we'll have knowledge
remember we created knowledge already
and we'll do knowledge
sports and then in knowledge and sports
we're going to set that equal to cricket
so we're going to put underneath this uh
our knowledge set up that we have a
thing called sports in there and we'll
see what this looks like in just a
second let's go ahead and put in we'll
do a couple of these let's see let's do
another row one and this time set of
sports let's do
science you know this person not only
you know we have row one which is both
knowledgeable and cricket and also in
chemistry so it's a chemist who plays
qriket in row one and uh let's see if we
have let's do another row one just to
keep it going and we'll do science in
this case let's do physics not only in
chemistry but also a physicist i have
quite a joy in physics myself so here we
go we have uh row one there we go and
then let's do uh row two let's see what
that looks like when we start putting in
row two and in row two this person is
has knowledge in economics this is a
master of business and how or maybe it's
global economics maybe it's just for the
business and how it fits in with the
country's economics and i would call it
macro economics so i guess it is for the
whole country there so we have knowledge
economics macroeconomics and then let's
just do one more we'll keep it as row
two and this time our economist is also
a musician so we'll put music and they
happen to have knowledge and they enjoy
oh let's do pop music they're into the
current pop music going on so we've
loaded our database and you'll see we
have two rows row one and row two in
here and we can do is we can list the
contents of our database by simply doing
scan
scan and then let's just do scan by
itself so you can see how that looks you
can always just type in there and it
tells you all the different setups you
can do with scan and how it works in
this case we want to do scan new tbl and
in our scan new tbl we have row one row
one row two row two and you'll see row
one has a column called knowledge
science time step value crickets value
physics so it has information as when it
was created when the timestamp is row
one also has knowledge sports and a
value of cricket so we have sports and
science and this is interesting because
if you remember up here we also gave it
originally we told it to come in here
and have chemistry we had science
chemistry and science physics and we
come down here i don't see the chemistry
why because we've now replaced chemistry
with physics so the new value is physics
on here let me go ahead and clear down a
little bit and in this we're going to
ask the question is enabled new table
when i hit enter in here you're going to
see it comes out true and then we'll go
ahead and disable it let's go ahead and
disable new table make sure i have our
quotes around it and now that we've
disabled it what happens when we do the
scan when we do the scan new table and
hit enter you're going to see that we
get an error coming up so once it's
disabled you can't do anything with it
until we re-enable it now before we
enable the table let's do an alteration
on it and here's our new table and this
should look a little familiar because
it's very similar to create we'll call
this test info we'll hit enter in there
it'll take just a moment for updating
and then we want to go ahead and enable
it so let's go ahead and enable our new
table so it's back up and running and
then we want to describe describe
new table and we come in here you'll now
see we have name knowledge and under
there we have our data encoding and all
the information under knowledge and then
we also have down below test info so now
we have the name test info and all the
information concerning the test info on
here and we'll simply enable it new
table so now it's enabled oops already
did that i guess we'll enable it twice
and so let's start looking at well we
had scan new table and you can see here
it brings up the information like this
but what if we want to go ahead and get
a row so we'll do r1 and when we do
hbase r1 you can see we have knowledge
science and it has a time stamp value
physics and we have knowledge sports and
it has a time stamp on it and value
cricket and then let's see what happens
we put into our
new
table and in here we want row one and if
you can guess from earlier because we
did something similar we're going to do
knowledge economics and then it's going
to be instead of i think it was what uh
macro economics is now market economics
and we'll go back and do our get command
and now see what it looks like and we
can see here where we have knowledge
economics it has a timestamp value
market economics physics and cricket and
this is because we have economics
science and sports those are the three
different columns that we have and then
each one has different information in it
and so if you managed to go through all
these commands and look at basics on
here you'll now have the ability to
create a very basic hbase setup nosql
setup based on your columns and your
rows and just for fun we'll go back to
the cloudera thanks guys i hope you guys
found this informative with this we've
come to the end of our detailed look
into the hadoop ecosystem now we have
shruti who will explain big data
analytics and some applications of big
data let us now understand why big data
analytics is required with an example so
all of you listen to music online isn't
it here we will take an example of
spotify which is a swedish audio
streaming platform and see how big data
analytics is used here spotify has
nearly 96 plus million users and all
these users generate a tremendous amount
of data data like the songs which are
played repeatedly the numerous likes
shares and the user search history all
these data can be termed as big data
here with respect to spotify have you
ever wondered what spotify does with all
this big data well spotify analyzes this
big data for suggesting songs to its
users i'm sure all of you might have
come across the recommendation list
which is made available to each one of
you by spotify each one of you will have
a totally different recommendation list
this is based on your likes your past
history like the songs you like
listening to and your playlists this
works on something known as the
recommendation system recommendation
systems are nothing but data filtering
tools they collect all the data and then
filter them using various algorithms
this system has the ability to
accurately predict what a user would
like to listen to next with the help of
big data analytics this prediction helps
the users stay on the page for a longer
time and by doing so spotify engages all
its users the users don't have the need
to go on searching for different songs
this is because spotify readily provides
them with a variety of songs according
to their taste well this is how big data
analytics is used by spotify now that we
have understood why big data analytics
is required let us move on to our next
topic that is what is big data analytics
but before that there is another term we
need to understand that is big data we
all hear the term big data many times
but do you know what exactly big data
means well we will understand the term
big data clearly right now big data is a
term for data sets that cannot be
handled by traditional computers or
tools due to their value volume velocity
and veracity it is defined as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
processed and analyzed using various
traditional methods do you know how much
data is being generated every day every
second even as i talk right now there
are millions of data sources which
generate data at a very rapid rate these
data sources are present across the
world as you know social media sites
generate a lot of data let's take an
example of facebook facebook generates
over 500 plus terabytes of data every
day this data is mainly generated in
terms of your photographs videos
messages etc big data also contains data
of different formats like structured
data semi-structured data and
unstructured data data like your excel
sheets all fall under structured data
this data has a definite format your
emails fall under semi-structured and
your pictures and videos all fall under
unstructured data all these data
together make up for big data it is very
tough to store process and analyze big
data using rtbms if you have looked into
our previous videos you would know that
hadoop is the solution to this hadoop is
a framework that stores and processes
big data it stores big data using the
distributed storage system and it
processes big data using the parallel
processing method hence storing and
processing big data is no more a problem
using hadoop big data in its raw form is
of no use to us we must try to derive
meaningful information from it in order
to benefit from this big data do you
know amazon uses big data to monitor its
items that are in its fulfillment
centers across the globe how do you
think amazon does this well it is done
by analyzing big data which is known as
big data analytics what is big data
analytics in simple terms big data
analytics is defined as the process
which is used to extract meaningful
information from big data this
information could be your hidden
patterns unknown correlations market
trends and so on by using big data
analytics there are many advantages it
can be used for better decision making
to prevent fraudulent activities and
many others we will look into four of
them step by step i will first start off
with big data analytics which is used
for risk management bdo which is a
philippine banking company uses big data
analytics for risk management risk
management is an important aspect for
any organization especially in the field
of banking risk management analysis
comprises a series of measures which are
employed to prevent any sort of
unauthorized activities identifying
fraudulent activities was a main concern
for bdo it was difficult for the bank to
identify the fraudster from a long list
of suspects bdo adopted big data
analytics which held the bank to narrow
down the entire list of suspects thus
the organization was able to identify
the fraudster in a very short time this
is how big data analytics is used in the
field of banking for risk management let
us now see how big data analytics is
used for product development and
innovations with an example all of you
are aware of rolls-royce cars right do
you also know that they manufacture jet
engines which are used across the world
what is more interesting is that they
use big data analytics for developing
and innovating this engine a new product
is always developed by trial and error
method big data analytics is used here
to analyze if an engine design is good
or bad it is also used to analyze if
there can be more scope for improvement
based on the previous models and on the
future demands this way big data
analytics is used in designing a product
which is of higher quality using big
data analytics the company can save a
lot of time if the team is struggling to
arrive at the right conclusion big data
can be used to zero in on the right data
which have to be studied and thus the
time spent on the product development is
less big data analytics helps in quicker
and better decision making in
organizations the process of selecting a
course of action from various other
alternatives is known as decision making
lot of organizations take important
decisions based on the data that they
have data driven business decisions can
make or break a company hence it is
important to analyze all the
possibilities thoroughly and quickly
before making important decisions
let us now try to understand this with
an use case starbucks uses big data
analytics for making important decisions
they decide the location of their new
outlet using big data analytics choosing
the right location is an important
factor for any organization the wrong
location will not be able to attract the
required amount of customers positioning
of a new outlet a few miles here or
there can always make a huge difference
for an outlet especially a one like
starbucks various factors are involved
in choosing the right location for a new
outlet for example parking adequacy has
to be taken into consideration it would
be inconvenient for people to go to a
store which has no parking facility
similarly the other factors that have to
be considered are the visibility of the
location the accessibility the economic
factors the population of that
particular location and also we would
have to look into the competition in the
vicinity all these factors have to be
thoroughly analyzed before making a
decision as to where the new outlet must
be started without analyzing these
factors it would be impossible for us to
make a wise decision using big data
analytics we can consider all these
factors and analyze them quickly and
thoroughly thus starbucks makes use of
big data analytics to understand if
their new location would be fruitful or
not finally we will look into how big
data analytics is used to improve
customer experience using an example
delta an american airline uses big data
analytics to improve its customer
experiences with the increase in global
air travel it is necessary that an
airline does everything they can in
order to provide good service and
experience to its customers delta
airlines improves its customer
experience by making use of big data
analytics this is done by monitoring
tweets which will give them an idea as
to how their customers journey was if
the airline comes across a negative
tweet and if it is found to be the
airline's fault the airline goes ahead
and upgrades that particular customer's
ticket when this happens the customer is
able to trust the airlines and without a
doubt the customer will choose delta for
their next journey by doing so the
customer is happy and the airlines will
be able to build a good brand
recognition thus we see here that by
using analysis delta airlines was able
to improve its customer experience
moving on to our next topic that is life
cycle of big data analytics here we will
look into the various stages as to how
data is analyzed from scratch the first
stage is the business case evaluation
stage here the motive behind the
analysis is identified we need to
understand why we are analyzing so that
we know how to do it and what are the
different parameters that have to be
looked into once this is done it is
clear for us and it becomes much easier
for us to proceed with the rest after
which we will look into the various data
sources from where we can gather all the
data which will be required for analysis
once we get the required data we will
have to see if the data that we received
is fit for analysis or not not all the
data that we receive will have
meaningful information summer fit will
surely just speak corrupt data to remove
this corrupt data we will pass this
entire data through a filtering stage in
this stage all the corrupt data will be
removed now we have the data minus the
corrupt data do you think our data is
now fit for analysis well it is not we
still have to figure out which data will
be compatible with the tool that we will
be using for analysis if we find data
which is incompatible we first extract
it and then transform it to a compatible
form depending on the tool that we use
in the next stage all the data with the
same fields will be integrated this is
known as the data aggregation stage the
next stage which is the analysis stage
is a very important stage in the life
cycle of big data analytics right here
in this step the entire process of
evaluating your data using various
analytical and statistical tools to
discover meaningful information is done
like we have discussed before the entire
process of deriving meaningful
information from data which is known as
analysis is done here in this stage the
result of the data analysis stage is
then graphically communicated using
tools like tableau power bi click view
this analysis result will then be made
available to different business
stakeholders for various decision making
this was the entire life cycle of big
data analytics we just saw how data is
analyzed from scratch now we will move
on to a very important topic that is the
different types of big data analytics
well we have four different types of big
data analytics as you see here these are
the types and below this are the
questions that each type tries to answer
we have descriptive analytics which asks
the question what has happened then we
have diagnostic analytics which asks why
did it happen predictive analytics
asking what will happen and prescriptive
analytics which questions by asking what
is the solution we will look into all
these four one by one with an use case
for each we will first start off with
descriptive analytics as mentioned
earlier descriptive analytics asks the
question what has happened it can be
defined as the type that summarizes past
data into a form that can be understood
by humans in this type we will look into
the past data and arrive at various
conclusions for example
an organization can review its
performance using descriptive analytics
that is it analyzes its past data such
as revenue over the years and arrives at
a conclusion with the profit by looking
at this graph we can understand if the
company is running at a profit or not
thus descriptive analytics helps us
understand this easily we can simply say
that descriptive analytics is used for
creating various reports for companies
and also for tabulating various social
media metrics like facebook likes tweets
etc now that we have seen what is
descriptive analytics let us look into
and use case of descriptive analytics
the dow chemical company analyzed all
its past data using descriptive
analytics and by doing so they were able
to identify the underutilized space in
their facility descriptive analytics
helped them in this space consolidation
on the whole the company was able to
save nearly four million dollars
annually so we now see here that
descriptive analytics not only helps us
derive meaningful information from the
past data but it can also help companies
in cost reduction if it is used wisely
let us now move on to our next type that
is diagnostic analytics diagnostic
analytics asks the question why a
particular problem has occurred as you
can see it will always ask the question
why did it happen it will look into the
root cause of a problem and try to
understand why it has occurred
diagnostic analytics makes use of
various techniques such as data mining
data discovery and drill down companies
benefit from this type of analytics
because it helps them look into the root
cause of a problem by doing so the next
time the same problem will not arise as
the company already knows why it has
happened and they will arrive at a
particular solution for it initsoft's bi
query tool is an example of diagnostic
analytics we can use query tool for
diagnostic analytics now that you know
why diagnostic analytics is required and
what diagnostic analytics is i will run
you through an example which shows where
diagnostic analytics can be used all of
us shop on e-commerce sites right have
you ever added items to your cart but
ended up not buying it yes all of us
might have done that at some point an
organization tries to understand why its
customers don't end up buying their
products although it has been added to
their cuts and this understanding is
done with the help of diagnostic
analytics an e-commerce site wonders why
they have made few online sales although
they have had a very good marketing
strategy there could have been various
factors as to why this has happened
factors like the shipping fee which was
too high or the page that didn't load
correctly not enough payment options
available and so on all these factors
are analyzed using diagnostic analytics
and the company comes to a conclusion as
to why this has happened thus we see
here that the root cause is identified
so that in future the same problem
doesn't occur again let us now move on
to the third type that is predictive
analytics as the name suggests
predictive analytics makes predictions
of the future it analyzes the current
and historical facts to make predictions
about future it always asks the question
what will happen next predictive
analytics is used with the help of
artificial intelligence machine learning
data mining to analyze the data it can
be used for predicting customer trends
market trends customer behavior etc it
solely works on probability it always
tries to understand what can happen next
with the help of all the past and
current information a company like
paypal which has 260 plus million
accounts always has the need to ensure
that their online fraudulent and
unauthorized activities are brought down
to nil fear of constant fraudulent
activities have always been a major
concern for paypal when a fraudulent
activity occurs people lose trust in the
company and this brings in a very bad
name for the brand it is inevitable that
fraudulent activities will happen in a
company like paypal which is one of the
largest online payment processors in the
world but paypal uses analytics wisely
here to prevent such fraudulent
activities and to minimize them it uses
predictive analytics to do so the
organization is able to analyze past
data which includes a customer's
historical payment data a customer's
behavior trend and then it builds an
algorithm which works on predicting what
is likely to happen next with respect to
their transaction with the use of big
data and algorithms the system can gauge
which of the transactions are valid and
which could be potentially a fraudulent
activity by doing so paypal is always
ready with precautions that they have to
take to protect all their clients
against fraudulent transactions we will
now move on to our last type that is
prescriptive analytics prescriptive
analytics as the name suggests always
prescribes a solution to a particular
problem the problem can be something
which is happening currently hence it
can be termed as the type that always
asks the question what is the solution
prescriptive analytics is related to
both predictive and descriptive
analytics as we saw earlier descriptive
analytics always asks the question what
has happened and predictive analytics
helps you understand what can happen
next with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
prescriptive analytics helps you arrive
at the best solution for a particular
problem various business rules
algorithms and computational modeling
procedures are used in prescriptive
analytics let us now have a look at how
and where prescriptive analytics is used
with an example here we will understand
how prescriptive analytics is used by an
airline for its profit do you know that
when you book a flight ticket the price
of it depends on various factors both
internal and external factors apart from
taxes seed selection there are other
factors like oil prices customer demand
which are all taken into consideration
before the flight sphere is displayed
prices change due to availability and
demand holiday seasons are a time when
the rates are much higher than the
normal days seasons like christmas and
school vacations also weekends the rates
will be much higher than weekdays
another factor which determines a
flight's fair is your destination
depending on the place where you are
traveling to the flight fair will be
adjusted accordingly this is because
there are quite a few places where the
air traffic is less and in such places
the flight sphere will also be less so
prescriptive analytics analyzes all
these factors that are discussed and it
builds an algorithm which will
automatically adjust a flight sphere by
doing so the airline is able to maximize
its profit these were the four types of
analytics now let us understand how we
achieve these with the use of big data
tools our next topic will be the various
tools used in big data analytics these
are a few of the tools that i will be
talking about today we have hadoop
mongodb talindi kafka cassandra spark
and storm we will look into each one of
them one by one we will first start off
with hadoop when you speak of big data
the first framework that comes into
everyone's mind is hadoop isn't it as i
mentioned earlier apache hadoop is used
to store and process big data in a
distributed and parallel fashion it
allows us to process data very fast
hadoop uses mapreduce big and high for
analyzing this big data hadoop is easily
one of the most famous big data tools
now let us move on to the next one that
is mongodb mongodb is a cross-platform
document-oriented database it has the
ability to deal with large amount of
unstructured data processing of data
which is unstructured and processing of
data sets that change very frequently is
done using mongodb talendi provides
software and services for data
integration data management and cloud
storage it specializes in big data
integration talent a open studio is a
free open source tool for processing
data easily on a big data environment
cassandra is used widely for an
effective management of large amounts of
data it is similar to hadoop in its
feature of fault tolerance where data is
automatically replicated to multiple
nodes cassandra is preferred for
real-time processing spark is another
tool that is used for data processing
this data processing engine is developed
to process data way faster than hadoop
mapreduce this is done in a way because
spark does all the processing in the
main memory of the data nodes and thus
it prevents unnecessary input output
overheads with the disk whereas
mapreduce is disk based and hence spark
proves to be faster than hadoop
mapreduce storm is a free big data
computational system which is done in
real time it is one of the easiest tools
for big data analysis it can be used
with any programming language this
feature makes storm very simple to use
finally we will look into another big
data tool which is known as kafka kafka
is a distributed streaming platform
which was developed by linkedin and
later given to apache software
foundation it is used to provide
real-time analytics result and it is
also used for fault tolerant storage
these were few of the big data analytics
tools the first big data application we
will look into is weather forecast
imagine there is a sudden storm and
you're not even prepared that would be a
terrifying situation isn't it dealing
with any calamities such as hurricane
storms floods would be very inconvenient
if we are caught off guard the solution
is to have a tool that predicts the
weather of the coming days well in
advance this tool needs to be accurate
and to make such a tool big data is used
so how does big data help here well it
allows us to gather all the information
required to predict the weather
information such as the climate change
details wind direction precipitation
previous weather reports and so on after
all this data is collected it becomes
easier for us to spot a trend and
identify what's going to happen next by
analyzing all of this big data a weather
prediction engine works on this analysis
it predicts the weather of every region
across the world for any given time by
using such a tool we can be well
prepared to face any climate change or
any natural calamity let's take an
example of a landslide and try to
understand how big data is used to
tackle such a situation predicting a
landslide is very difficult with just
the basic warning signs lack of this
prediction can cause a huge damage to
life and property this challenge was
studied by the university of melbourne
and they developed a tool which is
capable of predicting a landslide this
tool predicts the boundary where a
landslide is likely to occur two weeks
before this magical tool works on both
big data and applied mathematics an
accurate prediction like this which is
made two weeks before can save lives and
help in relocating people in that
particular region it also gives us an
insight into the magnitude of the
upcoming destruction this is how big
data is used in weather forecast and in
predicting any natural calamities across
the world let us now move on to our next
application that is big data application
in the field of media and entertainment
the media and the entertainment industry
is a massive one leveraging big data
here can produce sky-high results and
boost the revenue for any company let us
see the different ways in which big data
is used in this industry have you ever
noticed that you come across relevant
advertisements in your social media
sites and in your mailboxes well this is
done by analyzing all your data such as
your previous browsing history and your
purchase data publishers then display
what you like in the form of ads which
will in turn catch your interest in
looking into it next up is customer
sentiment analysis customers are very
important for a company the happier the
customer the greater the company's
revenue big data helps in gathering all
the emotions of a customer through their
posts messages conversations etc these
emotions are then analyzed to arrive at
a conclusion regarding the customer
satisfaction if the customer is unhappy
the company strives to do better the
next time and provides their customers a
better experience while purchasing an
item from an e-commerce site or while
watching videos on an entertainment site
you might have noticed a segment which
says most recommended list for you this
list is a personalized list which is
made available to you by analyzing all
the data such as your previous watch
history your subscriptions your likes
and so on recommendation engine is a
tool that filters and analyzes all this
data and provides you with a list that
you would most likely be interested in
by doing so the site is able to retain
and engage its customer for a longer
time next is customer churn analysis in
simple words customer churn happens when
a customer stops a subscription with a
service predicting and preventing this
is of paramount importance to any
organization by analyzing the behavioral
patterns of previously churned customers
an organization can identify which of
their current customers are likely to
churn by analyzing all of this data the
organization can then implement
effective programs for customer
retention let us now look into an use
case of starbucks big data is
effectively used by the starbucks app 17
million users use this app and you can
imagine how much data they generate data
in the form of their coffee buying
habits the store they visit and to the
time they purchase all of this data is
fed into the app so when a customer
enters a new starbucks location the
system analyzes all their data and they
are provided with their preferred order
this app also suggests new products to
the customer in addition to this they
also provide personalized offer and
discounts on special occasions moving on
to our next sector which is healthcare
it is one of the most important sectors
big data is widely used here to save
lives with all the available big data
medical researches are done very
effectively they are performed
accurately by analyzing all the previous
medical histories and new treatments and
medicines are discovered cure can be
found out even for few of the incurable
diseases there are cases when one
medication need not be effective for
every patient hence personal care is
very important personal care is provided
to each patient depending on their past
medical history an individual's medical
history along with their body parameters
are analyzed and personal attention is
given to each of them as we all know
medical treatments are not very pocket
friendly every time a medical treatment
is taken the amount increases this can
be reduced if readmissions are brought
down analyzing all the data precisely
will deliver a long-term efficient
result which will in turn prevent a
patient's readmission frequently with
globalization came an increase in the
ease for infectious diseases to spread
widely based on geography and
demographics big data helps in
predicting where an outbreak of epidemic
viruses are most likely to occur an
american healthcare company united
healthcare uses big data to detect any
online medical fraud activities such as
payment of unauthorized benefits
intentional misrepresentation of data
and so on the healthcare company runs
disease management programs the success
rates of these programs are predicted
using big data depending on how patients
respond to it the next sector we will
look into is logistics logistics looks
into the process of transportation and
storage of goods the movement of a
product from its supplier to a consumer
is very important big data is used to
make this process faster and efficient
the most important factor in logistics
is the time taken for the products to
reach their destination to achieve
minimum time sensors within the vehicle
analyze the fastest route this analysis
is based on various data such as the
weather traffic the list of orders and
so on by doing so the fastest route is
obtained and the delivery time is
reduced capacity planning is another
factor which needs to be taken into
consideration details regarding the
workforce and the number of vehicles are
analyzed thoroughly and each vehicle is
allocated a different route this is done
as there is no need for many trucks to
travel in the same direction which will
be pointless depending on the analysis
of the available workforce and resources
this decision is taken big data
analytics also finds its use in managing
warehouses efficiently this analysis
along with tracking sensors provide
information regarding the underutilized
space which results in efficient
resource allocation and eventually
reduces the cost customer satisfaction
is important in logistics just like it
is in any other sector customer
reactions are analyzed from the
available data which will eventually
create an instant feedback loop a happy
customer will always help the company
gain more customers let us now look into
a use case of ups as you know ups is one
of the biggest shipping company in the
world they have a huge customer database
and they work on data every minute ups
uses big data to gather different kinds
of data regarding the weather the
traffic jams the geography the locations
and so on after collecting all this data
they analyze it to discover the best and
the fastest route to the destination in
addition to this they also use big data
to change the routes in real time this
is how efficiently ups leverages big
data next up we have a very interesting
sector that is the travel and tourism
sector the global tourism market is
expected to grow in the near future big
data is used in various ways in this
sector let us look into a few of them
hotels can increase their revenue by
adjusting the room tariffs depending on
the peak seasons such as holiday seasons
festive seasons and so on the tourism
industry uses all of this data to
anticipate the demand and maximize their
revenue big data is also used by resorts
and hotels to analyze various details
regarding their competitors this
analysis result helps them to
incorporate all the good facilities
their competitors are providing and by
doing so the hotel is able to flourish
further ugly investing in an area which
could be the hub of tourism is very wise
few countries use big data to examine
the tourism activities in their country
and this in turn helps them discover new
and fruitful investment opportunities
let us look into one of the best online
homestay networks airbnb and see how big
data is used by them airbnb undoubtedly
provides its customers with the best
accommodation across the world big data
is used by it to analyze the different
kinds of available properties depending
on the customer's preferences the
pricing the keywords previous customers
ratings and experiences airbnb filters
out the best result big data works its
magic yet again now we will move on to
our final sector which is the government
and law enforcement sector maintaining
law and order is of utmost importance to
any government it is a huge task by
itself big data plays an active role
here and in addition to this it also
helps governments bring in new policies
and schemes for the welfare of its
citizens the police department is able
to predict criminal activities way
before it happens by analyzing big data
information such as the previous crime
records in a particular region the
safety aspect in that region and so on
by analyzing these factors they are able
to predict any activity which breaks the
law and order of the region governments
are able to tackle unemployment to a
great extent by using big data by
analyzing the number of students
graduating every year to the number of
relevant job openings the government can
have an idea of the unemployment rate in
the country and then take necessary
measures to tackle it our next factor is
poverty in large countries it is
difficult to analyze which area requires
attention and development big data
analytics makes it easier for
governments to discover such areas
poverty gradually decreases once these
areas begin to develop
governments have to always be on the
lookout for better development a public
survey voices the opinion of a country's
citizens analyzing all the data
collected from such surveys can help
governments build better policies and
services which will benefit its citizens
let us now move on to our use case did
you know that the new york police
department uses big data analytics to
protect its citizens the department
prevents and identifies crimes by
analyzing a huge amount of data which
includes fingerprints certain emails and
records from previous police
investigations and so on after analyzing
all of this data meaningful insights are
drawn from it which will help the police
in taking the required preventive
measures against crimes thanks shruti
now let me tell you how you can become a
big data engineer hi guys i'm rahul from
simply learn and today i'm going to tell
you how you can become a big data
engineer now it should come as no
surprise for you guys to know that
organizations generate as well as use a
whole lot of data this vast volume of
data is called big data companies use
big data to draw meaningful insights and
take business decisions and big data
engineers are the people who can make
sense out of this enormous amount of
data now let's find out who is a big
data engineer a big data engineer is a
professional who develops maintains
tests and evaluates the company's big
data infrastructure in other words
develop big data solutions based on a
company's requirements they maintain
these solutions they test out these
solutions as to the company's
requirements they integrate this
solution with the various tools and
systems of the organization and finally
they evaluate how well the solution is
working to fulfill the company's
requirements next up let's have a look
at the responsibilities of a big data
engineer now they need to be able to
design implement verify and maintain
software systems now for the process of
ingesting data as well as processing it
they need to be able to build highly
scalable as well as robust systems they
need to be able to extract data from one
database transform it as well as load it
into another data store with the process
of etl or the extract transform load
process and they need to research as
well as propose new ways to acquire data
improve the overall data quality and the
efficiency of the system now to ensure
that all the business requirements are
met they need to build a suitable data
architecture they need to be able to
integrate several programming languages
and tools together so that they can
generate a structured solution they need
to build models that reduce the overall
complexity and increase the efficiency
of the whole system by mining data from
various sources and finally they need to
work well with other teams ones that
include data architects data analysts
and data scientists next up let's have a
look at the skills required to become a
big data engineer the first step is to
have programming knowledge one of the
most important skills required to become
a big data engineer is that of
experience with programming languages
especially hands-on experience now the
big data solutions that organizations
would want you to create will not be
possible without experience in
programming languages i can even tell
you an easy way through which you can
get experience with programming
languages practice practice and more
practice some of the most commonly used
programming languages used for big data
engineering are python java and c plus
the second skill that you require is to
have in-depth knowledge about dbms and
sql you need to know how data is
maintained as well as managed in a
database you need to know how sql can be
used to transform as well as perform
actions on a database and by extension
know how to write sql queries for any
relational database management systems
some of the commonly used database
management systems for big data
engineering mysql oracle database and
the microsoft sql server the third skill
that you require is to have experience
working with etl and warehousing tools
now you need to know how to construct as
well as use a data warehouse so that you
can perform the etl operation or the
extract transform and load operations
now as a big data engineer you'll be
constantly tasked with extracting
unstructured data from a number of
different sources transforming it into
meaningful information and loading it
into other data storages databases or
data warehouses now what this is is
basically aggregating unstructured data
from multiple sources analyzing it so
that you can take better business
decisions some of the tools used for
this purpose are talent ibm data stage
pentaho and informatica next up we have
the fourth skill that you require which
is knowledge about operating systems now
since most big data tools have unique
demands such as root access to operating
system functionality as well as hardware
having a strong understanding of
operating systems like linux and unix is
absolutely mandatory some of the
operating systems used by big data
engineers are unix linux and solaris now
the fifth skill that you require to have
experience with hadoop based analytics
since hadoop is one of the most commonly
used tools when it comes to big data
engineering it's understood that you
need to have experience with apache
hadoop based technologies technologies
like hdfs hadoop map reduce apache edge
base hive and pig the sixth skill that
you require is to have worked with
real-time processing frameworks like
apache spark now as a big data engineer
you'll have to deal with vast volumes of
data so for this data you need an
analytics engine like spark which can be
used for large scale real-time data
processing now spark can process live
streaming data from a number of
different sources like facebook
instagram twitter and so on it can also
perform interactive analysis and data
integration and now we're at our final
skill requirement which is to have
experience with data mining and modeling
so as a data engineer you'll have to
examine massive pre-existing data so
that you can discover patterns as well
as new information with this you'll
create predictive models for your
business so that you can make better
informed decisions some of the tools
used for this are are rapidminer weka
and nime now let's talk about a big data
engineer's salary as well as other roles
they can look forward to now the average
salary of a big data engineer in the
united states is approximately ninety
thousand dollars per year now this
ranges from sixty six thousand dollars
all the way to hundred and thirty
thousand dollars per annum in india the
average salary is around seven lakh
rupees and ranges from four lakhs to 13
lakhs per annum after you've become a
big data engineer some of the job roles
that you can look forward to are that of
a senior big data engineer a business
intelligence architect and a data
architect now let's talk about
certifications that a big data engineer
can opt for first off we have the
cloudera ccp data engineer a cloudera
certified professional data engineer
possesses the skills to develop reliable
and scalable data pipelines that result
in optimized data sets for a variety of
workloads it is one of the industry's
most demanding performance-based
certification ccp evaluates and
recognizes a candidate's mastery of the
technical skills most sought after by
employers the time limit for this exam
is 240 minutes and it costs 400
next we have the ibm certified data
architect big data certification an ibm
certified big data architect understands
the complexity of data and can design
systems and models to handle different
data variety including structured
semi-structured unstructured volume
velocity veracity and so on a big data
architect is also able to effectively
address information governance and
security challenges associated with the
system this exam is 75 minutes long and
finally we have the google cloud
certified data engineer a google
certified data engineer enables data
driven decision making by collecting
transforming and publishing data they
should also be able to leverage deploy
and continuously train pre-existing
machine learning models the length of
the certification exam is two hours and
its registration fee is 200 now let's
have a look at how simply learn can help
you become a big data engineer
simply learn provides the big data
architect masters program this includes
a number of different courses like big
data hadoop and spark developer apache
spark and scala mongodb developer and
administrator big data and hadoop
administrator and so much more this
course goes through 50 plus in demand
skills and tools 12 plus real life
projects and the possibility of an
annual average salary of 19 to 26 lakh
rupees per annum it will also help you
get noticed by the top hiring companies
this course will also go through some
major tools like kafka apache spark
flume edge base mongodb hive pig
mapreduce java scala and much more i
hope this helps we have now come to the
final part of our video ajay will take
you through 80 of the most important
interview questions that just might
appear in your big data interview we
will discuss on hadoop interview
questions and we will learn on different
aspects and be prepared for hadoop
interviews so that you can move into the
big data arena here we have some list of
questions and an explanation of those so
that you can be well prepared for your
hadoop interviews now let's look at some
general hadoop questions so what are the
different vendor specific distributions
of hadoop now all of you might be aware
that hadoop or apache hadoop is the core
distribution of hadoop and then you have
different vendors in the market which
have packaged the apache hadoop in a
cluster management solution which allows
everyone to easily deploy manage monitor
upgrade your clusters so here are some
vendor-specific distributions we have
cloudera which is the dominant one in
the market we have hortonworks and now
you might be aware that cloudera and
hortonworks have merged so it has become
a bigger entity you have mapr you have
microsoft azure ibm's infosphere and
amazon web services so these are some
popularly known vendor-specific
distributions if you would want to know
more about the hadoop distributions you
should basically look into google and
you should check for hadoop different
distributions wiki page so if i type
hadoop different distributions and then
i check for the wiki page that will take
me to the distributions and commercial
support page and this basically says
that the sold products that can be
called a release of apache hadoop come
from apache.org so that's your open
source community and then you have
various vendor-specific distributions
which basically are running in one or
the other way apache hadoop but they
have packaged it as a solution like an
installer so that you can easily set up
clusters on set of machines so have a
look at this page and read through about
different distributions of hadoop coming
back let's look at our next question
so what are the different hadoop
configuration files now whether you're
talking about apache hadoop cloudera
hortonworks map r or no matter which
other distribution these config files
are the most important
and existing in every distribution of
hadoop so you have hadoop environment
dot sh wherein you will have environment
variables such as your java path what
would be your process id path where will
your logs get stored what kind of
metrics will be collected and so on your
core hyphen site file has the hdfs path
now this has many other properties like
enabling trash or enabling high
availability or discussing or mentioning
about your zookeeper but this is one of
the most important file you have hdfs
hyphen site file now this file will have
other information related to your hadoop
cluster such as your replication factor
where will name node store its metadata
on disk if a data node is running where
would data node store its data if a
secondary name node is running where
would that store a copy of name node's
metadata and so on your map red hyphen
site file is a file which will have
properties related to
your mapreduce processing you also have
masters and slaves now these might be
deprecated in a vendor-specific
distribution and in fact you would have
a yarn hyphen site file which is based
on the yarn processing framework which
was introduced in hadoop version 2 and
this would have all your resource
allocation and resource manager and node
manager related properties
again if you would want to look at
default properties for any one of these
for example let's say hdfs hyphen site
file i could just go to google and type
in one of the properties for example i
would say
dfs.namenode.name.directory and as i
know this property belongs to hdfs
hyphen site file and if you search for
this it will take you to the first link
which says sdfs default xml you can
click on this and this will show you all
the properties which can be given in
your sdfs hyphen site file it also shows
you which version you are looking at and
you can always change the version here
so for example if i would want to look
at 2.6.5
i just need to change the version and
that should show me the properties
similarly you can just give a property
which belongs to say core hyphen site
file for example i would say fs dot
default fs and that's a property which
is in core hyphen site file and
somewhere here you would see core minus
default.xml and this will show you all
the properties so similarly you could
search for properties which are related
to yarn hyphen site file or map red
hyphen site file so i could say yarn dot
resource manager and i could look at one
of these properties which will directly
take me to yarn default xml and i can
see all the properties which can be
given in yarn and similarly you could
say map reduce dot job dot reduces and i
know this property belongs to mapreduce
hyphen site file and this takes you to
the default xml so these are important
config files and no matter which
distribution of hadoop you are working
on you should be knowing about these
config files whether you work as a
hadoop admin or you work as a hadoop
developer knowing these config
properties would be very important and
that would also showcase your internal
knowledge about the configs which drive
your hadoop cluster let's look at the
next question so what are the three
modes in which hadoop can run so you can
have hadoop running in a standalone mode
now that's your default mode it would
basically use a local file system in a
single java process so when you say
standalone mode it is as you downloading
hadoop related package on one single
machine but you would not have any
process running that would just be to
test hadoop functionalities you could
have a pseudo distributed mode which
basically means it's a single node
hadoop deployment now hadoop as a
framework has many many services so it
has a lot of services and those services
would be running irrespective of your
distribution and each service would then
have multiple processes so your
pseudo-distributed mode is a mode of
cluster where you would have all the
important processes belonging to one or
multiple services running on a single
node if you would want to work on a sudo
distributed mode and using a cloud error
you can always go to google and search
for cloudera's quick start vm you can
download it by just saying cloudera
quick start vm and you can search for
this and that will allow you to download
a quick start vm follow the instructions
and you can have a single node cloudera
cluster running on your virtual machines
for more information you can refer to
the youtube tutorial where i have
explained about how to set up a quick
start vm coming back you could have
finally a production setup or a fully
distributed mode which basically means
that your hadoop framework and its
components would be spread across
multiple machines so you would have
multiple services such as sdfs yarn
flume scope
kafka hbase hive impala and for these
services there would be one or multiple
processes distributed across multiple
nodes so this is normally what is used
in production environment so you could
say standalone would be good for testing
pseudo distributed could be good for
testing and development and fully
distributed would be mainly for your
production setup now what are the
differences between regular file system
and hdfs so when you say regular file
system you could be talking about a
linux file system or you could be
talking about a windows based operating
system so in regular file system we
would have data maintained in a single
system so the single system is where you
have all your files and directories so
it is having low fault tolerance right
so if the machine crashes your data
recovery would be very difficult unless
and until you have a backup of that data
that also affects your processing so if
the machine crashes or if the machine
fails then your processing would be
blocked now the biggest challenge with
regular file system is the seek time the
time taken to read the data so you might
have one single machine with huge amount
of disks and huge amount of ram but then
the time taken to read that data when
all the data is stored in one machine
would be very high and that would be
with least fault tolerance if you talk
about sdfs your data is distributed so
sdfs stands for hadoop distributed file
system so here your data is distributed
and maintained on multiple systems so it
is never one single machine it is also
supporting reliability so whatever is
stored in hdfs say a file being stored
depending on its size is split into
blocks and those blocks will be spread
across multiple nodes not only that
every block which is stored on a node
will have its replicas stored on other
nodes replication factor depends but
this makes sdfs more reliable in cases
of your slave nodes or data nodes
crashing you will rarely have data loss
because of auto replication feature now
time taken to read the data is
comparatively more as you might have
situations where your data is
distributed across the nodes and even if
you are doing a parallel read your data
read might take more time because it
needs coordination from multiple
machines however if you are working with
huge data which is getting stored it
will still be beneficial in comparison
to reading from a single machine so you
should always think about its
reliability through auto replication
feature its fault tolerance because of
your data getting stored across multiple
machines and its capability to scale so
when you talk about sdfs we are talking
about horizontal scalability or scaling
out when you talk about regular file
system you are talking about vertical
scalability which is scaling up
now let's look at some specific sdfs
questions what is this why is sdfs fault
tolerant now as i just explained in
previous slides your sdfs is fault
tolerant as it replicates data on
different data nodes so you have a
master node and you have multiple slave
nodes or data nodes where actually the
data is getting stored now we also have
a default block size of 128 mb that's
the minimum since hadoop version 2. so
any file which is up to 128 mb would be
using one logical block and if the file
size is bigger than 128 mb then it will
be split into blocks and those blocks
will be stored across multiple machines
now since these blocks are stored across
multiple machines it makes it more fault
tolerant because even if your machines
fail you would still have a copy of your
block existing on some other machine now
there are two aspects here one we talked
about the first rule of replication
which basically means you will never
have two identical blocks sitting on the
same machine and the second rule of
replication is in terms of rack
awareness so if your machines are placed
in racks as we see in the right image
you will never have all the replicas
placed on the same rack even if they are
on different machines so it has to be
fault tolerant and it has to maintain
redundancy so at least one replica will
be placed on some other node on some
other rack that's how sdfs is fault
tolerant now here let's understand the
architecture of sdfs now as i mentioned
earlier you would in a hadoop cluster
the main service is your hdfs
so for your sdfs service you would have
a name node which is your master process
running on one of the machines and you
would have data nodes which are your
slave machines getting stored across or
getting or the processes running across
multiple machines each one of these
processes has an important role to play
when you talk about sdfs whatever data
is written to hdfs
that data is split into blocks depending
on its size and the blocks are randomly
distributed across nodes with auto
replication feature these blocks are
also
auto replicated across multiple machines
with the first condition that no two
identical blocks will sit on the same
machine now as soon as the cluster comes
up your data nodes which are part of the
cluster and based on config files would
start sending their beat to the name
node and this would be every three
seconds what does name node do with that
name node will store this information in
its ram so name node starts building a
metadata in its ram and that metadata
has information of what are the data
nodes which are available in the
beginning now when a data
writing activity starts and the blocks
are distributed across data nodes data
nodes every 10 seconds will also send a
block report to name node so name node
is again adding up this information in
its ram or the metadata in ram which
earlier had only data node information
now name node will also have information
about what are the files the files are
split in which blocks the blocks are
stored on which machines and what are
the file permissions now while name node
is maintaining this metadata in ram name
node is also maintaining metadata in
disk now that is what we see in the red
box which basically has information of
whatever information was written to hdfs
so to summarize your name node has
metadata in ram and metadata in disk
your data nodes are the machines where
your blocks or data is actually getting
stored and then there is a auto
replication feature which is always
existing unless and until you have
disabled it and your read and write
activity is a parallel activity however
replication is a sequential activity now
this is what i mentioned about when you
talk about name node which is the master
process hosting metadata in disk and ram
so when we talk about disk it basically
has a edit log which is your transaction
log and your fs image which is your file
system image right from the time the
cluster was started this metadata and
disk was existing and this gets appended
every time read write or any other
operations happen on sdfs
metadata in ram is dynamically built
every time the cluster comes up which
basically means that if your cluster is
coming up name node in the initial few
seconds or few minutes would be in a
safe mode which basically means it is
busy registering the information from
data nodes so name node is one of the
most critical processes if name node is
down and if all other processes are
running you will not be able to access
the cluster name nodes metadata in disk
is very important for name node to come
up and maintain the cluster name nodes
metadata in ram is basically for all or
satisfying all your client requests now
when we look at data nodes as i
mentioned data nodes hold the actual
data blocks and they are sending these
block reports every 10 seconds so the
metadata in name notes ram is constantly
getting updated and metadata in disk is
also constantly getting updated based on
any kind of write activity happening on
the cluster now data node which is
storing the block will also help in any
kind of read activity whenever a client
requests so whenever a client on an
application or an api would want to read
the data
it would first talk to name node name
node would look into its metadata on ram
and confirm to the client which machines
could be reached to get to that data
that's where your client would try to
read the data from sdfs which is
actually getting the data from data
nodes and that's how your read write
requests are satisfied now what are the
two types of metadata in name node
server holds as i mentioned earlier
metadata in disk very important to
remember edit log nfs image metadata in
ram which is information about your data
nodes files files being split into
blocks blocks residing on data nodes and
file permissions so i will share a very
good link on this and you can always
look for more detailed information about
your metadata so you can search for sdfs
metadata directories explained now this
is from hortonworks however it talks
about the metadata in disk which name
node manages and details about this so
have a look at this link if you are more
interested in learning about metadata on
disk coming back let's look at the next
question what is the difference between
federation and high availability now
these are the features which were
introduced in hadoop version 2. both of
these features are about
horizontal scalability of name node so
prior to version 2 the only possibility
was that you could have one single
master which basically
means that your cluster could become
unavailable if name node would crash so
hadoop version 2 introduced two new
features federation and high
availability however high availability
is a popular one so when you talk about
federation it basically means any number
of name nodes so there is no limitation
to the number of name nodes your name
nodes are in a federated cluster which
basically means name nodes
still belong to the same cluster but
they are not coordinating with each
other so whenever a write request comes
in one of the name node picks up that
request and it guides that request for
the blocks to be written on data nodes
but for this your name node does not
have to coordinate with other name node
to find out if the block id which was
being assigned was the same one as
assigned by other name node so all of
them belong to a federated cluster they
are linked via a cluster id so whenever
an application or an api is trying to
talk to cluster it is always going via
an cluster id and one of the name node
would pick up the read activity or write
activity or processing activity so all
the name nodes are sharing a pool of
metadata in which each name node will
have its own dedicated pool and we can
remember that by a term called namespace
or name service so this also provides
high fault tolerance supposed your one
name node goes down it will not affect
or make your cluster unavailable you
will still have your cluster reachable
because there are other name nodes
running and they are available now when
it comes to heartbeats all your data
nodes are sending their beats to all the
name nodes and all the name nodes are
aware of all the data nodes when you
talk about high availability this is
where you would only have two name nodes
so you would have an active and you
would have a standby now normally in any
environment you would see a
high availability setup with zookeeper
so zookeeper is a centralized
coordination service so when you talk
about your active and standby name notes
election of in name node to be made as
active and taking care of an automatic
failover is done by your zookeeper high
availability can be set up without
zookeeper but that would mean that the
admins intervention would be required to
make a name node as active from standby
or also to take care of failover
now at any point of time in high
availability a active name node would be
taking care of storing the edits about
whatever updates are happening on sdfs
and it is also writing these edits to a
shared location standby name node is the
one which is constantly looking for
these latest updates and applying to its
metadata which is actually a copy of
whatever your active name node has so in
this way your standby name node is
always in sync with the active name node
and if for any reason active name node
fails your standby name node will take
over and become the active remember
zookeeper plays a very important role
here it's a centralized coordination
service one more thing to remember here
is that in your high availability
secondary name node will not be allowed
so you would have a active name node and
then you will have a standby name node
which will be configured on a separate
machine and both of these will be having
access to a shared location now that
shared location could be nfs or it could
be a quorum of general nodes so for more
information refer to the tutorial where
i have explained about sdfs high
availability and federation now let's
look at some logical question here so if
you have a input file of 350 mb which is
obviously bigger than 128 mb how many
input splits would be created by sdfs
and what would be the size of each input
split so for this you need to remember
that by default the minimum block size
is 128 mb now that's customizable if
your environment has more number of
larger files written on an average then
obviously you have to go for a bigger
block size if your environment has a lot
of files being written but these files
are of smaller size you could be okay
with 128 mb remember in hadoop every
entity that is your directory on sdfs
file on sdfs and a file having multiple
blocks each of these are considered as
objects and for each object hadoop's
name nodes ram 150 bytes is utilized so
if your block size is very small then
you would have more number of blocks
which would directly affect the name
nodes ram if you keep a block size very
high that will reduce the number of
blocks but remember that might affect in
processing because processing also
depends on splits more number of splits
more the parallel processing so
setting of block size has to be done
with consideration about your
parallelism requirement and your name
nodes ram which is available now coming
to the question if you have a file of
350 mb that would be split into three
blocks and here two blocks would have
128 mb data and the third block although
the block size would still be 128 it
would have only 94 mb of data so this
would be the split of this particular
file now let's
understand about rack awareness how does
rack awareness work or why do we even
have racks so organizations always would
want to place their nodes or machines in
a systematic way there can be different
approaches you could have a rack which
would have machines running on the
master processes and the intention would
be that this particular rack could have
higher bandwidth more cooling dedicated
power supply top of rack switch and so
on the second approach could be that you
could have one master process running on
one machine of every rack and then you
could have other slave processes running
now when you talk about your rack
awareness one thing to understand is
that if your machines are placed within
racks and we are aware that hadoop
follows auto replication the rule of
replication in a rack of air cluster
would be that you would never have all
the replicas placed on the same rack so
if we look at this if we have block a in
blue color you will never have all the
three blue boxes in the same rack even
if they are on different nodes because
that makes us that makes it less fault
tolerant so you would have at least one
copy of block which would be stored on a
different track on a different note now
let's look at this so basically here we
are talking about replicas being placed
in such a way now somebody could ask a
question can i have my block and its
replicas spread across three lakhs and
yes you can do that but then in order to
make it more redundant you are
increasing your bandwidth requirement so
the better approach would be two blocks
on the same rack on different machines
and one copy on a different track now
let's proceed how can you restart name
node and all demons in hadoop so if you
were working on an apache hadoop cluster
then you could be doing a start and stop
using hadoop demon scripts so there are
these hadoop demon scripts which would
be used to start and stop your hadoop
and this is when you talk about your
apache hadoop so let's look at one
particular file which i would like to
show you more information here and this
talks about your different clusters so
let's look into this and
so let's look at the start and stop and
here i have a file let's look at this
one
and this gives you highlights so if you
talk about apache hadoop this is how the
setup would be done so you would have it
download the adobe tar file you would
have to untie it edit the config files
you would have to do formatting and then
start your cluster and here i have said
using scripts so this is in case of
apache hadoop you could be using a start
all script that internally triggers
start dfs and start yarn and these
scripts start dfs internally would run
hadoop demon multiple times based on
your configs to start your different
processes then your start yarn would run
yarn demon script to start your
processing related processes so this is
how it happens in apache hadoop now in
case of cloudera or hortonworks which is
basically a vendor-specific distribution
you would have say multiple services
which would have one or multiple demons
running across the machines let's take
an example here that you would have
machine 1 machine 2 and machine 3 with
your processor spread across however in
case of cloud era and hortonworks these
are cluster management solutions so you
would never be involved in running a
script individually to start and stop
your processes in fact in case of
cloudera you would have a cloudera scm
server running on one of the machines
and then clouded scm agents running on
every machine if you talk about
hortonworks you would have ambari server
an ambari agent running so your agents
which are running on every machine are
responsible to monitor the processes
send also their heartbeat to the master
that is your server and your server is
the one or a service which basically
will give instructions to the agents so
in case of vendor vendor-specific
distribution your start and stop of
processes is automatically taken care by
these underlying services and these
services internally are still running
these commands however only in apache
hadoop you have to manually follow these
to start and stop coming back
we can look into
some command related questions so which
command will help you find the status of
blocks and file system health so you can
always go for a file system check
command now that can show you the files
for a particular sdfs path it can show
you the blocks and it can also give you
information on
status such as under replicated blocks
over replicated blocks misreplicated
blocks default replication and so on so
your fsck file system check utility does
not repair if there is any problem with
the blocks but it can give you
information of
blocks related to the files on which
machines they have stored if they are
replicated as per the replication factor
or if there is any problem with any
particular replica now what would happen
if you store too many small files in a
cluster and this relates to the block
information which i gave some time back
so remember hadoop is coded in java so
here every directory every file and file
created block is considered as an object
and for every object within your hadoop
cluster name nodes ram gets utilized so
more number of blocks you have more
would be usage of name nodes ram and if
you're storing too many small files it
would not affect your disk it would
directly affect your name nodes ram
that's why in production clusters admin
guys or infrastructure specialist will
take care that everyone who is writing
data to hdfs follows a quota system so
that you could be controlled in the
amount of data you write plus the count
of data and individual rights on hdfs
now how do you copy data from local
system onto sdfs so you can use a put
command or a copy from local and then
given your local path which is your
source and then your destination which
is your sdfs path remember you can
always do a copy from local using a
minus f option that's a flag option and
that also helps you in writing the same
file or a new file to hdfs so with your
minus f you have a chance of overwriting
or rewriting the data which is existing
on sdfs so copy from local or minus put
both of them do the same thing and you
can also pass an argument when you're
copying to control your replication or
other aspects of your file now when do
you use dfs admin refresh nodes or rm
admin refresh nodes so as the command
says this is basically to do with
refreshing the node information so your
refresh nodes is mainly used when say a
commissioning or decommissioning of
nodes is done so when a node is added
into the cluster or when a node is
removed from the cluster you are
actually informing hadoop master that
this particular node would not be used
for storage and would not be used for
processing now in that case you would be
once you are done with the process of
commissioning or decommissioning you
would be giving these commands that is
refreshed nodes and rm admin refresh
nodes so internally when you talk about
commissioning decommissioning there are
include and exclude files which are
updated and these include and exclude
files will have entry of machines which
are being added to the cluster or
machines which are being removed from
the cluster and while this is being done
the cluster is still running so you do
not have to restart your master process
however you can just use these refresh
commands to take care of your
commissioning decommissioning activities
now is there any way to change
replication of files on sdfs after they
are already written and the answer is of
course yes so if you would want to set a
replication factor at a cluster level
and if you have admin access then you
could edit your sdfs hyphen site file or
you could say hadoop hyphen site file
and that would take care of replication
factor being set at a cluster level
however if you would want to change the
replication after the data has been
written you could always use a setrep
command so setrep command is basically
to change the replication after the data
is written
you could also
write the data with a different
replication and for that you could use a
minus d dfs dot replication and give
your application factor when you are
writing data to the cluster so in hadoop
you can let your data be replicated as
per the property set in the config file
you could write the data with a
different replication
you could change the replication after
the data is read so all these options
are available now who takes care of
replication consistency in a hadoop
cluster and what do you mean by under
over replicated blocks now as i
mentioned your fsck command can give you
information of over or under replicated
blocks now in a cluster it is always an
always name node which takes care of
replication consistency so for example
if you have set up a replication of
three and since we know the first rule
of replication which basically means
that you cannot have two replicas
residing on the same node it would mean
that if your replication is three you
would need at least three data nodes
available now say for example you had a
cluster with three nodes and replication
was set to 3 at one point of time one of
your name node crashed and if that
happens your blocks would be
under-replicated
that means there was a replication
factor set but now your blocks are not
replicated or there are not enough
replicas as per the replication factor
set this is not a problem your master
process or name node will wait for some
time before it will start the
replication of data again so if a data
road is not responding or if a disk has
crashed and if name node does not get
information of a replica name node will
wait for some time and then it will
start re-replication of those missing
blocks from the available nodes however
while name node is doing it the blocks
are in under replicated situation now
when you talk about over replicated this
is a situation where name node realizes
that there are extra copies of block now
this might be the case that you had
three nodes running with a replication
of three one of the node went down due
to a network failure or some other issue
within few minutes name node
re-replicated the data and then the
failed node is back with its set of
blocks again name node is smart enough
to understand that this is a over
replication situation and it will delete
set of blocks from one of the nodes it
might be the node which has been
recently added it might be your old node
which has joined your cluster again or
any node that depends on the load on a
particular node now we discussed about
hadoop we discussed about sdfs now we
will discuss about mapreduce which is
the programming model and you can say
processing framework what is distributed
cache in mapreduce now we know that when
we talk about mapreduce the data which
has to be processed might be existing on
multiple nodes so when you would have
your mapreduce program running it would
basically read the data from the
underlying disks
now this could be a costly operation if
every time the data has to be read from
disk
so distributed cache is a mechanism
wherein
data set or data which is coming from
the disk can be cached
and available for all worker nodes now
how will this benefit so when a map
reduce is running instead of every time
reading the data from disk
it would pick up the data from
distributed cache and this this will
benefit your mapreduce processing so
distributed cache can be set in your
jobconf where you can specify that a
file should be picked up from
distributed cache
now let's understand about these roles
so what is a record reader what is a
combiner what is a partitioner and what
kind of roles do they play in a
mapreduce processing paradigm or
mapreduce operation so record reader
communicates with the input split and it
basically converts the data into key
value pairs and these key value pairs
are the ones which will be worked upon
by the mapper your combiner is an
optional face it's like mini radios so
combiner does not have its own class
it relies on the reducer class basically
your combiner would receive the data
from your map tasks which
would have completed works on it based
on whatever reducer class mentions and
then passes its output to the reducer
phase partitioner is basically a phase
which decides how many reduced tasks
would be used aggregate or summarize
your data so partitioner is a face which
would decide based on the number of keys
based on the number of
map tasks your partition would decide if
one or multiple reduced tasks would be
used to take care of processing so
either it could be partitioner which
decides on how many reduced tasks would
run or it could be based on the
properties which we have set within the
cluster which will take care of the
number of reduced tasks which would be
used always remember your partitioner
decides how outputs from combiner are
sent to reducer and to how many reducers
it controls the partitioning of keys of
your intermediate map outputs so map
phase whatever output it generates is an
intermediate output and that has to be
taken by your practitioner or by a
combiner and then partitioner to be sent
to one or multiple reduced tasks this is
one of the common questions which you
might face
why is mapreduce lower
in processing so we know mapreduce goes
for parallel processing we know we can
have multiple map tasks running on
multiple nodes at the same time we also
know that multiple reduced tasks could
be running now why does then mapreduce
become a slower approach
first of all your mapreduce is a batch
oriented operation now mapreduce is very
rigid and it strictly uses mapping and
reducing phases so no matter what kind
of processing you would want to do you
would have to still provide the mapper
function and the reducer function to
work on data not only this
whenever your map phase completes
the output of your map face which is an
intermittent output would be written to
hdfs and thereafter underlying disks and
this data would then be shuffled and
sorted and picked up for reducing phase
so every time your data being written to
hdfs and retrieved from sdfs makes
mapreduce a slower approach the question
is for a mapreduce job is it possible to
change the number of mappers to be
created
now
by default you cannot change the number
of map tasks because number of map tasks
depends on the input splits however
there are different ways in which you
can either set a property to have more
number of map tasks which can be used
or you can customize your code or
make it use a different format which can
then control the number of map tasks
by default number of map tasks
are equal to the number of splits of
file you are processing
so if you have a 1 gb of file that is
split into 8 blocks of 128 mb there
would be eight map tasks running on the
cluster these map tasks are basically
running your mapper function
if you have hard coded properties in
your map red hyphen site file to specify
more number of map tasks
then you could control the number of map
tasks
let's also talk about some data types so
when you prepare for hadoop when you
want to get into big data field you
should start learning about different
data formats
now there are different data formats
such as
avro parque
you have a sequence file or binary
format and these are different formats
which are used now when you talk about
your data types
in hadoop these are implementation of
your writable and writable comparable
interfaces so for every data type in
java you have a equivalent in hadoop so
end in java would be intriguable in
hadoop float would be float writable
long would be long writable double
writable boolean writable array writable
map writable and object writable so
these are your different data types that
could be used within your mapreduce
program and these are implementation of
writable and writable comparable
interfaces what is speculative execution
now imagine you have a cluster which has
huge number of nodes and your data is
spread across multiple slave machines or
multiple nodes now at a point of time
due to a disk degrade or network issues
or machine heating up or more load being
on a particular node there can be a
situation where your data node will
execute task in a slower manner now in
this case if speculative execution is
turned on there would be a shadow task
or a another
similar task running on some other node
for the same processing so whichever
task finishes first will be accepted and
the other task would be killed so
speculative execution could be good if
you are working in an intensive workload
kind of environment where if a
particular node is slower you could
benefit from a unoccupied
or a node which has less load to take
care of your processing going further
this is how we can understand so node a
which might be having a slower task you
would have a scheduler which is
maintaining or
having knowledge of what are the
resources available so if speculative
execution as a property is turned on
then the task which was running slow a
copy of that task or you can say shadow
task would run on some other node and
whichever task completes first will be
considered this is what happens in your
speculative execution now how is
identity mapper different from chain
mapper now this is where we are getting
deeper into mapreduce concepts so when
you talk about mapper identitymapper
is the default mapper which is chosen
when no mapper is specified in
mapreducedriver class so for every
mapreduce program
you would have a map class which is
taking care of your mapping phase which
basically has a mapper function and
which would run one or multiple map
tasks right your programming your
program would also have a reduce class
which would be running a reducer
function which takes care of reduced
tasks running on multiple nodes
now if a mapper is not specified within
your driver class so driver class is
something which has all information
about your flow what's your map class
what is your reduced class what's your
input format what's your output format
what are the job configurations and so
on so identity mapper is the default
mapper which is chosen when no mapper
class is mentioned in your driver class
it basically implements an identity
function which directly writes all its
key pairs into output and it was defined
in old mapreduce api in this particular
package but when you talk about chaining
mappers or chain mapper this is
basically a class to run multiple
mappers in a single map task or
basically you could say multiple map
tasks would run as a part of your
processing the output of first paper
would become as an input to second
mapper and so on and this can be defined
in the under mentioned class or package
what are the major configuration
parameters required in a mapreduce
program
obviously we need to have the input
location we need to have the output
location so input location is where the
files will be picked up from and this
would preferably on sdfs directory
output location is the path where your
job output would be written by your
mapreduce program you also need to
specify input and output formats if you
don't specify the defaults are
considered then we need to also have the
classes which have your map and reduce
functions and if you intend to run the
code on a cluster you need to package
your class in a jar file export it to
your cluster and then this jar file
would have your mapper reducer and
driver classes so these are important
configuration parameters
which you need to consider for a map
reduce program now what is the
difference or what do you mean by map
side join and reduce side join map side
join is basically when the join is
performed at the mapping level or at the
mapping phase or is performed by the
mapper so each input data which is being
worked upon has to be divided into same
number of partitions
input to each map is in the form of a
structured partition and is in sorted
order so map site join you can
understand it in a simpler way that if
you compare it with rdbms concepts where
you had two tables which were being
joined it will always be advisable to
give your bigger table as the left side
table or the first table for your join
condition and it would be your smaller
table on the left side and your bigger
table on the right side which basically
means the smaller table could be loaded
in memory and could be used for joining
so map side drawing is a similar kind of
mechanism where input data is divided
into same number of partitions when you
talk about reduced side join here the
join is performed by the reducer so it
is easier to implement than website join
as all the sorting and shuffling will
send the values
or send all the values having identical
keys to the same reducer so you don't
need to have your data set in a
structured form so look into your map
side join or reduce side join and other
joins just to understand how mapreduce
works however i would suggest not to
focus more on this because mapreduce is
still being used for processing but the
amount of map reduced base processing
has decreased overall or across the
industry now what is the role of output
committer class in a mapreduce job so
output committer as the name says
describes the commit of task output for
a mapreduce job so we could have this as
mentioned or apache hadoop mapreduce
output committer you could have a class
which extends your output committer
class
so mapreduce relies on this mapreduce
relies on the output committer of the
job to
set up the job initialization cleaning
up the job after the job completion that
means all the resources which were being
used by a particular job setting up the
task temporary output checking whether a
task needs a commit committing the task
output and discarding the task out so
this is a very important class and can
be used within your mapreduce job what
is the process of spilling in mapreduce
what does that mean
so spilling is basically a process of
copying the data from memory buffer to
disk when obviously the
buffer usage reaches a certain threshold
so if there is not enough memory in your
buffer in your memory then the content
which is stored in buffer or memory has
to be flushed out so by default a
background thread starts spilling the
content from memory to disk after eighty
percent of buffer size is filled now
when is the buffer being used so when
your mapreduce processing is happening
the data from data is being read from
the disk loaded into the buffer and then
some processing happens
same thing also happens when you are
writing data to the cluster
so you can imagine for a 100 megabyte
size buffer the spilling will start
after the content of buffer reaches 80
megabytes this is customizable how can
you set the mappers and reducers for a
mapreduce job so these are the
properties
so number of mappers and reducers as i
mentioned earlier can be customized so
by default your number of map tasks
depends on the split and number of
reduced tasks depends on the
partitioning phase which decides number
of reduced tasks which would be used
depending on the keys however we can set
these properties either in the config
files or provide them on the command
line or also make them part of our code
and this can control the number of map
tasks or reduce tasks which would be run
for a particular job let's look at one
more interesting question what happens
when a node running a map task fails
before sending the output to the reducer
so there was a node which was running a
map task and we know that there could be
one or multiple map tasks running on one
or multiple nodes and all the map tasks
have to be completed before the further
stages that such as combiner or reducer
come into existence so in a case if a
node crashes where a map task was
assigned to it the whole task will have
to be run again on some other note so in
hadoop version 2 yarn framework has a
temporary demon called application
master so your application master is
taking care of execution of your
application and if a particular task on
a particular node failed due to
unavailability of node it is the role of
application master to have this task
scheduled on some other node now can we
write the output of map reduce in
different formats of course we can so
hadoop supports various input and output
formats so you can write the output of
mapreduce in different formats so you
could have the default format that is
text output format wherein records are
written as line of text you could have
sequence file which is basically to
write sequence files or your binary
format files where your output files
need to be fed into another mapreduce
jobs you could go for a map file output
format to write output as map files you
could go for a sequence file as a binary
output format so that's again a variant
of your
sequence file input format it basically
writes keys and values to a sequence
file so when we talk about binary format
we are talking about a non-human
readable format db output format now
this is basically used when you would
want to write data to say relational
databases or say no sql databases such
as hbase so this format also sends the
reduce output to a sql table now let's
learn a little bit about yarn yarn which
stands for yet another resource
negotiator it's the processing framework
so what benefits did yan bring in hadoop
version 2 and how did it solve the
issues of mapreduce version 1. so
mapreduce version 1 had major issues
when it comes to scalability or
availability because sorry in hadoop
version 1 you had only one master
process for processing layer and that is
your job tracker so your job tracker was
listening to all the task trackers which
were running on multiple machines so
your job tracker was responsible for
resource tracking and job scheduling in
yarn you still have a processing master
but that's called resource manager
instead of job tracker and now with
hadoop version 2 you could even have
resource manager running in high
availability mode you have node managers
which would be running on multiple
machines and then you have a temporary
demon called application master so in
case of hadoop version 2 your resource
manager or master is only handling the
client connections and taking care of
tracking the resources the jobs
scheduling or basically taking care of
execution across multiple nodes is
controlled by application master till
the application completes
so in yarn you can have different kind
of resource allocations that could be
done and there is a concept of container
so container is basically a combination
of ram and cpu cores
yarn can run different kind of workloads
so it is not just mapreduce kind of
workload which can be run on adobe
person2 but you would have graph
processing massive parallel processing
you could have a real-time processing
and huge processing applications could
run on a cluster based on yarn so when
we talk about scalability
in case of your hadoop version 2 you can
have a cluster size of more than 10 000
nodes and can run more than 100 000
concurrent tasks and this is because for
every application which is launched you
have this temporary demon called
application master so if i would have 10
applications running i would have 10 app
masters running taking care of execution
of these applications across multiple
nodes compatibility so hadoop version 2
is fully compatible with whatever was
developed as per hadoop version 1 and
all your processing needs would be taken
care by yarn
so dynamic allocation of cluster
resources taking care of different
workloads
allocating resources across multiple
machines and using them for execution
all that is taken care by
tenancy which basically means you could
have
multiple users or multiple teams
you could have open source and
proprietary data access engines and all
of these could be basically hosted using
the same cluster now how does yarn
allocate resources to an application
with help of its architecture so
basically you have a client or an
application or an api which talks to
resource manager resource manager is as
i mentioned managing the resource
allocation in the cluster when you talk
about resource manager you have its
internal two components one is your
scheduler and one is your applications
manager so when we say resource manager
being the master is tracking the
resources the source manager is the one
which is negotiating the resources with
slave it is not actually resource
manager who is doing it but these
internal components
so you have a scheduler which allocates
resources to various running
applications so scheduler is not
bothered about tracking your resources
or basically tracking your applications
so we can have different kind of
schedulers such as fifo which is first
in first out you could have a fair
scheduler or you could have a capacity
scheduler and these schedulers basically
control how resources are allocated to
multiple applications when they are
running in parallel so there is a queue
mechanism so scheduler will schedule
resources based on requirements of
application but it is not monitoring or
tracking the status of applications
your applications manager is the one
which is accepting the job submissions
it is monitoring and restarting the
application masters so it's application
manager which is basically then
launching a application master which is
responsible for an application so this
is how it looks so whenever a job
submission happens we already know that
resource manager is
aware of the resources which are
available with every node manager so on
every node which has fixed amount of ram
and cpu cores
some portion of resources that is your
ram and cpu cores are allocated to node
manager now resource manager is already
aware of how much resources are
available across nodes so whenever a
client request comes in resource manager
will make a request to node manager it
will basically request node manager to
hold some resources for processing node
manager would basically approve or
disapprove this request of holding the
and these resources that is a
combination of ram and cpu cores are
nothing but containers we can allocate
containers of different sizes within
yarn hyphen site file so your node
manager based on a request from resource
manager guarantees the container which
would be available for processing that's
when your resource manager starts a
temporary demand called application
master to take care of your execution so
your app master which was launched by
resource manager or we can say
internally by applications manager will
run in one of the containers because
application master is also a piece of
code so it will run in one of the
containers and then other containers
will be utilized for execution this is
how yarn is basically taking care of
your allocation your application master
is managing resource needs it is the one
which is interacting with scheduler and
if
a particular
node crashes it is the responsibility of
app master to go back to the master
which is resource manager and negotiate
for more resources
so your app master will never ever
negotiate resources with node manager
directly it will always talk to resource
manager and the source manager is the
one which negotiates the resources
container as i said is a collection of
resources like your ram cpu network
bandwidth and your container is
allocated based on the availability of
resources on a particular node so which
of the following has occupied the place
of a job tracker
of mapreduce so it is your resource
manager so resource manager is the name
of the master process in adobe portion
2. now if you would have to
write yarn commands to check the status
of an application so we could just say
yarn application minus status and then
the application id and you could kill it
also from the command line remember your
yarn has a ui and you can even look at
your applications from the ui you can
even kill your applications from the ui
however knowing the command line
commands would be very useful can we
have more than one resource manager in a
young base cluster yes we can that is
what hadoop version 2 allows us to have
so you can have a high availability yarn
cluster where you have a active and
standby and the coordination is taking
care by your zookeeper at a particular
time there can only be one active
resource manager and if active resource
manager fails your standby resource
manager comes and becomes active however
zookeeper is playing a very important
role remember zookeeper is the one which
is coordinating the server state and it
is doing the election of active to
standby failover what are the different
schedulers available in yarn so you have
a fifo scheduler that is
first in first out and this is not a
desirable option because in this case a
longer running application might block
all other small running applications
your capacity scheduler is basically a
scheduler where dedicated queues are
created and they have fixed amount of
resources so you can have multiple
applications accessing the cluster at
the same time and they would be using
their own cues
and the resources allocated to them if
you talk about fair scheduler you don't
need to have a fixed amount of
resources you can just have a percentage
and you could decide what kind of
fairness is to be followed which
basically means that if you were
allocated 20 gigabytes of memory however
the cluster has 100 gigabytes and the
other team was assigned 80 gigabytes of
memory then you have 20 access to the
cluster another team has 80 however if
the other team does not come up or does
not use the cluster in a fair scheduler
you can go up to maximum 100
of your cluster to find out more
information about your schedulers you
could either look in hadoop definitive
guide or what you could do is you could
just go to google and you could type for
example yarn
scheduler let's search for yarn
scheduler and then you can look in
hadoop definitive guide
and so this is your hadoop definitive
guide and it beautifully explains about
your different schedulers how do
multiple applications run and that could
be in your
fifo kind of scheduling it could be in
capacity scheduler or it could be in a
fair scheduling so have a look at this
link it's a very good link you can also
search for yarn untangling and this is a
blog of four or this is a series of four
blocks where it's beautifully explained
about your yarn how it works how the
resource allocation happens what is a
container and what runs within the
container so you can scroll down you can
be reading through this and you can then
also search for part two of it which
talks about the location and so on so
coming back
we basically have these schedulers what
happens if a resource manager fails
while executing an application in a high
availability cluster so in a high
availability cluster we know that we
will have two resource managers one
being active one being standby and
zookeeper which is keeping a track of
the server states so if a rm fails in
case of high availability the standby
will be elected as active and then
basically your resource manager or the
standby would become the active one and
this one would instruct the application
master to abort in the beginning then
your resource manager recovers its
running state so there is something
called as rm state store where all the
applications which are running their
status is stored so resource manager
recovers
its running state by looking at your
state store
by taking advantage of container
statuses and then continues to take care
of your processing now in a cluster of
10 data nodes each having 16 gb and 10
cores what would be total processing
capacity of the cluster take a minute to
think 10 data nodes 16 gb ram per node
10 cores
so if you mention the answer as 160 gb
ram
and 100 cores
then
you went wrong now think of a cluster
which has 10 data nodes each having 16
gb ram and 10 cores remember on every
node in a hadoop cluster you would have
one or multiple processors running those
processes would need ram the machine
itself which has a linux file system
would have its own processes so that
would also be having some ram usage
which basically means that if you talk
about 10 data nodes you should deduct at
least 20 to 30 percent towards the
overheads towards the cloud database
services towards the other processes
which are running and in that case i
could say that you could have 11 or 12
gb available on every machine for
processing and say 6 or 7 cores multiply
that by 10 and that's your processing
capacity remember the same thing applies
to the disk usage also so if somebody
asks you in a 10 data node cluster where
each machine has 20 terabytes of disks
what is my total storage capacity
available for sdfs so the answer would
not be 200 you have to consider the
overheads and this is basically which
gives you your processing capacity now
let's look at one more question so what
happens if requested memory or cpu cores
beyond or goes beyond the size of
container now as i said you can have
your configurations which can say that
in a particular data node which has 100
gb ram i could allocate say 50 gb
for the processing like out of 100 cores
i could say 50 cores for processing so
if you have 100 gb ram and 100 cores you
could ideally allocate 100 for
processing but that's not ideally
possible so if you have 100 gb ram you
would go for 50 gb and if you have 100
cores you would go for 50 cores now
within this ram and cpu course you have
the concept of containers right so
container is a combination of ram and
cpu cores so you could have a minimum
size container and maximum size
container now at any point of time if
your application starts demanding
more memory or more cpu cores
and this cannot fit into a container
location your application will fail
your application will fail because you
requested for a memory or a combination
of memory and cpu cores which is
more than the maximum container size so
look into this yarn tangling website
which i mentioned and look for the
second blog in those series which
explains about these allocations now
here we will discuss on hive peg hbase
and these components of hadoop which are
being used in the industry for various
use cases let's look at some questions
here and let's look how you should
prepare for them so first of all we will
learn on hive which is a data
warehousing package so the question is
what are the different components of a
hive architecture now when we talk about
hive we already know that hive is a data
warehousing package which basically
allows you to work on structured data or
data which can be structuralized so
normally people are well versed with
querying or basically processing the
data using sql queries a lot of people
come from database backgrounds and they
would find it comfortable if they know
structured query language hive is one of
the data warehousing package which
resides within a hadoop ecosystem it
uses hadoop's distributed file system to
store the data and it uses rdbms usually
to store the metadata although metadata
can be stored locally also so what are
the different components of an hive
architecture so it has a user interface
so user interface calls the execute
interface to the driver this creates a
session to the query and then it sends
the query to the compiler to generate an
execution plan for it usually whenever
hive is set up it would have its
metadata stored in an rdbms now to
establish the connection between rdbms
and hadoop we need odbc or jdbc
connector jar file and that connector
jar file has a driver class now this
driver class is mandatory to create a
connection between hive and hadoop so
user interface creates this interface
using the driver now we have metastore
metastore stores the metadata
information so any object which you
create such as database table indexes
their metadata is stored in metastore
and usually this metastore is stored in
an rdbms so that multiple users can
connect to hive so your metastore stores
the metadata information
and sends that to the compiler for
execution of a query what does the
compiler do it generates the execution
plan it has a dag now dag stands for
direct acyclic graph so it has a dag of
stages where each stage is either a
metadata operation a map or reduced job
or an operation on sdfs and finally we
have execution engine that acts as a
bridge between hive and hadoop to
process the query so execution engine
communicates bi-directionally with
metastore to perform operations like
create or drop tables so these are four
important components of hive
architecture now what is the difference
between external table and manage table
and height
so we have various kinds of table in
height such as external table manage
table partition table the major
difference between your managed and
external table is in respect to what
happens to the data if the table is
dropped usually whenever we create a
table in hive it creates a manage table
or we could also call that as an
internal table now this manages the data
and moves it into warehouse directory by
default whether you create a manage
table or external table usually the data
can recite in hive's default warehouse
directory or it could be residing in a
location chosen however when we talk
about manage table if one drops a manage
table not only the metadata information
is deleted but the table's data is also
deleted from his dfs if we talk about
external table it is created with an
external keyword explicitly and if an
external table is dropped nothing
happens to the data which resides in
sdfs so that's the main difference
between your managed and external table
what might be the use case if somebody
asks you there might be a migration kind
of activity or you are interested in
creating a lot of tables using your
queries so in that case you could dump
all the data on sdfs and then you could
create a table by pointing to a
particular directory or multiple
directories now you could then do some
testing of your tables and would decide
that you might not need all the tables
so in that case it would be advisable to
create external tables so that even if
the table is later dropped the data on
sdfs will be intact unlike your manage
table where dropping of table will
delete the data from sdfs also let's
learn a little bit on partition so what
is partition and hive and why is
partitioning required in hive if
somebody asks you that now normally in
world of rdbms partition is the process
to group similar type of data together
and that is usually done on basis of a
column or what we call as partitioning
key now each table usually has one
column in context of rdbms which could
be used to partition the data and why do
we do that so that we can avoid scanning
the complete table for a query and
restrict the scan to
set of data or to a particular partition
in hive we can have any number of
partition keys so partitioning provides
granularity in hive table it reduces the
query latency by scanning only relevant
partition data instead of whole data set
we can partition at various levels now
if i compare rdbms with hive in case of
rdbms you could have
one column which could be used for
partitioning and then you could be
squaring the specific partition so in
case of rdbms your partition column is
usually a part of the table definition
so for example if i have an employee
table i might have employee id employee
name employee age and employee salary as
four columns and i would decide to
partition the table based on salary
column now why would i partition it
because i feel that employee table is
growing very fast it is or it will have
huge amount of data and later when we
query the table we don't want to scan
the complete table so i could split my
data into multiple partition based on a
salary column giving some ranges in hive
it is a little different
in hive you can do partitioning and
there is a concept of static and dynamic
partitioning but in hive the partition
column is not part of table definition
so you might have an employee table with
employee id
name age
and that that's it that would be the
table definition but you could then have
partitioning done based on salary column
which will then create a specific folder
on sdfs in that case when we query the
data we can see the partition column
also showing up so we can partition the
transaction data for a bank for example
based on month like chan feb etc and any
operation regarding a particular month
will then allow us to query that
particular folder that is where
partitioning is useful now why does hive
not store metadata information in sdfs
if somebody asks you so we know that
hives data is stored in sdfs which is
hadoop distributed file system however
the metadata is either stored locally
and that mode of hive would be called as
embedded mode or you could have hives
metadata stored in rdbms so that
multiple clients can initiate a
connection now this metadata which is
very important for hive would not be
stored in sdfs so we already know that
sdfs read and write operations are time
consuming it is a distributed file
system and it can accommodate huge
amount of data so hive stores metadata
information in metastore using rdbms
instead of sdfs so this allows to
achieve low latency and faster data
access
now if somebody asks what are the
components used in hive query processor
so usually we have the main components
are your parser your execution engine
logical plan generation optimizer and
type checking so whenever a query is
submitted it will go through a parser
and parser would check the syntax it
would check for objects which are being
queried and other things to see if the
query is fine now internally you have a
semantic analyzer which will also look
at the query you have an execution
engine which basically will work on the
execution part that is the best
generated execution plan which could be
used to get the results for the query
you could also have user defined
functions which a user would want to use
and these are normally created in
java or java programming language and
then basically these user defined
functions are added to the class path
now you would have a logical plan
generation which basically looks at your
query and then generates a logical plan
or the best execution path which would
be required to get to the results
internally there is a physical plan
generated which is then looked in by
optimizer to get the best path to get to
the data and that might also be checking
your different operators which you are
using within your query finally we would
also have type checking so these are
important components in hype so somebody
might ask you if you are querying your
data using hive what are the different
components involved or if you could
explain what are the different
components which
work when a query is submitted so these
are the components now let's look a
scenario based question suppose there
are a lot of small csv files which are
present in a sdfs directory and you want
to create a single hive table from these
files so data in these files have fields
like registration number name email
address
so if this is what needs to be done what
will be your approach to solve it where
will you create a single hive table for
lots of small files without degrading
the performance of the system so there
can be different approaches now we know
that there are a lot of small csv files
which are present in a directory so we
know that when we create a table in hive
we can use a location parameter so i
could say create table give a table name
give the column and their data types i
could specify the delimiters and finally
i could say location and then point it
to a directory on svfs and this
directory might be the directory which
has a lot of csv files so in this case i
will avoid loading the data in the table
because table being point table pointing
to the directory will directly pick up
the data from one or multiple files and
we also know that hive does schema check
on read so it does not do a schema check
on write so in case there were one or
two files
which did not follow the schema of the
table it would not prevent data loading
data would anyways be loaded only when
you query the data it might show you
null values if data which was loaded
does not follow the schema of the table
this is one approach what is the other
approach so let's look at that you can
think about sequence file format which
is basically a smart format or a binary
format and you can group these small
files together to form a sequence file
now this could be one other smarter
approach so we could create a temporary
table so we could say create table give
a table name give the column names and
their data types we could specify the
delimiters as it shows here that is row
format and fields terminated by and
finally we can store that as text file
then we can load data into this table by
giving a local file system path and then
we can create a table that will store
data in sequence file format so my point
one is storing the data instance text
file point three would be storing the
data in sequence file format so we say
create table give the specifications we
say row format delimited fields are
terminated by comma stored as sequence
file then we can move the data from test
table into test sequence file table so i
could just say insert overwrite my new
table as select star from other table
remember in hive you cannot do insert
update delete however if the table is
existing you can do a insert overwrite
from an existing table into a new table
so this could be one approach where we
could have a lot of csv files or smaller
files club together as one big sequence
file and then store it in the table now
if somebody asks you write a query to
insert a new column that is
integer data type into a hive table and
the requirement might be that you would
want to insert this table at a position
before an existing column now that's
possible by doing an alter table giving
your table name and then specifying
change column giving you a new column
with the data type before an existing
column this is a simple way wherein you
can insert a new column into a hive
table what are the key differences
between hive and pig
now some of you might have heard hive is
a data warehousing package and pig is
more of a scripting language both of
them are used for data analysis
or trend detection hypothesis testing
data transformation and many other use
cases so if we compare hive and pig hive
uses a declarative language called hive
ql that is hive querying language
similar to sql and it is for reporting
or for data analysis even for data
transformation or for your data
extraction pig uses a high level
procedural language called pig latin for
programming both of them remember use
mapreduce processing framework so when
we run a query in hive to process the
data or when we create and submit a pic
script both of them trigger a mapreduce
job unless and until we have set them to
local mode hive operates on the server
side of the cluster and basically works
on structured data or data which can be
structuralized pig usually works or
operates on the client side of the
cluster and allows both structured
unstructured or even i could say
semi-structured data hive does not
support avro file format by default
however that can be done by using the
right serializer d serializer so we can
have hive table related data stored in
avro format in sequence file format in
part k format or even as a text file
format however when we are working on
smarter formats like avro or sequence
file or par k we might have to use
specific serializers d serializers for
avro this is the package which allows us
to use avro format pig supports avro
format by default hive was developed by
facebook and it supports partitioning
and pig was developed by yahoo and it
does not support partitioning so these
are high level differences there are
lots and lots of differences remember
hive is more of a data housing package
and pig is more of a scripting language
or a
strictly procedural flow following
scripting language which allows us to
process the data now let's get more and
let's get more deeper and learn about
pig which is as i mentioned a scripting
language which can be used for your data
processing it also uses mapreduce
although we can even have big run in a
local mode let's learn about pig in the
next section now let's learn on some
questions about pig which is a scripting
language and it is extensively used for
data processing and data analysis so the
question is how is apache pig different
from mapreduce now we all know that
mapreduce is a programming model it is
it's quite rigid when it comes to
processing the data because you have to
do the mapping and reducing you have to
write huge code usually mapreduce is
written in java but now it can also be
written in python it can be written in
scala and other programming languages so
if we compare pig with mapreduce pig
obviously is very concise it has less
lines of code when compared to mapreduce
now we also know that pig script
internally will trigger a mapreduce job
however user need not know about
mapreduce programming model they can
simply write simple scripts in pig and
that will automatically be converted
into mapreduce however mapreduce has
more lines of code peak is
high level language which can easily
perform join operations or other data
processing operations mapreduce is a low
level language which can not perform job
join operations easily so we can do join
using mapreduce however it's not really
easy in comparison to pick now as i said
on execution every pig operator is
converted internally into a mapreduce
job so every pick script which is run
which would be converted into mapreduce
job now mapreduce overall is a batch
oriented processing so it takes more
time to compile it takes more time to
execute either when you run a mapreduce
job or when it is triggered by pink
script pig works with all versions of
hadoop and when we talk about mapreduce
program which is written in one hadoop
version may not work with other versions
it might work or it might not it depends
on what are the dependencies what is the
compiler you are using what programming
language you have used and what version
of hadoop you are working on so these
are the main differences between apache
pig and mapreduce what are the different
ways of executing pig script so you
could create a script file store it in
dot pic or dot text and then you could
execute it using the pic command you
could be bringing up the grunt shell
that is pig's shell now that usually
starts with mapreduce mode but then we
can also bring it up in a local mode and
we can also run pig embedded as an
embedded script in other programming
language so these are the different ways
of executing your big script now what
are the major components of pig
execution environment this is this is a
very common question interviewers would
always want to know different components
of hive different components of pig even
different components which are involved
in hadoop ecosystem so when we want to
learn about major components of big
execution environment here are some so
you have pig scripts now that is written
in pig latin using built-in operators
and user-defined functions and submitted
to the execution environment that's what
happens when you would want to process
the data using pic now there is a parser
which does type checking and checks the
syntax of the script the output of
parser is a tag direct cyclic graph so
block and wikipedia for dag so dag is
basically a sequence of steps which run
in one direction then you have an
optimizer now this optimizer performs
optimization using merge transform split
etc it aims to reduce the amount of data
in the pipeline that's the whole purpose
of optimizer you have a internal
compiler so pick compiler converts the
optimized code into a mapreduce job and
here user need not know the mapreduce
programming model or how it works or how
it is written they all need to know
about running the pick script which
would be internally converted into a
mapreduce job and finally we have an
execution engine so mapreduce jobs are
submitted to the execution engine to
generate the desired results so these
are major components of pig execution
environment now let's learn about
different complex data types in pig
supports various data types
the main ones are tuple bag and map what
is tuple or tuple as you might have
heard a tuple is an ordered set of
fields which can contain different data
types for each field so in array you
would have multiple elements but that
would be of same types list can also
have different types your tuple is a
collection which has different fields
and each field can be of different type
now we could have an example as one
comma three or one comma three comma a
string or a float element and all of
that form a tuple bag is a set of tuples
so that's represented by curly braces so
you could also imagine this like a
dictionary which has various different
collection elements what is a map map is
a set of key value pairs used to
represent data so when you work in big
data field you need to know about
different data types which are supported
by pig which are supported by hive which
are supported in other components of
hadoop so tuple bag map array array
buffer you can think about list you can
think about dictionaries you can think
about map which is key value pair so
these are your different complex data
types other than the primitive data
types such as integer character string
boolean float and so on now what are the
various diagnostic operators available
in apache pic so these are some of the
operators or options which you can give
in a big script you can do it dumb now
dumb operator runs the pig latin scripts
and displays the result on the screen so
either i could do it dumb and see the
output on the screen or i can even do a
dump into and i could store my output in
a particular file so we can load the
data using load operator in pig and then
pig also has different internal storage
like json loader or big storage which
can be used if you are working on
specific kind of data and then you could
do a dump either before processing or
after processing and dump would produce
the result the result could be stored in
a file or
seen on the screen you also have a
describe operator now that is used to
view the schema of a relation so you can
load the data and then you can view the
schema of relation using describe
operator explain as we might already
know displays the physical logical and
mapreduce execution plans normally in
rdbms when we use x-plane we would like
to see what happens behind the scenes
when a particular script or a query runs
so we could load the data using load
operator as in any other case and if we
would want to display the logical
physical and mapreduce execution plans
we could use explain operator there is
also an illustrate operator now that
gives the step-by-step execution of
sequence of statements so sometimes when
we would want to analyze
our script to see how good or bad they
are or would that really serve our
purpose we could use illustrate and
again you can test that by loading the
data using load operator and you could
just use a illustrate operator to have a
look at the step-by-step execution of
the sequence of statements which you
would want to execute so these are
different diagnostic operators available
in apache pic now if somebody asks state
the usage of group order by and distinct
keywords in big script so as i said pig
is a scripting language so you could use
various operators so group basically
collects various records with the same
key and groups the data in one or more
relations here is an example you could
do a group data so that is basically a
variable or you can give some other name
and you can say group relation name by h
now say i have a file where i have field
various fields and one of the field is a
relation name so i could group that by a
different field order by is used to
display the contents of relation in a
sorted order whether ascending or
descending so i could create a variable
called relation 2 and then i could say
order relation name 1 by ascending or
descending order distinct basically
removes the duplicate records and it is
implemented only on entire records not
on individual records so if you would
want to find out the distinct values and
relation name field i could use distinct
what are the relational operators in pig
so you have various relational operators
which help data scientists or data
analysts or developers who are analyzing
the data such as co-group which joins
two or more tables and then performs
group operation on the join table result
you have cross it is used to compute the
cross product that is a cartesian
product of two or more relations
for each is basically to do some
iteration so if it will iterate through
tuples of a relation generating a data
transformation so for example if i say
variable a equals and then i load a file
in a and then i could create a variable
called b where i could say for each a i
would want to do something say group
join is to join two or more tables in a
relation limit is to limit the number of
output tuples or output results split is
to split the relation into two or more
relations union is to get a combination
that's it will merge the contents of two
or more relations and order is to get a
sorted result so these are some
relational operators which are
extensively used in pig for analysis
what is the use of having filters in
apache pick now say for example i have
some data which has three fields year
product quantity and this is my phone
sales data so filter operator could be
used to select the required values from
a relation based on a condition it also
allows you to remove unwanted records
from data file so for example filter the
products where quantity is greater than
thousand so i see that i have
one row wherein are multiple rows where
the quantity is greater than thousand
such as 1500 1700 1200 so i could create
a variable called a i would load my file
using pix storage as i explained earlier
big storage is an internal parameter
which can be used to
specify the delimiters now here my
delimiter is comma so i could say using
pix storage as and then i could specify
the data type for each field so here
being integer product being character
array and quantity being integer then b
i could say filter a whatever we have in
a by quantity greater than thousand so
it's very concise it's very simple and
it allows us to extract and process data
in a simpler way now suppose there is a
file called test.txt
having 150 records in hdfs so this is a
file which is stored on his dfs and it
has 150 records where we can consider
every record being one line and if
somebody asks you to write a big command
to retrieve the first 10 records of the
file first we will have to load the data
so i could create a variable called test
underscore data and i would say load my
file using big storage specifying the
delimiter as comma as and then i could
specify my fields whatever fields our
file have and then i would want to get
only 10 records for which i could use
the limit operator so i could say limit
on test data and give me 10 records this
is very simple and we can extract 10
records from 150 records which are
stored in the file on sdfs now we have
learnt on pig we have learned some
questions on hive you could always
look more in books like programming in
hive or programming in pig and look for
some more examples and try out these
examples on a existing hadoop setup now
let's learn on hbase which is a nosql
database now edge base is a four
dimensional database in comparison to
your rdbms which usually are
two-dimensional so rdbms have rows and
columns but hbase has four coordinates
it has row key which is always unique
column family which can be any number
column qualifiers which can again be any
number per column family and then you
have a version so these four coordinates
make edge base a four dimensional key
value store or a column family store
which is unique for storing huge amount
of data and extracting data from hbase
there is a very good link which i would
suggest everyone can look at if you
would want to learn more on hbase and
you could just say hbase mapper and this
basically brings up a documentation
which is from mapr but then that's not
specific to mapper and you can look at
this link which will give you a detailed
explanation of hbase how it works what
are the architectural components and how
data is stored and how it makes hbase a
very powerful nosql database so let's
learn on some of the important or
critical questions on hbase which might
be asked by the interviewer in an
interview when you are applying for a
big data admin or a developer position
role so what are the key components of
edge base now as i said this is one of
the favorite questions of interviewers
where they would want to understand your
knowledge on different components for a
particular service hbase as i said is a
nosql database and that comes as a part
of service with cloudera or hortonworks
and with apache hadoop you could also
set up edgebase as an independent
package so what are the key components
of hbase hbase has a region server now
hbase follows the similar kind of
topology like hadoop now hadoop has a
master process that is name node and
slave processes such as data nodes and
secondary name node in the same way
hbase also has a master which is h
master and the slave processes are
called region servers so these region
servers are usually co-located with data
nodes however it is not mandatory that
if you have 100 data nodes you would
have 100 region servers so it purely
depends on admin so what does this
region server contain so region server
contains hbase tables that are divided
horizontally into regions or you could
say group of rows is called regions so
in edge base you have two aspects one is
group of columns which is called column
family and one is group of rows which is
called regions now these regions or
these rows are grouped based on the key
values or i would say row keys which are
always unique when you store your data
in each base
you would have data in the form of rows
and columns so group of rows are called
regions or you could say these are
horizontal partitions of the table so a
region server manages these regions on
the node where a data node is running a
region server can have up to thousand
regions it runs on every node and
decides the size of region so region
server as i said is a slave process
which is responsible for managing hbase
data on the node each region server is a
worker node or a worker process
co-located with data node which will
take care of your read write update
delete request from the clients now when
we talk about more components of hbase
as i said you have h master so you would
always have a connection coming in from
a client or an application what does
hmaster do it assigns regions it
monitors the region servers it assigns
regions to region servers for load
balancing and it cannot do that without
the help of zookeeper so if we talk
about components of hbase there are
three main components you have zookeeper
you have h master and you have region
server region server being the slave
process your edge master being the
master process which takes care of all
your table operations assigning regions
to the region servers taking care of
read and write requests which come from
client and for all of this edge master
will take in help of zookeeper which is
a centralized coordination service so
whenever a client wants to read or write
or change the schema or any other
metadata operations it will contact
hmaster edgemaster internally will
contact zookeeper so you could have
hbase setup also in high availability
mode where you could have a active edge
master than a backup edge master you
would have a zookeeper quorum which is
the way zookeeper works so zookeeper is
a centralized coordination service which
will always run with a quorum of
processes so zookeeper would always run
with odd number of processes such as 3 5
and 7 because zookeeper works on the
concept of majority consensus now
zookeeper which is a centralized
coordination service is keeping a track
of all the servers which are alive
available and also keeps a track of
their status
for every server with zookeeper is
monitoring zookeeper keeps a session
alive with that particular server edge
master would always check with zookeeper
which region servers are available alive
so that regions can be assigned to the
region server at one end you have region
server which are sending their status to
the zookeeper indicating if they are
ready for any kind of read or write
operation and at other end edge master
is querying the zookeeper to check the
status now zookeeper internally manages
a meta table now that meta table will
have information of which regions are
residing on which region server and what
rookies those regions contain so in case
of a read activity hmaster will query
zookeeper to find out the region server
which contains that meta table once
hmaster gets the information of meta
table it can look into the meta table to
find out the row keys and the
corresponding region servers which
contain the regions for those row keys
now if we would want to understand
rookie and column families in each base
let's look at this and it would be good
if we could look this on an excel sheet
so row key is always unique it acts as a
primary key for any hbase table it
allows logical grouping of cells and
make sure that all cells with the same
row key are co-located on the same
server so as i said you have four
coordinates for hbase you have a row key
which is always unique you have column
families which is nothing but group of
columns and when i say column families
one column family can have any number of
columns so when i talk about h base h
base is four dimensional and in terms of
hbase it is also called as a column
oriented database which basically means
that every row in one column could have
a different data type now you have a row
key which uniquely identifies the row
you have column families which could be
one or many depending on how the table
has been defined and a column family can
have any number of columns or i could
say for every row within a column family
you could have different number of
columns so i could say for my row one i
could just have two columns such as name
and city within the column family for my
row two i could have name city age
designation salary for my third row i
could have thousand columns and all that
could belong to one column family so
this is a horizontally scalable database
so column family consists of group of
columns which is defined during table
creation and each column family can have
any number of column qualifiers
separated by a delimiter now a
combination of row key column family
column qualifier such as name city h and
the value within the cell is makes the
hbase a unique four dimensional database
for more information if you would want
to learn on hbase please refer this link
which is hbase mapper and this gives a
complete hbs architecture that has three
components of name node
three component that is name node region
servers and zookeeper how it works how
each edge master interacts with
zookeeper what zookeeper does in
coordination how are the components
working together and how does hbs take
care of read and write coming back and
continuing why do we need to disable a
table so there are different table
operations what you can do in hbase and
one of them is disabling a table now if
you would want to check the status of
table you could all check that by is
disabled and giving the table name or is
enabled and the table name so the
question is why do we need to disable a
table now if we would want to modify a
table or we are doing some kind of
maintenance activity in that case we can
disable the table so that we can modify
your changes settings when a table is
disabled it cannot be accessed through
the scan command now if we have to write
a code to open a connection in each base
now to interact with hbs one could
either use a graphical user interface
such as hue or you could be using the
command line hb shell or you could be
using hbase admin api if you are working
with java or say happy base if you are
working with python where you may want
to open a connection with hbase so that
you can work with it based
programmatically in that case we have to
create a configuration object that is
configuration my conf and then create a
configuration object and then you can
use different classes like etch table
interface to work on a new table you
could use h column qualifier and many
other classes which are available in
hbase admin api what does replication
mean in terms of hbase so edge base as i
said works in a cluster way and when you
talk about cluster you could always set
up a replication from one hbase cluster
to another hbase cluster so this
replication feature in each base
provides a mechanism to copy data
between clusters or sync the data
between different clusters this feature
can be used as a disaster recovery
solution that provides high availability
for hbase so if i have a hbase cluster
one where i have one master than
multiple region servers running in a
hadoop cluster i could use the same
hadoop cluster to create a hbase replica
cluster or i could have a totally
different hbase replica cluster where my
intention is that if things are changing
in a particular table in cluster 1 i
would want them to be replicated across
different cluster so i could alter the
edge base table and set the replication
scope to 1. now a replication scope of 0
indicates that table is not replicated
but if we set the replication to 1 we
basically will have to set up ah base
cluster where we can replicate hbase
tables data from cluster one to cluster
so these are the commands which can be
used to enable replication and then
replicate the data of table across
clusters can we import and export in
hbase of course we can it is possible to
import and export tables from one hbase
cluster to other hbase cluster or even
within a cluster so we can use the hbase
export utility which comes in this
particular package give a table name and
then a target location so that will
export the data of hbase table into a
directory on sdfs then i could create a
different table which would follow some
kind of same definition as the table
which was exported and then i could use
import to import the data from the
directory on sdfs to my table if you
would want to learn more on hbase import
and export you could look at hbase
import operations let's search for the
link and this is the link where you
could learn more about hbase import
export utilities how you could do a bulk
import bulk export which internally uses
mapreduce and then you could do a import
and export into hbase tables moving
further what do we mean by compaction in
hbase now we all know that hbase is a
nosql database which can be used to
store huge amount of data however
whenever a data is written in hbase it
is first returned to what we call as
write ahead log and also to mem store
which is
write cache now once the data is written
in wall and your mem store it is
offloaded to form an internal hbase
format file which is called h5 and
usually these edge files are very small
in nature so we also know that sdfs is
good when we talk about few number of
larger files in comparison to
large number of smaller files due to the
limitation of name node's memory
compaction is process of merging hbase
files that is the smaller edge files
into a single large file this is done to
reduce the amount of memory required to
store the files and number of disk seeks
needed so we could have lot of h files
which get created when the data is
written to hbase and these smaller files
can then be compacted through a major or
minor compaction creating one big edge
file which internally would then be
written to sdfs and sdfs format of
blocks that is the benefit of compaction
there is also a feature called bloom
filter so how does bloom filter work so
bloom filter or hbase bloom filter is a
mechanism to test whether a h file
contains a specific row or a row column
cell bloom filter is named after its
creator burton harvard bloom it is a
data structure which predicts whether a
given element is a member of a set of
data it provides an in-memory index
structure that reduces the disk reads
and determines the probability of
finding a row in a particular file this
is one of very useful features of edge
base which allows for faster access and
avoids disk seeks
does hbase have any concept of name
space so namespace is when you have
similar elements grouped together so
namespace yes hbase supports namespace
so namespace is a logical grouping of
tables analogous to a database in rdbms
so you can create hbs namespace to the
schema of rdbms database so you could
create a namespace by saying create
namespace and giving it a name and then
you could also list the tables within a
namespace you could create tables within
a specific namespace now this is usually
done in production environment where a
cluster might be multi-tenant cluster
and there might be different users of
the same nosql database in that case
admin would create specific namespace
and for specific namespace you would
have different directories on sdfs and
users of a particular business unit or a
team can work on their hbase objects
within a specific name space this is a
question which is again very important
to understand about the rights or reads
so how does right ahead log wall help
when a region server crashes now as i
said when a write happens it will happen
into mem store and wall that is your
edit log or write a headlock so whenever
a write happens it will happen in two
places mem store which is the right
cache and wall which is a edit log only
when the data is written in both these
places and based on the limitation of
mem store the data will be flushed to
create an edge-based format file called
h-file these files are then compacted
and created into one bigger file which
will then be stored on sdfs and sdfs
data as we know is stored in the form of
blocks on the underlying data nodes so
if a region server hosting a mem store
crashes now where is region server
running that would be co-located with
data node so if a data node crashes or
if a region server which was hosting the
mem store write cache crashes data in
memory the data that in memory which was
not persisted is lost now how does hbase
recover from this as i said your data is
written into wall and mem store at the
same time hbase recovers against that by
writing to wall before the write
completes so whenever a write happens it
happens in mem store and wall at the
same time hbase cluster keeps a wall to
record changes as they happen and that's
why we call it as also an edit log if
hbase goes down or the node that goes
down the data that was not flushed from
mem store to edge file can be recovered
by replaying the right ahead lock and
that's the benefit of your edit log or
write a headlock now if we would have to
write hbase command to list the contents
and update the column families of a
table i could just do a scan and that
would give me complete data of a table
if you are very specific and if you
would want to look at a particular row
then you could do a get table name and
then give the row key however you could
do a scan to get the complete data of a
particular table you could also do a
describe to see what are the different
column families and if you would want to
alter the table and add a new column
family it is very simple you can just
say alt give the hbase table name and
then give you a new column family name
which will then be added to the table
what are catalog tables in hbase so as i
mentioned your zookeeper knows the
location of this internal catalog table
or what we call as the meta table now
catalog tables in edge base have two
tables one is edge based meta table and
one is hyphen root the catalog table
edge base meta exists as an edge base
table and is filtered out of hbase
shells list command so if i give a list
command on edge base it would list all
the tables which base contains but not
the meta table it's an internal table
this meta table keeps a list of all
regions in the system and location of
hbase meta stored in zookeeper so if
somebody wants to find out or look for
particular rows they need to know the
regions which contain that data and
those regions are located on region
server to get all this information one
has to look into this meta table however
we will not be looking into meta table
directly we would just be giving a write
or a read operation internally uh based
master queries the zookeeper zookeeper
has the information of where the meta
table exists and that meta table which
is existing on region server contains
information of row keys and the region
servers where those rows can be found
your root table keeps a track of
location of the meta table what is hot
spotting in edge base and how to avoid
hot spotting now this is a common
problem and always admin guys or guys
who are managing the infrastructure
would think about it so one of the main
idea is that edge base would be
leveraging the benefit of sdfs your all
read and write requests should be
uniformly distributed across all of the
regions in region servers otherwise
what's the benefit of having a
distributed cluster so you would have
your data stored across region servers
in the form of regions which are
horizontal partitions of the table and
whenever read and write requests happen
they should be uniformly distributed
across all the regions in the region
servers now hot spotting occurs when a
given region serviced by a region server
receives most or all of read write
request which is basically a unbalanced
way of read write operations now hotspot
can be avoided by designing the row key
in such a way that data being written
should go to multiple regions across the
cluster so you could do techniques such
as salting hashing reversing the key and
many other techniques which are employed
by users of hbase we need to just make
sure that when the regions are
distributed across region servers they
should be spread across region servers
so that your read and write request can
be satisfied from different region
servers in parallel rather than all read
and write request hitting the same
region server overloading the region
server which may also lead to the
crashing of a particular region server
so these were some of the important
questions of hbase and then there are
many more please refer to the link which
i specified in during my discussion and
that gives you a detailed explanation of
how each base works you can also look
into hp's definitive guide by o'reilly
or hbase in action and these are really
good books to understand about hbase
internals and how it works now that we
have learnt on hive which is a data
warehousing package we have learnt on
pig which is a scripting or a scripting
language which allows you to do data
analysis and we have learned some
questions on a nosql database just note
it that there are more than 225 nosql
databases existing in market and if you
would want to learn and know about more
nosql databases you can just go to
google and type no sql databases
org and that will take you to the link
which is for nosql databases and this
shows there are more than 225
nosql databases existing in market and
these are for different use cases used
by different users and for with
different features so have a look at
this link now when you talk about data
ingestion so let's look at data
ingestion and this is one good link
which i would suggest to have a look at
which lists down around 18 different
ingestion tools so when you talk about
different data injection tools some are
for structured data some are for
streaming data some are for data
governance some are for data ingestion
and transformation and so on so have a
look at this link which also gives you a
comparison of different data ingestion
tools so here let's learn about some
questions on scope which is one of the
data injection tools mainly used for
structured data or you could say data
which is coming in from rdbms or data
which is already structured and you
would want to ingest that you would want
to store that on sdfs which could then
be used for hive which could be used for
any kind of processing using mapreduce
or hive or pig or spark or any other
processing frameworks or you would want
to load that data into say high voltage
based tables scope is mainly for
structured data it is extensively used
when organizations are migrating from
rdbms to a big data platform and they
would be interested in ingesting the
data that is doing import and export of
data from rdbms to sdfs or vice versa so
let's learn about some important
questions on scope which you may be
asked by an interviewer when you apply
for a big data related position how is
scoop different from flow so this is a
very common question which is asked
scoop which is mainly for structured
data so scope works with rdbms it also
works with no sql databases to import
and export data so you can import data
into sdfs you can import data into data
browsing packets such as hive directly
or also in hbase and you could also
export data from hadoop ecosystem to
your rdbms however when it comes to flow
flow is
more of
a data injection tool which works with
streaming data or unstructured data so
data which is constantly getting
generated for example log files or
metrics from server or some chat
messenger and so on so if you are
interested in working on capturing and
storing the streaming data in a storage
layer such as sdfs or hbase you could be
using flue there could be other tools
also like kafka or storm or chokwa or
samsa nifi and so on scoop however is
mainly for structured data your loading
data in scope is not event driven so it
is not based on event it basically works
on data which is already stored in rdbms
in terms of flume it is completely event
driven that is as the messages or as the
events happen as the data is getting
generated you can have that data
ingested using flow scope works with
structured data sources and you have
various scope connectors which are used
to fetch data from external data
structures or rdbms so for every rdbms
such as mysql oracle db2 microsoft sql
server you have different connectors
which are available flume it works on
fetching streaming data such as tweets
or log files or server metrics from your
different sources where the data is
getting generated and if you are
interested in not only ingesting that
data which is getting generated in a
streaming fashion but if you would be
interested in processing the data as it
arrives scoop can import data from rdbms
onto sdfs and also export it back to
rdbms flume is
then used for streaming data now you
could have one to one one too many or
many to one kind of relation so in terms
of floom you have components such as
your source sync and channel that's the
main difference between your scope and
flow what are the different file formats
to import data using scope well there
are lots and lots of formats in which
you can import data into scope when you
talk about scope you can have delimited
text file format now that's the default
import format it can be specified
explicitly using as text file argument
so when i want to import data from an
rdbms i could get that data in sdfs
using different compression schemes or
in different formats using the specific
arguments so i could specify an argument
which will write string based
representation of each record to output
files with delimiters between individual
columns and rows so that is the default
format which is used to import data
using scope so to learn more about your
scope and different arguments which are
available you can click on
scoop.apache.org
you can look into the documentation and
i would suggest choosing one of the
versions and looking into the user guide
and here you can search for arguments
and look for specific control arguments
which show how you can import data using
scope so here we have common arguments
and then you also have import control
arguments wherein we have different
options like getting data as avro as
sequence file as text file or par k file
these are different formats you can also
get data in default compression scheme
that is gzip or you can specify
compression codec and then you can
specify what compression mechanism you
would want to use when you are importing
your data using scope when it comes to
default format for flume we could say
sequence file which is a binary format
that stores individual records in record
specific data types so these data types
are manifested as java classes and scope
will automatically generate these data
types for you so scoop does that when we
talk about your sequence file format in
terms of your scoop you could be
extracting storage of all data in binary
representation so as i mentioned you can
import data in different formats such as
avro parquet sequence file that is
binary format or machine readable format
and then you could also have data in
different compression schemes let me
just show you some quick examples here
so if i look in
the content and here i could search for
a scoop based file where i have listed
down some examples so if i would want to
use different compression schemes here
are some examples have a look at these
so i'm doing a scoop import i'm also
giving an argument so that scope which
also triggers a map reduced job or i
would say map only job so when you run a
scoop import it triggers a map only job
no reduce happens here and you could
specify this parameter or this argument
on the command line
mapreduce.framework.name
so that you could run your map only job
in a local mode to save time or that
would interact with yarn and run a
full-fledged map only job we can give
the connection and then connect to
whatever rdbms we are connecting
mentioning the database name give your
username and password give the table
name give a target directory or it would
create a directory same as the table
name which would work only once and then
i could say minus z to get data in a
compressed format that is gzip or i
could be specifying compression codec
and then i could specify what
compression codec i would want to use
say snappy b z
default i could also run a query by
giving a scope import and when i'm
specifying a query if you notice i'm not
given any table name because that would
be included in the query i can get my
data as a sequence file format which is
a binary format which will create a huge
file so we could also have compression
enabled and then i could say the output
of my map job should use a compression
at record level for my data coming in
sequence file so sequence file or a
binary format supports compression at
record level or at block level i could
get my data in an avro file where data
has embedded schema within the file or a
par k file also so these are different
ways in which you can set up different
compression schemes or you can even get
data in different formats and you could
be doing a simple scope import for these
looking further what is the importance
of eval tool in scope so there is
something called as eval tool so scoop
eval tool allows users to execute user
defined queries against respective
database servers and preview the result
in the console so either i could be
running a straight away query to import
the data into my sdfs or i could just
use scoop eval connect to my external
rdbms specify my username and password
and then i could be giving in a query to
see what would be the result of the
query which we intend to import now
let's learn about how scope imports and
exports data between rdbms and
its architecture so rdbms as we know has
your database structures your tables
which all of them are logical and
internally there is always metadata
which is stored your scope import
connects to an external rdbms and for
this connection it uses an internal
connector jar file which has a driver
class so that's something which needs to
be set up by admin but they need to make
sure that whichever rdbms you intend to
connect to they need to have the jdbc
connector for that particular rdbms
stored within the scope lib folder so
scope import gets the metadata and then
for your scoop command it converts that
into a map only job which might have one
or multiple map tasks
now that depends on your scoop command
you could be specifying that you would
want to do a import only in one task or
in multiple tasks these multiple map
tasks will then run on a section of data
from rdbms and then store it in sdfs
so at high level we could say scoop will
introspect database to get gathered the
metadata it divides the input data set
into splits and this division of data
into splits mainly happens on primary
key column of the table now if somebody
might ask what if my table in rdbms does
not have a primary key column then when
you are doing a scope import either you
will have to import it using one mapper
task by specifying hyphen hyphen
m equals one or you would have to say
split by parameter to specify a numeric
column from rdbms and that's how you can
import the data let me just show you a
quick example on this so i could just
look in again into the scoop command
file and here we could be looking at an
example so if you see this one here we
are specifying minus minus m equals 1
which basically means i would want to
import the data using one map task now
in this case whether the table has a
primary key column or does not have a
primary key column will not matter but
if i say a minus minus ms6 where i am
specifying multiple map tasks to be
imported then this will look for a
primary key column in the table which
you are importing now if the table does
not have a primary key column then i
could be specifying a split by and then
specify the column so that the data
could be split into multiple chunks and
multiple map tasks could take it
now if the second scenario is your table
does not have a primary key column and
it does not have a numeric column on
which you could do a split by in that
case and if you would want to use
multiple mappers you could still say
split by on a textual column but you
will have to add this property so that
it allows splitting the data which is
non-numeric all of these options are
given in the scoop apache.org link going
further how scoop imports and exports
data between rdbms and sdfs with its
architecture so as i said it submits the
map only job to the cluster and then it
basically does a import or export so if
we are exporting the data from sdfs in
that case again there would be a map
only job it would look at multiple
splits of the data which is existing
which your map only job would process
through one or one table map task and
then export it to rdbms suppose you have
a database testdb in mysql we if
somebody asked you to write a command to
connect this database and import tables
to scoop so here is a quick example as i
showed you in the command file so you
could say scoop import this is what we
would want to do you connect using jdbc
now this will only work if the jdbc
connector already exists within your
scope lib directory admin has to set up
that so you can connect to your rdbms
you can point to the database so
here our database name is test
underscore db i could give user name and
then either i could give password on the
command line or just say capital p so
that i could be prompted for the
password and then i could give the table
name which i would want to import i
could also be specifying minus minus m
and specify how many map tasks do i want
to use for this import as i showed in
previous screen how to export a table
back to rdbms now for this we need the
data in a directory on hdfs so for
example there is a department's table in
retail database which is already
imported into scoop and you need to
export this table back to rdbms so this
is the content of the table now create a
new department table in rdbms so i could
create a table specifying the column
names whether that supports null or no
if that has a primary key column which
is always recommended and then i can do
a scope export i can connect to the
rdbms specifying my username and
password specify the table into which
you want to export the data and then you
give export directory pointing to a
directory on htfs which contains the
data this is how you can export data
into table seeing example on this so i
could again look into my file and here i
have an example of import this is where
you are importing data directly into
hive and you have scope import where you
are importing data directly into hbase
table and you can then query your hbase
table to look at the data you could also
do a export by running your map only job
in a local mode connecting to the rdbms
specifying your username specifying the
table where you would want to export and
the directory on sdfs where you have
kept the relevant data this is a simple
example of export looking further
what is the role of jdbc driver in scoop
setup so as i said if you would want to
use scoop to connect to an external
rdbms we need the jdbc odbc connector
jar file now one or admin could download
the jdbc connector jar file and then
place the jar file within the scoop lib
directory wherever scoop is installed
and this jdbc connector jar file
contains a driver now jdbc driver is a
standard java api which is used for
accessing different databases in rdbms
so this connector jar file is very much
required and this connector jar file has
a driver class
and this driver class enables the
connection between your rdbms and your
hadoop structure each database vendor is
responsible for writing their own
implementation that will allow
communication with the corresponding
database and we need to download the
drivers which allow our scope to connect
to external rdbms so your jdbc driver
alone is not enough to connect to scope
we also need connectors to interact with
different database so a connector is a
plugable piece that is used to fetch
metadata and allow scoop to overcome the
differences in sql dialects so this is
how connection can be established so
normally your admins would when they are
setting up scope and hadoop they would
download
say mysql jdbc connector and this is how
they would go to the mysql connectors if
you are connecting to mysql similarly
for your other rdbms you could be say
going in here
you could be looking for a previous
version depending you could be going for
platform independent and then you could
be downloading the connected jar file
now if you enter this jar file you would
see a mysql connector jar and if we look
in com.mysql.jdbcom.mysql.jdbc.driver
so this is the package which is within
the connector jar file and this
has the driver class which allows the
connection of your scope with your rdbms
so these things will have to be done by
your admin so that you can have your
scope connecting to an external rdbms
now how do you update the columns that
are already exported so if i do a export
and i put my data in rdbms can i really
update the columns that are already
exported yes i can using a update key
parameter so scoop export command
remains the same the only thing i will
have to specify now is the table name
your fields terminated by if you have a
specific delimiter and then you can say
update key and then the column name so
this allows us to update the columns
that are already exported in rdbms
what is code gen so scope commands
translate into your mapreduce job or map
only job so code gen is basically a tool
in scope that generates data access
objects dao java classes that
encapsulate and interpret imported
records so if i do a scoop code gen
connect to an rdbms using my username
and give a table this will generate a
java code for employee table in the test
database so this code gen can be useful
for us to understand what data we have
in this particular table finally can
scoop be used to convert data in
different formats i think i already
answered that right if no which tools
can be used for this purpose so scope
can be used to convert data in different
formats and that depends on the
different arguments which you use when
you do a import such as avro file
parquet file binary format with record
or block level compression so if you are
interested in knowing more on different
data formats then i think i can suggest
a link for that and we can say hadoop
formats
i think it is tech
maggie avro
parque let's see you can find out the
link tech mac e
yeah this is a very good link which
specifies or talks about different data
formats which you should know such as
your text file format different
compression schemes how is data
organization what are the common formats
what do you have in text file structured
binary sequence files with compression
without compression what is record level
what is block level what is a avro data
file what is a secret what is a
parquet data file or a columnar format
and other formats like orc rc and so on
so please have a look at this link thank
you all for watching this live session
on how to full course 2022 video by
simply lot i hope it was useful and
informative if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you